i should have my speaker on i gotta
remember to turn that on
okay um
we got a busy day we got about 150
people that signed up uh in support of
the constitutional amendment we're doing
at 3 30.
now if at any time during the day you
have to get up and go testify like at 3
30 i have to introduce a bill next door
i'll turn the gavel over to
representative moffat
and then i'll quietly walk out so when
you come back in just quietly
walk in and you know
uh take your seats there and uh
you know for any of the hearings
um
if we have a lot of people coming in
you're going to hear me say that um
you know
bring it down to three minutes and then
if it's repetitious we don't want to
hear it if you have anything new to add
you know what i mean so that way there
we're not being the same thing over and
over and over
okay
before we get started any questions or
anything uh
okay
uh if phyllis katzesaurus comes i'm
hoping she's gonna be here
there's a bill that uh ben berube who's
a long time friend of mine
and it killed me to tell him that i'm
not going to reschedule his bill
because it's a resolution and i don't
think i should bring you all in just for
one bill
you know i mean so what we'll do is
we'll have somebody if if phyllis isn't
here we'll have somebody introduce the
bill
you know and if you have somebody on
your side that wants to introduce it we
can do that
okay we'll adjust from there but to
bring everybody in for that one
resolution
it's just and it's too late for me to
put it on the schedule for tomorrow
wait a minute i wonder if i could recess
to tomorrow
i have to think about this i might be
able to recess it i don't know
i think you can
yeah
yeah one bill tomorrow
but normally you know we schedule you
know got to be in the calendar
so i'll have to find out if i can
you ready
i'm going to open up the hearing on
fort house bill 1411 relative to the
transparency of federal agency
operations within new hampshire
and i'll introduce the uh sponsor is
representative forrest
fossa
welcome
thank you mr
chairman for the record i'm
representative william foster from
hillsborough five which is the towns of
new boston and mount vernon
i'm here today to
introduce house bill 1411 which is
relative to the to transparency of
federal
agency operations within new hampshire
in speaking with voters in my district
many had questions about the authority
and level of activity of our federal
agencies in our state
upon investigating this
i made several interesting discoveries
some of which i was unaware of
these investigations led to the
development of hb 1411
i personally was surprised to find out
that there are currently 73 federal
agencies employing full-time law
enforcement officers
in the united states and these
officers are authorized by law to
perform four specific functions
conduct criminal criminal investigations
execute search warrants including no
knock warrants make arrests
and carry firearms
when i began to look into these agencies
to which of these agencies were
operating in new hampshire and to what
extent
they were performing these functions i
was surprised again at what i found
agencies of the federal government are
under no obligation to provide any
transparency of their past present or
future
presence or activities to citizens of
any state
while the most while most active
agencies
in a state in the spirit of cooperation
develop relationships
and share to some degree this
information with the state
and even local law enforcement officials
it is voluntary
and only to the level they wish to
this lack of transparency leads to a
lack of knowledge and understanding in
regards to the president activities
the presence and activities of the
federal government agencies in our state
this in turn leads to fear speculation
and
misunderstanding fb
1411 seeks to improve this transparency
in a safe and voluntary way
it has the ag's office request
non-identifying and historic data
relating to the presence and level of
activities of these agencies during the
previous month or year
on a monthly basis
this data is then compiled and put into
a single location on the state doj
public website
i believe by increasing transparency and
public awareness
in an easy to access location we have an
opportunity to reduce speculation and
misinformation and improve the pro the
public's trust
i hope that these agencies will see this
as an opportunity to improve and define
their public image and improve the state
and federal relations
in the state of new hampshire
i ask your support in moving this bill
out of committee otp
okay thank you representative i take it
you will take questions oh yes
okay um representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um i teach at keene state
college
and
one concern we've had is that federal
agents from ice
can
sometimes come on the campus and request
or
really demand off sometimes with a
warrant sometimes not
to get information on international
students
um
and
uh you know they'll walk into say the
admissions office or the registrar's
office and with ice jackets on saying we
want information on these students
um
and you have a secretary or
administrative assistant
there it's it's very intimidating i uh
and we're trying to develop some
protocols because
there should be a warrant and there
should be a specific type of warrant in
order to get that information sometimes
there is sometimes there isn't you have
a person sitting at a front desk
is this the type of thing would your
bill then
help alert us
that ice agents are on the ground trying
to collect information
and that we should be prepared to ask
certain questions or refer them to
university council
in reality no because
uh what this will do
is it will
allow you to look and see to what level
they have done it
the questions that that are asked and
that are written in this bill
generally refer to what they did in the
previous month
um and and this is in regards to
operational security for federal
agencies it would be very difficult for
a state to say hey we would like to know
what you're going to be doing because
that affects their ability to operate
and and we don't have the authority to
do that they have the authority to
operate in the state
what this does is it
provides transparency in what in who's
it about who is in the state and what
they have been doing so that we can look
and see the levels of of activity within
the state over a year period um right
now that data is collected across
you can get the data some of it if you
go to
the websites of those agencies and and
see hey are you operating in our state a
lot of times you would actually have to
write letters to them and as uh
civilians you may or may not get an
answer because they're under no
obligation to tell you
this is the ag asking them to
voluntarily
give us some of this data that is not
dangerous to their operational security
so that we can have a running tally of
what what they're actually doing so it's
just a matter of increasing transparency
in public awareness
and giving us something that we can look
at and say this is what's been happening
in our state and we can we can take
different actions we could possibly um
talk to the federal congressional
uh delegation and see if they could you
know if we had concerns and see if they
could address those at the federal level
there's very little we can do at the
state level
when it comes to federal operations
and thank you representative for taking
my question
in your bill you include the total
number of federal foreign refugee
relocations in new hampshire year to
date
updated monthly the first question i
have is why did you include that
um it's just a data point to see because
when when they are
when they are bringing refugees into the
state there is different federal
activities the transportation a bunch of
different activities and all this is
doing is keeping track of the level of
that activity um
and and so that was included in there
it's
um it actually is is public knowledge if
you
can hit the right websites and the right
agencies that are doing it this just
allows someone
to look at that and see it
in one spot that's awesome
thank you for the question thank you mr
chair
so do you expect the locations to change
monthly is that why you're having it
updated monthly
the locations yeah because you said no
that will probably end up being static
data within the database
but if they if they um
add locations or add um
facilities then that would be recorded
at that point
the additions more than anything else or
the subtractions if they leave
okay thank you
okay uh representative moffitt you had a
question
thank you mr thank you representative
for taking my question and uh so i
noticed the way this is worded it
asks that the federal agencies
voluntarily verify an update if they
don't do that there's i don't see any
enforcement or mechanism
we don't have the authority well thank
you
thank you for the question we don't have
the authority to
do any kind of enforcement on the
federal agencies what we can do is we
can ask them for the information if they
don't provide the information we can say
they chose not to provide the
information if they do that over a long
enough period of time
the question may come up as to why
they're not providing information
right now we don't have any of that so
this gives us just a little bit it gives
us as much as i could
but like i said we are very limited as
to what we can do at a state level
uh understood thank you and a follow-up
so if an fbi if the fbi is conducting a
uh
some um
investigation of uh say
border violations or
whatever they would be doing here
uh
would i suspect they would have concerns
about opsec operational security and and
would be very reticent to share
who's here doing what is it is that a
fair concern that that
that they would have
about
this measure well as far as a fair
concern over operational security yeah i
with with my uh
with with the units that i served with
in the air force and
i understand operational security
very well and how a little teeny bit of
information can actually damage the
ability of an agency or organization to
get their job done
so when i did this um
if you look in the wording it basically
is trying to say things that they've
completed not ongoing investigations
it's not i'm not trying to target
anything they are doing because in doing
that it would
compromise their investigation so if
this is just a matter of
what have you completed
because i don't see any any uh
any
danger to their operational security by
asking them what they've completed
thank you
okay before i go to representative
one of the things we talked about
earlier was the date
uh there will be an amendment on this
here to change the date from july to
probably january i believe 2023 uh
is that what your plan was uh thank you
mr chairman i my plan was to just do
something like a 60 days after uh
passage
that way
my recommendations here would be to do
something like a january or 2023. okay i
could do that give them an ample enough
time because you don't know
what type of software is this a mandate
or
you know do they have to bring up a new
website for this here or what design
something
we don't know
and there's nobody here from federal
government you know to come in to
testify on this so something to keep in
mind that's why we try to put it out to
give them the opportunity
okay uh representative
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
uh representative for taking my question
i just had one question um are federal
agencies so when the attorney general of
the state of new hampshire solicits and
they you know request this information
to be published on the website are the
federal agencies required is it like an
all or nothing are they required to give
all this information or if they choose
not to give all of it then they can't
give it all or could they just pick and
choose you know which information that
they do give well they actually could
pick and choose it's nine data points if
uh they give you the data point you
write down what data they gave you and
if they don't then you write down that
they didn't you know that they didn't uh
provide you with any data could i have a
follow-up mr chairman thank you mr
chairman uh just just another question
then because you know this is the point
that i'm trying to lead to is so so so
federal agencies will have a certain
amount of discretion over what
information if they choose to provide
what information they give so then it
protects their agency's ability to
operate
and it can protect the public interest
of them being able to operate on behalf
of the public or to provide as much
information as they like so they can
have as much transparency and you know
also uh fulfill that duty to the public
too correct oh absolutely yes thank you
for the question they they they would be
able to um withhold information that
they felt was uh you know a threat to
their their operational security
but could provide information
that that would let people know what
they're doing because sometimes what
they're often what they're doing in our
state is very good things and
even that would be a positive awareness
so this would allow us to to hopefully
um improve the uh the federal and state
relations
okay um
thank you representative i mean i i like
to build but i'm not sure whether we can
hold um the federal government you know
i mean in this here because i wish there
was somebody that came in the testify on
this year
so even if we moved it over the senate
hopefully somebody from this you know
that will testify in the senate if they
see that we're serious
and want information there now represent
you had a great question there about at
the colleges there and i know there was
an issue somewhere out in california or
argonne where they were doing the same
thing
but it came out that
the um
the elected officials were telling
people to leave
knowing they broke the law
before the knowing that they were coming
in it's illegal
you know to really do that um so it's
that's why i
i relate what you said there but i
believe this happened in other states
okay are there any other questions
okay thank you representative fossum
thank you
does anyone else want to speak on this
here or at all uh okay with that i'm
going to close the hearing
on 1411
and you're going to uh you what to do is
i guess the only
anyone recommend any changes on this
here at all or amendment he's going to
do amendment to change the date
yes
uh i did have an amendment to strike one
of the lines of
the refugee resettlement
and i will hand that out uh oh you
already have one yep
okay what to do is no hold on we're not
gonna execute it yet hold on to that
amendment okay when we execute the bill
then you can pass it out
okay okay uh and that his will be a
separate amendment and then you do your
amendment on the date okay
thank you
all right thanks
okay we got an 11
uh 9 30 next
one let me see 9 30 yeah 9 30.
now
representative phillips cancer source is
not here yet
so if we have somebody on your side they
want to introduce that bill um hcr 6 at
9 30.
mr chairman have a question yes
i see we have a very substantial amount
of time for hcr 6.
are there a lot of people expected to um
to speak on it
no that was a probably a screw-up on me
i'm not scared of saying i'm not perfect
yeah
no no i don't care yeah
yeah no i um i don't know why that
happened 9 30. yeah that's a fig
the last time the last time that bill
came here i had about 30 people come in
and you know i mean and testify and um
representative there was a
representative of manchester uh tommy um
what was his name you remember linda
um
good guy there and pushed it i actually
supported the last time
you know on the bill they had to move it
forward for him but it didn't get
anywhere on the house floor
uh but can we fit anything else in there
uh no i can't i mean i can
if we
wait i don't know if we can exactly yeah
we can uh i
what i can do is uh once we find out if
you're all on board with 1505 we have
the amendment
i can execute that bill after that we
can knock that out
uh that's on the veterans
establish a concurrent jurisdiction in
juvenile matters with the u.s department
of defense
so once you've been uh representing
maxwell you tell me you're on board with
that i'll move that forward
okay uh in that time we'll kill it there
i'm gonna go see if i can find him
okay all right you want me sitting with
you and help you out
okay uh and then whatever else we have
if he gets the amendment on this other
one if you're on board with this bill
then we'll move that one forward too
well
yeah
right yeah we can do that one too and we
have the you have the amendment done on
14. okay good so had that one ready to
be passed out then
and
and then that would make it easier
tomorrow you get out earlier you know
less less bills we got to exact
okay so we got a few minutes so
okay
i'm going to open up the hearing on hci6
and it's a resolution urgent at the
united kingdom return of parthian elgin
marbles to greece
and our
representative
for uh hello committee my name is
representative manny espithi i'm here to
introduce hcr 6 which would urge the
united kingdom to return the parthenon
uh
slash the elgin marbles to greece um
yeah i think it's in the name so uh with
that i'll
end my testimony okay
i don't know if ben uh representative
ben berube is gonna is here
i mean i know he's not here but i'm
saying what i will do for representative
ruby
is when we execute this bill i'm not
gonna execute today i'm going to let him
know
that i will give him an opportunity
during our executive session to say a
few words out of respect for i've known
berube a long time he's a very honorable
guy so i will let him say a few words on
this bill to explain
everything you know to the uh to you all
on it
yes representatives
can you check with him and see if he can
be here tomorrow and i will give him the
opportunity to introduce his amendment
and i will let him speak to the
committee which we normally don't do but
it's up to the chairman to do mr chair
can i ask a question yeah well he
probably wouldn't know
do i do you do you don't have any
written
no he oh yeah okay i just wanted to make
sure i asked him to open up the bills
you know that way there i don't have to
bring these in another day but but like
i said out of respect for representative
rudy we will give him that opportunity
so you'll be able to check with him
okay
all right with that i'm gonna close the
hearing on
uh hcr6 and it's 9 34. yeah okay
yeah wait we're going to uh
exec 15 yeah let me take a look at some
bills that we have that maybe will exact
one uh let's say 20
does anyone need a copy of uh should i
ask them about 1505 what's that yeah
yeah on 1505 do you all have that
amendment
i don't have the 1505 amendment
i don't have an amendment to it um
i have a copy if you want to make copies
of it i'll make copies okay
you don't have one
who else needs copies
for
who needs a copy of the amendment for
1505.
do you have a copy
of the amendment we all have projects
except for a representative
yeah i think that would be fair for um
representative rudy to be able to
go
he would have done the same thing for me
if he when he was a chair
i'm going to open up the hearing on hb
an act establishing concurrent
jurisdiction in juvenile matters with
the u.s department of defense for
coordination with the military family
advocacy program
and i am going to introduce amendment
2022-0
as ought to pass
linda met me
and then massabella
linda
okay and
al you did who seconded that uh
representative thank you
okay and the amendment is what we
discussed here in the committee that we
all made some you know that make the
changes on the uh the actual bill
um
let me see what we did here
this is a pretty good um
you know amendment here for those that
don't know we do have a military school
compact
uh that we passed a few years ago and it
helps out with veterans that moved in
here to the state to get stationed here
and when their kids go into the schools
if their football games are being
already established baseball that they
able to get on those teams if they
played in other schools
because a lot of times the militaries
move
they try to move them during the summer
but it don't happen like my kids for 22
years always moved during the school
years so they've always showed up when i
moved here to
that brought them here to new hampshire
they turned around and
you know they were like two months they
were bored here in new hampshire because
they went to
military schools throughout the country
so a little more advanced in the you
know their education
so uh and it's very important for these
military kids that we make sure that
they're
not pushed aside when they come in so
it's just a fair game that's all
okay anyone else want to talk on the
amendment
yes
thank you mr yeah i think it's a good
amendment i think it fixes all the
issues and it really it changes the name
which i think was one of the things he
wanted so i think i think it's a great
amendment and uh for a great bill
all right thank you okay um without no
further delay i'm going to ask the clerk
to
take the roll call
on amendment
2022-0115-h
all right representative moffitt yes on
the amendment
a representative
delanus
sorry representative rollins sorry to
say
sure
yes
okay on the amendment yes
um
representative foster yes on the
amendment
representative
is not here
he's busy
um
representative massimilia yes on the
amendment okay
representative piedra
wilhelm
not here oh he's not here pardon me
representative espica
yes
representative owen griffiths is not
here either
representative toll
yes
uh representative of the branch
representative welkowitz
yes
and have i missed anyone yes
always representative baldassaro yes
what's the vote
the best
i'm going to make the motion not to pass
this amendment but i will give somebody
else an opportunity
if you want to write a blurb on this
here to put your name in history rather
because i don't like it always be me but
um but i you know i write a lot of them
it should be shared of wealth but i'll
do it
after
so if nobody else wants to make that
motion then i will
make the motion then
okay i'll make the motion as uh ought to
pass
as amended on house bill 1505
and
is there a second
what's that got
you got that rep mastermill a second
yeah just
yep let's see
okay
and i
will speak here um this basically is on
which we're all familiar is on juvenile
matters
you know that get reported to the
department of defense and depending uh
on the you know the issues are going on
at the basin really
and uh a lot of times if there's kids
with problems that are out of town
you know the dod needs to want to know
if there's any you know problems with
the
active duty or military kids that are
here within the communities and stuff so
it's a pretty good compact
uh you know advocacy program there
anyone else want to speak on
you know okay with that i
will ask the
clerk to um take a roll call on ought to
pass as amendment
amendment 2022-0115
which is establishment concur in
jurisdiction in juvenile matters with
the u.s department of defense for
coordination with the military families
family advocacy program
okay
representative moffitt
yes on otpa
representative katz chorus yes
representative rollins yes
representative delemus yes
representative williams uh foster sorry
yes
and representative deshay is still not
with us
uh representative massimila yes
representative piedra yeah
representative espikia yes
representative told
representative lebranch yes
and representative
yes
and representative baldassaros yes
wow 12 years
12 to 0. uh any objection on the consent
calendar
okay consent calendar
and i'll i'll write the blood okay
with that i'll close
house bill 1505
let's see is there any other
eights we're not going to touch her six
11 40 14 11 we don't have the amendment
on that do
we oh that's one we're going to wait
till tomorrow just regard that
okay
was there anything else
on the other bills
see i'm beefing
is
i'm going to open up the executive
session on
house bill 1441
which is establishing the commission to
organize the observance of the 250th
anniversary of the declaration of
independence
and i am representative the says you
have a motion on an amendment
yeah and um i'd like to
motion
uh we adopt the amendment for house bill
1441. i think that's what i'd say
correct mr chairman okay thank you
fellas representative
has a motion to adopt 2022-014
h
and you want to speak to your motion
uh do i need a second mr chair um do we
have a second
representative massimilia
good question
actually a second by uh mason is not
required but i always oh okay i didn't i
didn't i didn't realize that but i'm
saying i always do a second but you're
right
but go ahead you can speak to your
motion yeah of course um so the the
amendment in front of us today to uh
house bill 1441 2022-01
it would essentially amend the bill to
uh to exactly replicate uh 2007's senate
bill 221.
that was a suggestion by representative
wall who actually introduced that uh
legislation back in 2007
establishing a commission to organize
events in celebration of the abraham
lincoln bicentennial so um some of the
some of the basic changes is the makeup
to the commission
i decided to make it so then there would
be one person from the senate appointed
by the senate president one from the
minority one from the majority caucus um
from the house appointed by the speaker
one from the majority one from the
minority office um
we we left in the native american
affairs chair of their designee and we
then added the state veterans council um
as established and rsa 110-b colon 89 or
their designee that was in you know an
agreement that was came up with with the
majority caucus and the minority caucus
of the committee we also um changed
instead of having it so the board of
trustees of the college system and the
community college system we changed it
so then it would be the chancellor of
the university system or the community
college system because that's what it
had in uh and the formerly uh lincoln
the abraham lincoln bicentennial
commission right so then instead of
having the board of trustees meet and
have to appoint someone having the
chancellor has already been appointed to
you know basically run these
institutions have them or a designee do
it would make more sense and you know
saves everyone time
so that's kind of the change of the the
makeup and it would be 15 people on the
committee we also changed a little bit
of what the duties were i made them a
little bit more precise and more in line
with what historically has been done
with commissions like this
for example like the abraham lincoln
bicentennial
one thing that we added that isn't in
senate bill 221 that's going to be in
this legislation is making sure that
there's a publicly noticized and
publicized event for july 4th 2026. um
that wasn't a requirement in the abraham
lincoln bicentennial i think it's
important for requirement in this that
we have a specific day of when a
celebration will take place and when uh
in that the public is notified and told
about it and then one last thing that
some people had asked about that even
olas had asked about and i had to
explain to them based on what uh
representative wall explained to me is
the uh the trust fund that was
established this wasn't done in the
previous bill this was done though in
the abraham lincoln bicentennial uh
purpose of this is so then there can be
a certain amount of funds if the finance
committee chooses in future budget uh
you know future budgets to put some
money aside or so the state can solicit
donations the commission can solicit
donations from organizations you know
within the state and across the country
or accept federal funds if federal funds
ever become available for helping states
the fund would be run by the by the
treasurer of the state and um it would
uh it would lapse into the general fund
any extra dollars in 2027 and um one
last thing to just clarify too is that
um
i believe we have the uh the
organization um and this is the same
this was one question i couldn't find
answered by representative wall
which is they meet this commission even
after the celebration that was something
the abraham lincoln bicentennial did too
why they did that i'm not sure i
couldn't get a hold of anyone who was on
that um on that committee i actually
think senator hassan might have been
involved so and when she was a state
senator then to give it some perspective
right so um
that might be for creating a final
report
um i'm not entirely sure but i know that
it could also just be because they said
well what if we couldn't have it on that
date and we need to reschedule for a
date in the future um i don't know but i
copied the exact how the lincoln abraham
lincoln bicentennial
how they established their commission it
worked it was successful they had a good
program i think you know we shouldn't
reinvent the wheel this amendment just
mocks that
thank you um
are there anyone else that want to speak
to the uh
representative
thank you uh
yeah no i think uh i think that probably
that final date to your point is
probably to debrief and probably come
out with the final report and like look
at oh how did this work out
um i'm wondering if they if the lincoln
um
uh memorial team like if they came out
with a report after um might be good to
guess maybe either our researcher to
look into but
um no i think this is a great amendment
i think let's not reinvent the wheel i
think this is this is the right way to
do this so
support it okay anything anyone else
okay with that i will ask the clerk to
make a do a roll call on
amendment to hb 14 41 202
okay
representative moffat
yes on the amendment okay
representative kat zaccharus yes
representative rollins yeah
representative delanus yes
representative foster yes
representative de check yes
representative messimilla yes
representative piedra
representative espica yes
representative
uh toll yeah representative le branch
yes
representative
yes and representative baldus yes
okay
okay uh representative uh
who's doing the uh blurb on this one
are you
who's doing the blurb on this is a
republican or democrat that wants to
make the motion
ought to pass as amended i'll make the
motion mr chairman okay
uh i'd like to motion um house bill 1441
ought to pass as amended
okay we have a motion to ought to pass
as amendment is there a second mass
miller
okay you got that clerk uh yeah all
right
i sure do
yes
give us a second to catch up
second
okay i have an amen i have a motion on
the floor ought to pass is amended
uh with as 2022-0148
h
uh is there any discussion
okay i'm going to add something to it
for the record
there was the emails that went around to
the whole committee this here was as
nonpartisan as nonpartisan gets
the only thing is it got a little bit
out of control because it went to the
whole committee which goes against the
91a because there's a quorum working on
legislation
so um
i complement representative walls and
representative horrigan
and being involved so what i did was to
cover if anyone wanted to see those
emails that went around under a 91 a
those emails representative de shays
brought them in
and we put them in the file
so that way they're we're in compliance
with the uh under 91a uh rules so i
wanted to put that out there uh for the
record
uh since there's no one else that's
going to speak
then i will ask the clerk to uh
take a roll call on ought to pass as
amended in house bill 1441. okay
uh representative moffitt
yes on otpa
representative yes representative
rollins yes representative delemus yes
representative foster yes representative
duchette yes representative noah yes
representative piedra yeah
representative
yes
and representative
yes all right
so 13 and 10. without objection uh we'll
put this on the consent calendar
okay consent calendar
okay i will close the hearing on 1441
and we'll be back in here at fort at 10
45 i think right are you going to do a
review 10 45 uh representative de chase
okay let me give you the paper i'll
write it down real quick all right i got
it yeah okay
10 45
all right thank you and we'll be back
again
well you got to keep track of it all you
know god bless you
linda that was one bill that was a great
team effort on you know between the uh
sponsor
and uh
that's what happens you get yourself all
set up and busy
well you're gonna have to ask the chair
about that phyllis we
thought a bunch of people testifying
we thought we'd bring the whole thing
okay so we have to be out of here by
midnight yeah
okay well i mean
i'm trying not to
it's a not an easy thing
and i'm done with 1505 i don't even know
why i have it
now
ah this is going to be tomorrow
that right there
okay and then you need to did you did i
give you the your sheet too
all right okay i'll write that out yeah
yeah no problem i'm not trying to bug
you about it i'm just trying to organize
and i believe whoa
we are
about to deal with hrc uh i mean hcr7
right
you know they think it's right of a grey
area
but you know
i get their perspective
oh wait a second right here right here
14 11
14 11.
okay that goes for my own file
and this is
that's hr6 mr chairman
one second i'm sending something to our
assistant
has your amendment come back down from
1411 for 1411 yet no ok
thank you
okay we're gonna get ready to start yeah
you had something quick
yeah
does a senator so how does it work when
it's a concurrent resolution because i
know the senate has rules for what they
permit what they don't permit to come
because i know they usually don't take
these unless they're probably to take
this because the gop wants it yeah oh
they're going to okay
that's what that okay that's that
clarification too yeah
no just don't ask yeah
i won't be asking yeah that's why i
asked you
they want them on record i know
okay
i'm going to open up the hearing on hcr
which is reaffirming support for the
nation of israel in the location of the
embassy of the united states
therein and the prime sponsor
representative spelaine welcome to the
committee
i'm here today to uh
present to you hcr 7. uh it's already
been read by the chair
this is a simple resolution but i think
it's an important and powerful statement
because at this time we have generations
who are forgetting history we have
institutions that are trying to rewrite
history
we have nations and people who are more
and more attacking the simple existence
of one of our most steadfast allies in a
region
of great upheaval
and as we recently saw in texas
terrorists are becoming more brazen
new hampshire should stand firm with
israel and tell the world that we
remember and we support our democratic
ally
and that's all i have
okay thank you you take questions from
the committee i will thank you any
questions for representatives colleen
representative miller
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um i'm just curious what precipitated
this bill as i mentioned we've got more
and more
statements from countries throughout the
the world and actions taking place
within our own borders that
are disturbing and
we have recently located the embassy uh
into jerusalem where it belongs and uh
there are many many people trying now to
fight to not only tear down israel
itself but to
remove the capital and remove the
embassy
thank you
representative
uh my question and thank you chairman
for letting me ask a question uh why
in this house resolution or house
concurrent resolution
uh
why does it make the specification that
we are supporting the uh change in the
embassy's location
because it is now located where we had
for generations promised it would be
moved and uh although
four or five uh different presidents
came and go without it moving we finally
have it in the right place and it should
remain
we fulfilled a promise that was made
long ago yes okay representative cat
service you have a question
no oh representative
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
uh representative spelaine for bringing
forward this important concurrent
resolution um i my question is um is it
is it true that it was uh president uh
bill clinton who originally had the had
the uh the law passed at the embassy
would be moved from tel aviv to
jerusalem and that has just been
congress constantly suspending that
change until finally the president
united states president trump allowed it
to be moved to jerusalem
that would be my understanding
thank you
any uh
thank you for the follow-up uh do you
think that this house concurrent
resolution uh is
uh unjustly picking a sign in a tooth uh
in a conflict between the israelis and
palestinians and do you think that it
could interfere with the peace process
no i don't
any other questions around
representative
thank you mr uh
did the obama administration also
support the move from tel aviv to
jerusalem do you know i do not know
okay uh representative a couple here um
i i believe um president obama also
in his speech and when he first ran was
in support
because as a matter of fact my
understanding and many presidents that
did support this here
and president trump was the first one to
you know finally do it make it happen do
you agree
yes okay my other question is on uh
there's a lot of
concerns over why now
um
why did you put this in now versus
a year ago
because we've seen the attacks and the
uh drum beat around the world and
especially at the u.n to try to um
subvert and and um
make israel uh
not no longer a nation of its own
okay thank you um are there any other
questions
since no i thank you very much thank you
you will recognize uh our
great house whip uh representative
jeanine narda
my former assistant
good morning mr chairman welcome and
good morning members of the committee um
i'm the house majority whip and i
represent hillsborough 21 the town of
merrimack
so my testimony today includes a bit of
history or history lesson rather i stand
in support of hcr 7. i've always known
that the land of israel belongs to the
jewish people it says so in the bible
for the non-believers the bible is a
history book for the rest of us it's
god's holy word and the jews are his
chosen people
when i was a child i remember going with
my mother to see the movie the hiding
place that must have been my first
introduction to the holocaust
as i got older i started reading books
on the topic and watching documentaries
and other movies i also learned that my
my father witnessed the horror as a
young gi in patton's third army when he
helped to liberate the consecration camp
dachau in during world war ii
six million jews were killed during the
holocaust
after the war among those who survived
many immigrated to the holy land
israel has been our strongest ally in
the middle east
i don't know if you've heard of brigitte
gabriel but she was born in lebanon and
had to live in an underground bunker for
seven years during the civil war and
destroyed the peace in that country
it was in the nation of israel that
interceded to rescue her and then helped
to get her to the united states today
she is an american activist for freedom
and liberty and obviously supports
israel
on a personal note i have always had
great respect for judaism i learned a
lot about the faith from the guff which
is said to be the repository for all the
unborn souls to the mezuzah
the latter is a decorative case that
contains specific hebrew verses from the
torah it looks like a scroll and you'll
find it on the doorposts of jewish homes
before entering the home you touch the
mezuzah and then kiss your fingertips
and that is what i do out of respect
when i visit a jewish home
when i went to a synagogue i had a
profound sense that i was in a holy
place
i can't describe it but i've met others
who have said the same
so when i first visited the orthodox
church that i've been attending for the
last 20 years i remember thinking wow
it's almost jewish here except they're
christians
so knowing how much i revere the ancient
faith
explains why i asked to co-sponsor hcr
hcr7
and i thank the prime sponsor for adding
my name
i remember seeing him wear and i support
israel pin when he was a freshman
legislator four terms ago i also
remember asking him where he got it
because i wanted to get one too but i
couldn't find it this morning i would
have wore it
now i too support israel and i believe
that having the u.s embassy in israel is
prudent and just and it needs to stay
there
lastly a resolution may not be a bill
that has sharp teeth but it's the
strongest statement we can make on any
given subject so i ask that you please
support hcr7 thank you
will you take questions representative
i'll try
thank you any questions for
representative nardo
seeing none thank you uh representatives
talk
for those that know representative nord
has been on this committee for a few
years also
thank you
okay the chair
um
the chair's going to recognize i'm
saving another rep for the end but uh
the chair's going to recognize warren
wharton sinkler
who opposes the bill
welcome uh
mr seikler yeah hi i'm here to oppose
hr17
i'm here to oppose h.r
is that okay
since we were just honored to give you
your name and we have yeah
a different bill mr chair
oh wait did you say hs
at least
okay i'm sorry i had that in the wrong
pile there
all right thank you
sorry about that
we'll get back with you
okay uh the chair recognized uh
representative aaron
who i always like to hear from and i was
saving her for the end
see what we learned today
thank you mr chair good morning good
morning committee members for the record
i'm representative judy aaron i
represent sullivan county district 7.
but i'm here for myself
this bill hcr 7 offers a concurrent
resolution reaffirming the general
court's support for the nation of israel
and the location of the embassy of the
united states therein
as a co-sponsor of this bill i believe
this is an extremely important statement
for our new hampshire house to make
and especially to communicate to our
federal delegation at this time
first
the support of israel is something we
should declare
israel is our ally and the only free and
democratic country in the middle east
second the movement of the u.s embassy
from tel aviv to jerusalem
was an affirmation that the holy city is
indeed
the political seat
secular heart
and religious soul of the country of
israel
jerusalem has been fought over for
millennia by its inhabitants and by
regional powers and invaders
it is sacred to judaism
christianity and islam
and each religion has sites of great
significance there which israel
recognizes and protects fiercely
israel's government regards jerusalem as
the eternal and indivisible capital of
the country and the united states
recognized that important historical
political and religious claim
so do 32 other countries in the world
i believe that we must as a legislative
body make a bold statement in support
and
solidarity of the jewish people and
their homeland israel
as well as the decision by our
government to move the u.s embassy to
the rightful capital of israel jerusalem
watching the hostage situation unfold at
congregation beth israel in coleyville
texas last week was another reminder of
the unfortunate rise in anti-semitism
throughout our country and the world it
reminds us all that we must take a stand
against anti-semitism and discrimination
of all kinds
indeed
we have even had a bipartisan statement
broadcast taking a stance against
anti-semitism on december second twenty
twenty one
by our speaker of the house and minority
leadership so this bill seems a natural
follow-up to that letter to house
members
my husband has family that live in
israel
members of his family immigrated to
israel before it became a state
when it was the only place jews could go
to escape persecution in eastern europe
both of us personally have many family
members who perished in hitler's
concentration camps
we as descendants are considered
survivors
and thank god our relatives survived
those awful times
and were either able to come to america
or go to israel to be free
but still my husband and i have seen the
ugly realities of anti-semitism
we grew up with it and unfortunately it
still lingers even since hitler's defeat
and we've heard the ugly words of people
wanting to push the house of israel
into the sea
instead of working towards peaceful
peaceful resolutions to this kind of
awful division in hatred
and so
i would like to see
our new hampshire house take a leading
role
to a firm support of the jewish state of
israel
and the jewish people as one way to
combat anti-semitism and so i'm asking
you
to pass this bill out of your committee
with an otp recommendation thank you so
much thank you pardon me for
my emotional love thank you take your
time thank you
worthy of emotion yeah please if thank
if i may
thank you
um representative you take questions
from anyone if they have questions yes
does anyone here i have any questions
representative lebranch
thank you and i
thank you for coming to this committee
and testifying today
uh in your testimony you talked about a
peaceful resolution to the conflict uh
would you support an amendment to this
house a concurrent resolution that
would keep the majority of the
resolution the same but add
a section calling for uh
or reaffirming our support to the peace
process between israel and palestine
i think the bill is fine the way it is
thank you representative i wouldn't
support it either but
i appreciate the representative bringing
it up
anyone else
okay thank you uh representative
representative lebranch if you want to
bring amendment forward
i mean that's you you could do that you
know i just can't guarantee it'll pass
but you have that right
yeah i have an amendment and it's being
printed by house commission okay thank
you um is there anyone else who has not
spoken i i mean that wants to speak on
this bill
representative nom silva
you can submit a card after to us
yes okay
welcome to the committee you know uh
representative sibler it's always an
honor thank you very much thank you mr
chair and thank you members of the
committee i wasn't intending to speak
but i'm a co-sponsor of this bill
one there's been
the statements about in support of this
bill
and i think that one thing that has been
absent in the testimony so far is that
a couple of months ago
a member of the general court
actually
publicly
espoused
the motto
of the terrorist group hamas
from the river to the sea palestine will
be free
and when you examine that statement from
that terrorist group designated
terrorist group
it means to wipe out the state of israel
and kill all the jews by pushing them
into the mediterranean sea
that's what it means
that's the that's the subtext of that
statement
and we need
by passing this
continuing resolution or concurrent
resolution
to say that this is not an acceptable
thing
for the state of new hampshire
thank you
thank you uh representative would you
take any questions from any certainly
remember any questions uh for
representative sibling
no
uh with that uh representative i i i'm
kind of glad this came forward because
for many years that i kept hearing in
here and it's going to happen it's going
to happen under republican democrats
and of course as you know it took
president trump
to finally make it happen so would you
agree this would be a win-win for the
relationship between america and israel
absolutely and it's our only true ally
through thick and thin in the mideast
yes
well thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much for the commitment is there
anyone else out there that wants to
speak that did not sign up
i don't see any with that i am going to
close the hearing on house concurrent
resolution seven
in
let me see
at 11 15 will be uh h.r 17 so it'll be
fifty about 15 minutes
thank you
a jewish
wow
if you're going to be speaking on h.r 17
please fill out a pin card
and submit it
to us
thank you
is
obviously
god
thank you
my
hey
um
bread
so
okay
um
all right
oh
distributors
is
yes
thank you
oh
okay
foreign
um
yes
foreign
oh i forgot something upstairs
i'm gonna leave my first year i'll be
right there
um
i know i know the clocks are off and off
in these buildings
you
what's up
um
i'm going to say that again one sec
don't look at me
i didn't have my mic on um
okay
once again i'm going to open up the
hearing on hr 17 house resolution
opposing our federal in state efforts to
establish a carbon tax on fuels for
electricity and transportation i'm going
to welcome representative bernardi to
the committee and the floridas
thank you very much chairman and
committee uh for the record my name is
jd bernardi i'm representative from
rockingham 16 which is southampton east
kingston and kensington
so why would anyone want to propose a
carbon tax on fuels and transportation
and for transportation and electricity
nominally because burning carbon dioxide
based fuels releases carbon dioxide into
the environment
and what's wrong with releasing carbon
dioxide
the gas that we exhale when we breathe
about two pounds a day into the
atmosphere
well the environmental crusaders say it
will cause global warming and manifold
attendant consequences
adverse weather sea level rises
this was predicted by computer models
that were first reported by the u.n
environmental director
in 1972
but then it was global cooling because
of all the other pollutants
that are part of combustion
since 1982
89 90 2007
1518 and last year
the world is just another
10 years from a global
warming catastrophe
additionally the computer models focus
only on man-made sources of carbon
dioxide and completely ignore
significant
uncontrollable contributions like
volcanic eruptions
importantly
none of the crusaders models
correspond to the actual observed
climate on earth
global temperature change has been about
a half a degree in the last 50 years
the most disastrous models
model scenarios have pushed pushed by
the crusaders
and a complicit media and big tech say
that these levels will be a three and a
half to four and a half degrees
disasters sell
and support the need
for big government solutions and support
the need for more government grants
to study the quote-unquote problem
mankind has easily adapted to this
modest half-degree temperature change we
lived through warmer periods in the past
the highest recent temperatures
occurred during the dust bowl areas of
the 1930s
previous warm periods occurred in the
middle ages when they grew barley
in greenland so the vikings could
survive
during the roman era they grew grapes in
england for wine
the sun's warmth and carbon dioxide
allow plants to photosynthesize to grow
and produce more abundant grasses trees
and crop yields
not remotely an emergency
it's been a positive
thing
agriculturally for this planet
le chateau's principle tells us that
when a settled system is disturbed
disturbed it will adjust to diminish the
change that has been made to it
despite the modest carbon dioxide
increase
storms floods droughts have reduced
80 percent
from 1980 to 2016.
yet this doesn't stop
demagoguing these events
that have always occurred and will
continue to occur
there is no climate emergency and we
should not be stampeded into adopting a
climate crusader's prescription for
raising carbon taxes to lessen the use
of these fuels for transportation and
electricity
unfortunately
since the time that i drafted this bill
the biden administration has effectively
added an overwhelming carbon tax by
various
anti-energy initiatives
natural gas production and distribution
has been discouraged
the keystone xl pipeline was cancelled
immediately at the start of the
administration
dominion and duke energy canceled the
atlantic pipeline due to quote
legal uncertainties
caused by progressive pipeline opponents
the panic pipeline was cancelled for
similar reasons
all new drilling was prohibited on
federal lands so existing wells so as
existing wells are closed supplies
become more limited and prices go up
note about 56 percent of the electricity
generated in new england is from natural
gas
supplier
portions of our electric bills have more
than doubled
new hampshire pays the fifth highest
electric rates in the continental u.s
and they're skyrocketing
natural gas prices for home heating are
jumping over 50 percent as well
on top of that gasoline prices have
surged from two dollars a gallon to 330
a gallon and even more today since i
wrote this
effectively the biden administration has
already implemented a massive carbon tax
earlier this legislative session the
transportation and climate initiative
tci was rejected by this legislature and
the governor
tci was another carbon training
trading scheme
that was intended for 13 states from
north carolina to maine
carbon emissions were to be capped for
transportation fuels and carbon credits
would be sold to fuel suppliers the tci
was designed to achieve
the same carbon reduction by making gas
and oil prices more expensive
forcing consumers to ride share or take
mass transit
rising gas prices caused by the biden
administration effectively killed the
tci plan resulting in the governor
formally rejecting the initiatives and
all the other governors following suit
finally
the last federal plan clean
energy performance program is another
carbon reduction program in the pending
built back better legislation
it is also designed to make electric
prices rise
bottom line we don't need to accept
false climate models
and extremist solutions that our
economy and our people
say no to carbon taxes and send that
message to our federal delegation
with that i will take questions
uh thank you representative for your
testimony i got a few things myself
and you know while you were speaking
some things that popped will you take
questions from me absolutely
um i i had flashbacks of my younger days
with tip o'neill and the kennedys my
grandfather was a four-term mayor in
cambridge massachusetts so i grew up at
the mall
and back then as a kid the sky was going
to fall
it was called something else back then
then i joined the marines global cooling
yeah warming that's right and i joined
the marines and all they kept hearing in
a few years we're done the sky's going
to fall
then i listened to vice president
al gore when i was in the marines and
for the record i retired from the marine
corps and all i heard was it's the end
of the world
in a couple of years we're done
um but since then i've seen the light in
my my grandfather used to tell me read
the almanac
is is the almanac i mean uh that they
always say you if you want to know
what's going on with the weather read
the the farmer's almanac
statement well there are a lot of people
that take that point of view
okay
my my other thing was on this here is
why is it always the united states
that has to do a redistribution of
people's money
for this carbon tax where china and
other countries no big deal we we bow to
them how come
well i
these carbon tax initiatives are driven
by people like uh
uh
john kerry and and others that want us
to quote unquote lead the way
and and uh are not
willing to force the same requirements
on
china or india or other
third world developing countries into
second or first world countries uh to
accept the same costs so i you know i i
can't explain their ill logic but that's
what they want to do
okay for the record do you sit on
science and technology yes i'm on
science technology one of the big geeks
that
keeps us straight in this information i
appreciate it thank you are there any
other questions uh
okay representative uh
sure um well just to wax nostalgically i
remember mr coffler
in seventh grade teaching us about
something called the greenhouse effect
when i was born in 1958
uh there were 347 parts per million of
carbon dioxide there's now 417 parts per
million of carbon dioxide 98 of all
climate scientists tell us that
that
sort of contrary to what you're saying
um
what do you know about the greenhouse
effect and is it just not true was mr
koffler wrong in telling me about
about that
well mr koffler is not wrong in telling
you about the greenhouse effect i think
some of the things that you might be
remembering are wrong
uh the greenhouse effect has caused by
the shortwave radiation coming in from
the sun
being easily passed through the
atmosphere but once it we do a little
heating of the of the earth the long
wave radiation that
would is emitted
it does not all escape and that causes a
warming and and
there was a recent paper in the
international journal of atmosphere and
oceanic sciences december of this last
year
that describes how the earth itself
would be
uh
33 degrees kelvin
which is
centigrade
reindex to absolute zero
cooler did we not if we didn't have the
greenhouse effect so 33 degrees of the
earth's current temperature centigrade
degrees would be we would be cooler now
of that
they analyzed what are the contributors
to that greenhouse effect
the biggest greenhouse gas is water
vapor all the stuff in our clouds and
that's responsible for
29.4 degrees of that greenhouse effect
three
i have the numbers here
[Music]
3.3 degrees of that are caused by carbon
dioxide and .3 degrees of that are
caused by methane
why they want to have
cows no longer fart in the in the fields
and nitrous oxide um
so
that those are the facts of the
circumstance
so
the rising of the greenhouse gases that
you've described
are
demonstrated to cause one half a degree
centigrade
rise
from
carbon dioxide and the attendant water
vapor changes that happen with that
because of more cloud formation
point zero six and point zero eight
respectively of the methane and nitrous
oxide this is a de minimis amount a day
minimus effect
additionally there are two other papers
that have recently been published that
basically
describe the effect of carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere and
and
it's
uh
and how it impacts um
the uh
the temperature rise and and
it effectively says
the higher the the amount of carbon
dioxide the less the carbon dioxide has
an effect i i reference uh
um le chatelier's
principle
basically what this would say is the
first 100 parts per million causes 70
percent of the
impact of temperature
the next
going from 100 to 200 you you get up to
of the effect going from
uh 200 to 300 you get up to 96 of the
effect and
above that is your is your remaining
four percent is that last increment of
carbon dioxide essentially
demonstrating the more you add
the less the
effect well thank you for that uh
of course when they speak on the floor
there a lot of us are lost you know and
but
you know they're the knowledgeable ones
there any other questions uh
representative yes representative
deloomis thank you thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
i i
know that plants give off carbon dioxide
and they do use carbon monoxide they use
it and they and they expel it right also
yes right so at night at night they do
it and sometimes and parts of the day
when the sun comes out then you've got
photosynthesis
so
if we cut down all my question is if we
cut down all the trees in the
rain forests
would that help with global warming
i i eliminated the carbon dioxide that
they would they would emit i i well
since the plants are large contributors
i i i understand your your point i think
the greater impact of cutting down uh
the trees is is going to
cause less sequestering of carbon
dioxide in fact one of the
the
the methods people talk about about
addressing co2 buildup is
uh planting more trees
so that
so that the trees uh when they
when they photosynthesize and grow and
capture that carbon in their wood and
and whatnot they are they are reducing
the net carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
as you as if you remember in my
testimony i made the statement
that
agriculturally
increased levels of carbon dioxide have
been a good thing for this planet and if
you go to sophisticated greenhouses and
you want to understand how they can
push plant growth and get things ready
for the season one of the things they do
is
tightly isolate those those houses and
add carbon dioxide to the atmosphere so
the plants grow faster so it's a vet a
net positive for plant growth
would you take one more question
absolutely
well i am a gardener
and uh i
i just wanted to ask if you feel that
there's a good natural balance that the
that we have on earth that our balance
is
between the oxygen and the carbon
dioxide is
fairly static and and uh and would
sustain life
as we know it and has been for
the next few thousand years or
well i i would agree with that i think
that you know even
even
though the modern industrial society is
clearly contributing
to
a a modest increase in carbon dioxide
one of the other recent papers that that
has been published this time in in
climate
describes
what the levels of carbon dioxide have
been in the atmosphere
uh by they've
looked at the stable isotopes
over the uh
the
last
435 million years
okay so in that paper
they found a negative a modest but
negative correlation between
the amount of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere
and uh
and and warming uh there are times
in
in the
ancient past when the carbon dioxide
levels in the atmosphere were
significantly higher than they are now
and i do not believe that the modest
amount of carbon dioxide
change that we're now seeing is going to
have any
significant impact on on humans in fact
one of the things that humans are very
good at doing is adapting to their
environment
thank you for answering all right thank
you representative seeing that
there are no other questions we thank
you for your testimony it was definitely
a learning process for me that was
wonderful yeah it was wonderful
testimony there and most people
really
don't look oh do you have a
oh i'm sorry i didn't see it
representative massimilia
thank you mr chairman
and thank you representative for taking
my question
do you see any parallel
between the consequences that resulted
as the denial of the pandemic and its
resulting consequences
could be a parallel to the possibility
of longer
term
effects of denial of the carbon
emissions
short answer no
uh
but first i would uh not agree with your
initial premise that there was a denial
of the pandemic
i think what there has been is a
disagreement as time has gone on about
what the proper methods to address the
pandemic are
and that has been characterized by those
that don't like that as denial i believe
that is inaccurate
thank you
any other questions
seeing so thank you very much uh for
your testimony thank you the chair
recognized uh representative janine nada
our
whip
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
like representative bernardi and
representative vos i too am on the
committee of nerds and geeks also known
as science technology and energy i know
it's riveting so wake up everyone
so the past four terms now i've been on
the committee of science technology and
energy and many times now we have heard
arguments for and against a carbon tax
i keep some of the past testimony in a
folder that has the eiffel tower on the
cover it serves as a reminder of the
crowds that took to the streets to
protest the carbon tax that was imposed
on the people of france
serving in the new hampshire legislature
we often hear the same bills over and
over each term in this committee it was
the honor and remember flag that kept
coming back
so let me tell you what a carbon tax
would mean for new hampshire
new england convenience stores and
energy markets association testified
that every cent the state charges
through this plan will get pushed down
the various supply chains and ultimately
end up hitting new hampshire citizens in
the wallet
it will affect anyone who drives a car
heats their home or business or anyone
doing construction
projects of any kind anyone who buys
groceries or eats out in a restaurant
and on and on and on this tax will touch
everyone in the state multiple times
each and every day
this domino effect was further explained
by representative michael vose the
collapse of the new hampshire economy is
what this carbon tax will likely induce
since surrounding states will not have
adopted this tax energy prices in those
states will become lower than those here
people will drive to neighboring states
to buy cheaper gas
renters especially those who commute out
of state for work will move there
because apartment utilities will be
lower
since all goods and services vendors in
new hampshire will be subject to the
carbon tax the price of everything will
go up
this inflation will cut back on other
expenses such as labor
jobs will be lost companies may
eventually be forced to recla relocate
out of state new hampshire will fall
into a death spiral
of economic chaos
at a task force meeting at the american
legislators exchange council a slide was
presented to highlight our states and
the ridiculous carbon tax proposal
new hampshire is among the lowest in the
usa for carbon emissions less than
0.0029 percent
so let me repeat that point zero zero
two nine percent of the u.s total
so how can anyone possibly rationalize
taxing the people of new hampshire and
we're talking 300 to 800 million dollars
for such a minuscule return
in 2019 the majority party at the time
tabled the carbon tax bill to avoid
having the public hear the debate on
this disastrous legislation that spells
government overreach to the extreme
so as legislators we sometimes receive
literature from the heartland institute
you may hear testimony later today from
someone who will try to convince you
that there that the heartland institute
is just a tiny little outfit that knows
nothing on the contrary the heartland
institute has the respect of tens of
thousands of scientists worldwide who
dispute that we are in a climate crisis
keep in mind that the public is only
told what those in charge of the media
and or administration want you to know
during a previous administration only
the climate alarmists got federal grants
and those in opposition got canceled
i had the opportunity to attend the
international climate conference this
past october
i took home stacks of books and read
every one of them and i filled up this
entire notepad
with notes just from that conference in
those books and i kept hearing no carbon
is good you need carbon you you need
carbon and we've had more carbon in the
air in times past
so true science dictates that questions
must always be asked
is science ever really settled
new information pops up every day
so to sum it all up
a resolution is not a bill that knocks
change
it is a political statement that we do
not want to ruin our economy with an
unsustainable carbon tax like they
implemented and implemented in france
put the granite staters first and pass
this resolution thank you well thank you
representative um
do we have a copy of your written
testimony too if we can
i have to meet a girl scout so you know
sitting here just listening to this
stuff here and i think of um
the number came up if i'm not mistaken
was 308 million dollars coming in
you know on uh this redistribution of
money
uh what is this doing to our electric
bills
keeps going up and up and up well let me
tell you um
there was a scientist named
holger
i have his name here somewhere
holder i can't remember his last name at
the moment but he's from germany and he
told me that there are people in germany
because they have the highest energy
costs in the world followed by australia
in the united states it's california
that has the highest
people cannot afford electricity in in
germany there's there's they're freezing
and they want to do that to us here why
if people want to sit in the dark alone
and freeze i mean they're welcome to do
that but we shouldn't be forced to
right
now they could move to germany yeah
another quest yeah they moved to germany
my next question would be is um
one of the phone calls and different
things i get from business owners are
from out of state that
would love to come to new hampshire but
they always complain about our high
electric costs
i mean
what
can we do
to straighten this out because i mean to
me this is a redistribution of money it
is and we've been doing great here in
new hampshire for many many years the
sky is not falling so what can we do to
attract more business that are
complaining about electric bills i mean
well on science and tech and energy
what we what we try to say is we have to
um chip away a little bit at a time
because we keep getting told every time
there's a bill or something oh it's only
the price of a cup of coffee it's only
the price of two cups of coffee well you
know we're talking about gallons and
gallons of coffee with all these little
taxes and fees so it keeps going up so
we have to chip away where we can
also well this is another committee but
i just put in a bill in ways and means
to continue lowering the business
profits tax and business enterprise tax
because that will help
bring
businesses to want to come here
and also um
you don't have to be a nerd or a geek to
to want to know what the energy prices
are so there's this little app called
iso to go
so it's free you
download it to your phone and you can
see real time what the energy costs in
new hampshire so right now it's 168
dollars and five cents per megawatt
my last question here maybe you can help
me out understand this here
is what that 308 million dollars 300 to
800 million 300 800 million 800 million
yeah what does what does that money go
what do you i mean besides helping low
income
with their homes that's awful a lot of
them what are we doing with that money
that's a good question
why don't they just leave it where
with the people where it belongs they
they take it and they like redistribute
it like they'll give it to someone here
and it's like you spend 100 today to
maybe get 70 back later on it's a big
long
uh complicated um
system so just leave it alone just don't
no carbon tax just you don't need it
but what are they how is it making a
difference in the carpenter i mean in
the carbon
i mean with that you know with the money
they're taken from because of producing
carbon or trees is somebody taxing the
trees or
you know what i mean where it's
producing all this carbon they will
tax the air we breathe
okay i mean that's why i'm confused on
why so much money's coming in
and that i mean elderly in my district
are complaining you know it's the same
thing
they're putting the heat down to 65 or
60 you know just to stay because of the
cost and electricity and oil and other
okay
that's it
any other questions
representative chase uh thank you mr
chairman thank you representative notter
for uh taking my question so so let's
assume right let's let's entertain the
idea that that that this issue could be
solved via carbon tax right let's let's
make that assumption
um my question though is don't we
already have a a regulatory system
reggie right the greenhouse green uh
the regional greenhouse gas initiative
reggie is an energy tax it's an and so
um has that been effective in reducing
greenhouse gases and how has that money
been reinvested in new hampshire right
is that is that current system is that
working is that successful and would if
that is successful would it not prove
that we don't need a carbon tax we
already have our own system or if it
isn't successful wouldn't it just
further prove that a carbon tax probably
wouldn't work if reggie's not working
i'm lost in your question but um i
always
sponsor a co-sponsor bill every year to
try and get rid of reggie
yeah that was a disaster okay um
okay anyone else uh you had a question
well thank you very much
representative uh nada appreciate your
testimony
the chair welcome that opposes the bill
um
wharton sinclair we finally get them up
here all right
written testimony representative
thank you
thank you chair to the committee yeah
thank you very much my name is wharton
sinclair and i'm from sandwich new
hampshire and i was curious do we have
numbers on
uh on the on the record of how many
opposed and in favor of h.r 17
no i don't
i have the numbers um
i will i mean i'm sure there are online
and also
uh in-person uh indications of the
numbers of uh pro and conor i can just
like to know those numbers i mean i can
get the numbers there uh um okay
assistant there will get it first but i
can tell you myself as a legislator for
the town of londonderry
i look at what it's costing my elderly
and other stuff so even though there's
people all around the country calling in
and opposing us here emails i got from
out of state and i'm saying oh they they
want us and then there was some from
in-state so don't get me wrong but they
they would love for us to you know keep
redistributing people's money and all
i'm doing is hurting my seniors and
low-income people but go ahead so my
comments are as follows
we in this country have always embraced
good science and good technology and it
served us extremely well
right now we you know we've done things
like
addressing the ozone
ozone layer destruction very effectively
by phasing out the chemicals
that were causing that damage to the
ozone layer and exposing people to uv
light
we can do we have a problem right now
the scientists are telling us that as
the representative to my right here
pointed out earlier
of climate scientists
are in agreement that climate change is
real it's happening it's caused by our
carbon dioxide emissions primarily
uh from the use of fossil fuels
and it's having uh profound effects
right now those are not modeled effects
they are real uh we are experiencing sea
level rise we are experiencing a lot
large loss of ice
from glaciers and at our poles
and
we are experiencing severe heat waves
and record temperatures and wildfires
all of which
have been scientifically related to
the climate change that we're causing
with our carbon dioxide emissions
this is something that you know i would
like to think that we as a society
can grasp science and address and solve
with
good sound policy
i'd like to point out that h.r 17
in its uh in its points opposing carbon
taxes
essentially paints a caricature of a
badly designed
carbon tax
it's not really related to real
proposals of carbon taxes or carbon
pricing
for example um
the the hr 17
suggests that
with a with carbon pricing we would end
up
hurting our
competitiveness but in reality the bills
that are that are on that are actually
being considered that implement carbon
pricing as a means of creating the
incentives to use less fossil fuels
those bills all include measures such as
a carbon border adjustment mechanism
or cbam which would basically
uh
it would force exporters to the us who
don't have an equivalent carbon price
to pay a border adjustment on the goods
they're importing to us
so this would protect the
competitiveness of american
manufacturing
by levying
essentially the equivalent carbon tax on
goods as they're imported that's that's
real
carbon pricing policy and what hr 17
discusses isn't
real it's a caricature of poorly
designed
carbon pricing meant to
to scare legislators and to mislead the
public about what carbon pricing really
is and what it can accomplish
another example is that it talks about
electricity prices
as being immediately and substantially
increased by a carbon tax well obviously
that depends how that carbon tax is
is introduced does it start small and go
up over time we in new hampshire we
already generate more than 60 percent of
the electricity we consume
with non-emitting sources so we're
actually already quite far ahead of the
curve
if you have a small and steadily
increasing price on fossil based carbon
you'll promote
the utilities to move away from fossil
fuel energy and you'll give them time to
do it and an incentive to do it
and by doing that in fact they avoid the
tax completely
so the tax may not
really even show up that much but by
being present and creating incentives it
leads us in the right direction away
from the use of fossil fuels which are
causing this problem
which i discussed earlier due to global
warming global warming these are facts
we have sea level rise we have
uh
uh you know the the
the warmest years on record have all
been in the last seven years
uh
that's real data and uh
i think by slamming the door on carbon
pricing without carefully considering
what a good carbon price would entail
we're really throwing the baby out with
the with the wash water
and we should
we should not uh we should not do that
this bill is misguided and
in
trying to preempt
a policy without carefully considering
you know the nuance the caveats how it
can be structured positively for our
city for our citizens and for our
residents
uh and that's all i have thank you very
much
thank you uh
will you accept uh
questions sure absolutely
some of you you brought up there that
on the use of uh you said we used we
want to use less fossil fuels
i'm no uh you know representative branch
who's one of our gurus and uh
you know brilliant on this uh issues
here
and i know when i look at studies you
say 98 of the scientists
but i see other studies that disagree
with many many studies disagree
okay on this area here but my question
is what the electric cars that they're
pushing
and uh what does that do to the grid
and what does that do to electric
companies that have to produce
more
um electricity and they must be doing
put more
in the air or carbon or whatever in the
air i mean what does that do i mean
we uh we i own an electric car and i
charge it overnight and
in the state of new hampshire
between 1am and 5am
almost certainly the electricity i'm
using to charge my car comes from our
nuclear plant at seabrook it's
completely emissions free
yeah if we as we transition to more
electric
electricity in our transportation sector
we will need to improve our electric
grid we will need to add supply
but we should get going on that that's
something that putting a price on
the problem
will really
encourage us to do aggressively we need
to move fast with this because the
threat to our children and grandchildren
is real
uh we will not have the same climate
here in new hampshire we're already
seeing last summer heat waves that
wouldn't have been at all you know
common or they would be
they would have been extremely
uh rare 30 years ago
okay um i'm hoping representative branch
is taking notes because i'm going to ask
him to come back up if you don't mind at
the end to help my committee out and
decipher some of the things that have
been said here before we go to
executives there to make a difference
but
with your electric car one question
there would help us on some of the votes
that we get
you're not paying any road tax anymore
because you're not getting gas
what's that going to do to the highways
i mean the highways are funded from uh
gasoline taxes but they're also you want
to get rid of fossil fuels but they're
also funded in very large measure
by
regular income taxes federal income
taxes because
the gasoline tax the federal gasoline
tax hasn't increased since 1992
so
so you and i
when we when we pay our income tax to
uncle sam we're actually supporting
uh we're supporting transportation so if
i may
because we're
moving along now a lot of time here but
if i may i just need you to answer me
i'm talking new hampshire new hampshire
maintains their roads by the gas tax
not by the taxpayers uh you know the gas
tax watch is used and then we bond
to fix certain roads that are paid by
those general fund then in the gas tax
so with all these electric cars
i'm just asking your recommendation
how do you ex
how do you recommend us to tax you to me
because you're driving a car you're not
using fuel i mean i do agree with you in
principle
the the roads do need to be paid for and
at some point it will be appropriate to
levy
uh tax to you know on electric vehicles
to help pay for the roads
you know right now the sector is
extremely small and it's actually
important that it be allowed to grow
so prematurely slapping a punitive tax
on electric vehicles is i think a bad
idea right now that's my personal
opinion yeah i mean the principle you
bring up there about paying for our
roads and services is important and i
agree with it okay because we're losing
money in our gas tax that's why i'm
bringing that up but you have a question
thank you uh chair and thank you for
your testimony uh
so you know
would you believe that um
that are you know in december was the
you know it was nine degrees warmer than
the average um
would you believe that this year was
yeah nine degrees warmer than the
average in uh in massachusetts or in new
hampshire
uh our december you know i don't have
the i don't have at my fingertips the
state uh
climatologist's uh conclusions for the
for the month of december is that
is that yeah that's what i saw on the
news the other day right yeah
it was a very warm fall and right into
december that's correct
thank you any other questions
i can tell you i left went to florida
there because it was too cold it was
colder than normal in my book but i had
representative uh
yeah and i i want to
thank you for your testimony and thank
you mr chair for allowing me to ask a
question um
i i too i drive a hybrid vehicle and i
drove here today and i
got about 78 the equivalent of 78 miles
to the gallon with my hybrid
uh
vehicle so i guess i am contributing to
the demise of new hampshire roads by not
burning enough fossil fuels no
but
i want to ask you it was previously in
previous testimony we heard that the
united states
produces a very small amount of the co2
in the world
but i'm seeing according to the union of
concerned scientists that
we are one of the top we are the top co2
emitting country in the world that we
emit 24.5
of the co2 compared to 13.9 percent
produced by china
can you resolve this do you know
anything about this are we are we
actually very tiny contributors or is
the union of con concerned scientist
data incorrect
you know i believe we were passed by
china not long ago like without actually
looking up numbers i'm afraid i'm not
exactly the expert on this but uh we are
certainly as a nation one of the largest
uh in emitters in the world of the gases
that
are causing global warming
thank you mr single for the record are
you a scientist are you
i actually am a material scientist so i
have a phd
in a field that's not related to climate
but
i am scientifically trained i have some
background in chemistry
and physics and uh
yeah that's my
i'm a retired researcher
okay one last uh representative dilemma
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
and it's a it's going to probably be a
silly question to you
but
considering that we've had an ice age
and you do do you believe that there was
an ice age okay absolutely considering
we've had an ice age and considering
that greenland did in fact grow crops
and i think that's
fairly common knowledge
how would you explain the warming that
took place from the ice age to
the heat that it would take to have
green land produce
uh plants and then now you're saying
that
with the with the infinitesimal amounts
of of carbon that that we were just told
about
by my esteemed colleague
that
we're able to affect any change if the
if globally the sun probably had a fair
amount to do with the warming of the
planet
for that
are you
suggesting that
by having hybrid cars and and stopping
the emissions that we produce now which
also do benefit the growth of plants
that we're going to affect
we're going to all drown in the raising
waters from the ocean i i i'm confused
i mean there are a lot of questions you
you asked actually quite quite a few
questions some of them you can make it
some of them would require a lot of a
lot of discussion to resolve you know i
think there's
there are certainly some very good
sources on the causes of the ice ages it
was actually more than one
and a lot of them have to do with
earth's orbit around the sun and angles
of inclination between the axis of the
earth and the sun but
you know i think
this material is
something that scientists
climate scientists are well aware of and
there are good scientific explanations
for ice ages
and um in the context of our complete
fairly complete and rigorous
understanding of the earth's climate
system
we are still able to say that
our
carbon dioxide emissions are disrupting
the climate that we have today and will
be causing
substantial warming have already caused
substantial warming and that that's a
dangerous thing we can't let that just
go on unabated and expect to enjoy our
cool summers and
wonderful climate here in new hampshire
and you know play other parts of the
world will really suffer
very unduly
because of heat and sea level rise thank
you
you have a question
yes i do mr chairman
thank you for taking my question thank
you for your testimony um
as a scientist do you believe that there
is a correlation
between
the availability and cost of energy in a
society
and the average standard of living
within that society
i
you know i think
use of energy does certainly contribute
to our well-being but this having a
having putting a price on fossil based
carbon
is not uh
the the end of energy use as we know it
that certainly is would be unacceptable
and but i you know again this goes back
to
uh
over generalization about carbon pricing
uh in terms of well-designed versus
poorly designed and if we are careful
and deliberate carefully about
how exactly to implement something like
a carbon price
we can accomplish what we need to
accomplish with respect to climate
change without
you know sacrificing and having our
citizens sacrifice uh in their life in
their standard of living
oh really
you don't want to real quick
yeah no i'll give you a follow-up i was
just wondering uh when you tax them on
the carbon does the carbon like
automatically go away because we took
their money
you know i mean so but go ahead
represent foster
thank you mr chairman um
with that said do you think that a
carbon tax would have a positive or
negative effect on the average standard
of living within our society
i mean i think a well-designed carbon
tax
you know is an economic question really
so it's a question
of
properly designed carbon tax does that
increase gdp or does it increase jobs
or does it increase
our population's health
and i think
there are economists who've carefully
considered this question
and the answers that they have come up
with is that
what a carbon tax will do
is effective at reducing carbon
emissions
without sacrificing jobs or standard of
living
or if those sa if there are sacrifices
they're they're
very small and negligible
um certainly on
issues such as health
you know transitioning away from fossil
fuels removes a lot of
you know air quality burdens
that impact
americans and not so much in new
hampshire but
certainly in our big cities and adjacent
to our highways you know having
less uh just air pollution is is a is a
beneficial side effect of
uh
you know moving our energy use away from
polluting fossil fuels
all right thank you
thank you of course you know we're here
concerned with what's going on in new
hampshire
since we're taking people our bit money
out of their pockets
but they thank you very much very very
interesting testimony and i like
listening to both sides anyways thanks
for allowing me
for years just testify
um
is it phil or is it yeah brown phil
brown
uh who opposes the bill
oh hi
i'm opposed to the resolution yes
oh by the way your other answer you were
asking how many supported or
140 opposed in for support which is
normal for this type of bill
because they come in from all over the
place and uh on these bills and a lot of
them i want to pull the list a lot of
them are all activists and they come
from out of state too but thank you
okay
yes welcome mr brown
good day my name is phil brown i'm a
retired science teacher from concord
high school
taught science at all grades and in all
science areas for 35 years here in the
state
and uh i'm i'm in opposition to this
resolution and and
i gave you a piece of paper
that i actually
uh brought to bear for house
hb 1657 it was about local foods for
local schools
but if you look at this side
did you get did all of you folks get one
of these
okay if you look at this side
there are two data tables here
the first data table
relates to a 20-year period from roughly
or 19 yes uh 1981 to 2000.
and this is a data table that was
created by uh looking at the
noaa which is the national ocean and
graphic and atmospheric administration
does every year they study the number of
billion dollar disasters
billion-dollar disasters in this country
right
in the 20-year period from 81 to 2000
they were i don't have my spectacles so
i'm hoping i can read it correctly there
were if you look at the
the the vertical line with the yellow
bar on it uh in that 20-year period
there were 84
cpi adjusted computer price index
adjusted 84 billion dollar disasters
and the total cost to the country was
roughly 456
billion dollars
okay
in 1986
down at goddard space flight center
jim hansen
after looking at the data that came from
the mauna loa
observatory on the island of mauna loa
out in the pacific he was studying the
levels of carbon dioxide
and 350 parts per million
of co2 was initially
monitored that particular year
well the ice cores somebody was talking
about ice cores in greenland they've
been taking ice cores out of the ice in
greenland and they go down
a mile two miles deep into the ice
and they can study them
and they can figure out for a particular
year
like 25 000 years ago when was our last
last ice age
that the greatest amount of co2 in the
atmosphere at that time was 300 parts
per million and now we're at 400 and
i'm going to say close to 20 i'm not
sure
so 350 in 1986 which is in this 20-year
time period
okay so what we have is a situation
where if you look at the second data
table below that
which is just the last five years
from
2017 to 2021
the total number of disasters roughly
the same but a five-year period as
opposed to a 20-year period there were
86 billion dollar disasters in the in
the united states
at a cost of roughly 742
billion dollars
so the cost of having
this disruption
to our climate and to our earth and to
our social system
is ever increasing on our society i'm
not even talking about the 10 plus
billion or trillion dollars that we've
spent on covet over the last three years
right
so we're talking here about disasters
that we see
and and you would really have to be
somewhat
out of it not to notice that when we
have rain events we don't just have rain
anymore we have deluges
when we have wind events we don't just
have
breezes we have wind
right we have wind
now that wind can be used offshore to
generate electricity which could reduce
the amount of co2 in the atmosphere
we need to seriously think about what
the cost is to our society
by an ever increasing dependence on
fossil fuels
when i was born in 1948
there were only 2 billion people on this
planet
2 billion
today we're approaching 8 billion
and all of them
want to live like we have lived here in
the united states for the last 70 years
we have lived as kings and queens
we have lived the life that no one could
have imagined
growing up in the depression like my mom
did
we we need to think about what we can do
to preserve this planet
for my children your children our
grandchildren into the future
and so i would really like to think that
you would want to consider them
in
not supporting
this resolution
so that's my testimony
and i will take questions do you have
written testimony
just just this okay okay that's right
you did get this right i didn't write
down what i just said you no no i just
we appreciate the testimony you got
uh but anyways uh would you take
questions of course thank you any
questions
uh representative branch
you brought up a thank you uh for coming
to testify today uh you brought up uh
renewables and wind power
do you believe that uh renewables and
carbon neutral uh power sources such as
nuclear wind solar could make up for the
uh loss in electricity production uh
from fossil fuels oh i certainly do
believe that
i mean they the
the offshore wind program for the gulf
of maine stands to create an enormous
amount of electricity we are we are so
far behind in that kind of of electrical
generation compared to european
countries and and even china that we
need to think seriously about ways to
catch up
and that's an ideal way to catch up
when
a question uh when we tax do this carbon
tax i mean i'm i don't know where the
money goes what but i'm pretty
interested now i'm gonna have to dig
into this a little more
educate me
when we when they pay their carbon taxes
like their carbon go away or what what
happens
i'm sorry sir what i'm trying to figure
out in my mind
when we charge a business
a carbon tax
what happens after that does that like
the carbon go away or does uh or we just
keep taking their money
well do you mean is the carbon
diminishing in the atmosphere yeah
because we're taking their money i mean
where what happens then do they have to
like invest in something that cleans
uh i mean well if you reduce the amount
of carbon dioxide being generated by
fossil fuels my question is how real
quick if i may instead
how do you reduce it once you take their
money
how well you're not what you're doing is
you're trying to push the economy
towards more renewable sources of
electrical generation like offshore wind
so we take their money just to push them
to basically to
it motivates them right they know how to
do this right the
the industries know how to generate
electricity using offshore wind but they
don't want to necessarily do it because
right now there's no
monetary incentive to do that
but by passing and utilizing a carbon
type tax and it's only a tax in the
sense that
the people pay it initially but then
they get it back
they get the money back it's returned
back to the to the the stakeholders the
the the consumers if you will
if i may uh if you can real quick
because i know scientists they can go on
and on no disrespect but i
i because we our science and technology
committee when they can really educate
us in but it takes a while for slow
people uh like myself
so i'm trying to get educated i'm still
confused
on uh
i mean so why we keep carbon tag this is
where i'm getting at
why i'm leaning to support this here is
because
i have elderly and i have um you know in
my district at a complaint that are
suffering
you know i mean with the electric bills
and stuff i got people on oxygen that
are paying more money
but yet we're gonna
put this carbon tax and we're raising
the cost of electricity
and yet
it's hurting people
that's helped me out to understand what
this
you
know the only thing that i can say
relative to that is that the way that
the plan is designed and i'm not sure
catherine or john are you going to
testify in regard to this
i might want to defer
your question to me
to either john gage or his wonderful
daughter catherine back there she's one
of the children that i'm advocating for
with clean energy with renewable energy
so they they might be able to better
answer you that question okay but um
thank you very much without any other
questions then uh
oh okay sir
that i do not know i would like to think
probably 30 years
i would like to think that that would be
uh which is kind of what a nuclear power
plant
without some retrofit is designed to
last 30 years
and i am i am definitely in favor of
nuclear energy
you know i know there was a lot of huff
and puff about seabrook many years ago
but there are ways of doing nuclear
energy
that may that may result in a
significant amount of
less
polluting
uh electrical generation today than what
we are seeing now with seabrook okay
thank you
okay follow-up gad
probably the same thing that we do with
the old automobiles you know we we would
recycle the metals
because there's a lot of very very
valuable materials and those and the
windmills themselves
okay thank you very much sir for your
testimony thank you folks if you want to
see what they do with those uh windmills
here take a ride out to yucca valley
where i used to go train in the desert
hundreds of them all rusted out and just
sitting there they look beautiful
so
at the bottom of that sheet too by the
way there's a little point of
information about the amount of fema
money that new hampshire has taken over
two different intervals and that's gone
up significantly
over the last 20 years thank you
okay i'm going to invite uh john gage
and welcome to the committee and he
opposes the bill and i'm going to ask
the the next few speakers because we're
running out of time and i want my
representatives to go to lunch but um if
it's anything
that you've already heard that's been
spoken we
please don't be repetitious we want to
hear new
uh some new uh testimony
that hasn't been already said
now john are you a scientist
no
i'm an amateur scientist i have a
biology degree from college but instead
of watching professional sports on tv i
read science books for fun so
um i'm an artist it's hard for me to
hear with that mask can you put the mic
down some yeah sure
oops
[Music]
how's this
yes
i'm submitting that as information
um i will i tried to submit my written
testimony
after i had registered my opposition to
this
resolution and it didn't let me so i
don't know if
i couldn't do it again it gave me an
error that i'd already registered my
position so
i either have to send my written
testimony to you or some get it to you
some other way
wonderful thank you
yeah so if that's what i said before i
heard the first two speakers i added
about 10 more minutes to what i could
say
but it's up to you how much time you
want to spend
um
so
my background is in computer science but
i as i said i i love to read science and
i started off reading biology and
chemistry and physics and astronomy and
about seven years ago i shifted to
climate science
just for fun
i have worked in a biology lab so i knew
how to read research i know how to
identify reputable sources
and evaluate
information from multiple sources so
what you have right there is the fourth
national climate assessment the
executive summary from volume one and
the overview from volume 2.
this is produced by law
by the united states global change
research program
it's a combination of climate scientists
and other scientists from across a wide
range of scientific organizations nasa
noaa the department of energy the
department of defense
the epa
it's reviewed by the national academy of
sciences
the whole purpose of this is to do a
survey of what we know about global
warming and climate pollution
write it down and produce a report that
is supposed to be used by
the legislative side of government to
make decisions about what we should do
about our climate pollution
so
representative notter mentioned somebody
might come up
and talk about the heartland institute
because
i have seen her handing out copies of a
booklet called why science
to disagree about global warming
there is a bunch of shadow organizations
that are funded by the fossil fuel
industry
koch brothers exxon others to produce
misinformation
they take a
a bit of science
and then they exclude a bunch of other
science and they
produce documents that
try to convince you that the science is
not science
but they're not science they're
propaganda so
propaganda is
marketing made to influence people's
opinions and decisions
uh it's not based on what we know
through science it's based on how to
convince people
that we should
behave a certain way
not pass certain legislation so
the first volume of this is the causes
of global warming as we know through
science
now there's not a scientific
organization that in the world that
disagrees with the conclusions in here
i'd like to read just two
paragraphs
there's a nice so it's a very large
report this is the executive summary 25
pages or so there's a two page
highlights of it and i'm going to read
you two paragraphs from the highlights
which is two pages long what page are
you reading from it's page one page one
thank you
that way to clerk and underline it for
the committee sure
so remember this is from all of the
science organizations
in the us and they surveyed all the
science from around the world for the
last couple decades
and they say globally global annual
sorry so second paragraph on page one
global annually average surface air
temperature has increased by about 1.8
degrees fahrenheit over the last 115
years
this period is now the warmest in the
history of modern civilization that's
the last 10 000 years
the last few years have also seen
record-breaking climate-related weather
extremes in the last three years have
been the warmest years on record for the
globe
these trends are expected to continue
over climate time scales
this assessment concludes based on
extensive evidence that it is extremely
likely that human activities especially
emissions of greenhouse gases are the
dominant cause of the observed warming
since the mid 20th century
for the warming over the last century
there is no convincing alternative
explanation supported by the extent of
observational evidence
so extremely likely in scientific terms
means 95 to 100 percent
confidence
that it's right based on all the
evidence
so
the heartland institute will say the
science isn't settled
science has never settled
which is true
we can become very confident that we
know something through science when the
evidence becomes overwhelming
and that's what it is about human cause
pollution
and global warming
okay the volume 2 was about the impacts
of the problem
but i want to talk to you directly about
what you asked
why carbon tax how does putting a price
on carbon reduce emissions
it's a lot easier to understand how a
regulation can reduce emissions you say
you can't
release that pollution so they don't
uh if you tell a coal produced a power
plant that uses coal
that they have to reduce their emissions
by a certain amount they produce less
electricity or they have to install
something that pulls co2 out of the air
it raises the cost of that electricity
so you've
you've legislated regulation
and you've indirectly affected the cost
of energy
that cost
it goes into producing electricity the
consumers of that electricity pay higher
costs
so that's why people don't like
regulations it increases costs
you can also use subsidies and
incentives
we can
help people buy electric cars
give them a tax break
that helps the people that buy the
electric cars which
is kind of a regressive thing because
that's more the wealthy
people that are able to buy a more
expensive car get some tax help and they
get get electric cars
so the the reason we want to do that is
that they then produce less pollution
which is good for everybody they also
expand the market for electric vehicles
which over time makes them cheaper for
everybody but that's also a regressive
policy
and it's one particular thing we've got
a lot of pollution from everywhere
a vehicle transportation is 40 of us
emissions but it's
less than half
then there's a carbon price
let me talk about a really good design
for a carbon
carbon price a carbon tax
there's three parts
and they work like the legs of a stool
the first is a steadily rising fee
on the production of fossil fuels based
on the carbon emissions
paid by the fossil fuel producers so
when they sell coal oil and natural gas
into the economy
they pay another line item on tax to the
irs
for the carbon content of their fuels
we start
there's a bill in congress to do this
called the energy innovation act which
would start at 15 per ton of co2 emitted
from the fuels and rising by ten dollars
more a year so it'll reach about a
hundred dollars
in about 10 years wrap it up please uh
because you're four minutes away over
but
the second part
the second part is the dividend
all the money that's collected
is rebated back to all american
households on an equal per capita basis
so
we will start paying trickle down higher
prices from that carbon fee
if all the money that's collected is put
into a carbon trust and rebated back to
households on an equal basis one share
per adult a half a share per child most
people will come out ahead
most people especially low income and
middle income households will receive
more money in their carbon rebate
than they pay in higher prices total
this helps low-income households affect
higher energy prices it doesn't hurt
them
we advocate for carbon fee and dividend
but that's a carbon tax according to
you know legislation
even though it's not raising revenue for
government spending all the money is
going back to households
if you
like this resolution you're saying we
don't want carbon fee and dividend
the third thing that this stool needs is
to protect u.s manufacturers and
to
hold other countries accountable for
their pollution
how do we do that
with border adjustments as
one of your previous immigrants you can
wrap it up because i'm trying to out of
respect for my committee because uh
otherwise i don't want to recess there
and put it to the end of the day that's
why i want to give respect that you all
came here oh sure because i have another
hearing at one o'clock and i want them
to eat lunch
okay
i teach a class to high school students
called help solve climate change it
covers the science economics policies
and politics of global warming
and it teaches them to advocate for
effective and equitable climate
solutions
carbon fee fian dividend is the most
powerful
effective and equitable
policy we have
as part of that in new hampshire
we did a carbon cash back coalition
project and put a warrant article in 44
towns town meetings in the last two
years
33 of those towns voted to ask their
state and federal legislators to pass
carbon infinitive and legislation
including londonderry
because you mentioned that your voters
in londonderry wouldn't like this
but if you explain simply that
if we put a price on pollution
we'll get less of it through efficient
market forces
if we rebate the money back to
households we have a revenue neutral
policy it's not a tax and in fact most
people come out ahead
and it's the only way that we can use
border adjustments
to hold other countries accountable for
their pollution if you say we're not
going to do a carbon tax you're saying
we're taking away our tools
i want to thank you for your testimony i
i can tell you right now while you were
speaking i brought up my solar usage
because i fell into the trap
and i bought i had 30 panels on my house
thinking it was going to save the day
like today i'm very low because of
cloudy day but i i during winter months
and other you know cloudy days and rainy
days i produce nothing very limited
but i
got sucked in on it and they think it
was the best deal in the world and i've
got these big panels on my roof which
does save me money
but i gotta wait for the sun to come out
yeah i'm saying so i thought i'd throw
that out there on uh on my feelings
on this green energy there that i
thought was the best thing since peanut
butter and i feel like i got used well
that's the difference between subsidies
and letting the market figure it out i
didn't get the subsidy the company that
put them in took the subsidy i was more
looking to save money for my family as
somebody who lives on a budget
so if we have carbon fee and dividend
you'll actually come out ahead you will
end up with uh more money each month in
your carbon dividend
yet in seven years
but thank you anyways well it's
happening in canada they're doing it
there right
we live in new hampshire this bill is
interested in the state of new hampshire
the people who live here not next door
massachusetts anywhere else we're
concerned about new hampshire well the
resolution says we want our state and
federal governments to not carbon tax
and what i'm saying is what we need is a
federal
carbon fee and dividend with border
adjustments
so the resolution it doesn't say just
state the resolution also says federal
which
according to the experts is
our best first step to reduce pollution
around the world in a way that protects
family budgets and helps u.s
manufacturers be even more competitive
in a global marketplace well i thank you
very much for your testimony and uh
there any questions
okay go ahead representative chase
yeah so i i i decided to save my
question for you know because i knew you
had something you'd send calls and send
emails to the committee well thank you
mr chairman for let me ask thank you for
your testimony today so um
you know obviously
you know
a big reason why people want a carbon
tax and a big reason you know why so
many people came here today was um that
they want to see less
carbon-based energy being used in our in
our economy and on our energy grid but
um however
i'm just i'm a little confused and if
you could just briefly briefly explain
um
the reality is we can't to my
understanding and we can't fully move
our entire energy grid to be carbon
neutral or carbon to zeroed out because
a lot of these energy sources like solar
and like wind right they're very
dependent on natural and you know what
the climate is right what the weather is
of the day and even things like nuclear
it takes a lot of energy to get the
plant going and the energy is pretty you
know it stays stagnant at a current
level right to deal with the troughs
that happen throughout the day or even
based on months of the year you need to
be able to you know increase energy or
decrease the amount of energy and the
only fuel source the only kind of energy
source that can do that is coal natural
gas and oil right you can control it's
very easy for a coal plant to control
the amount of energy that you're putting
into the grid or to decrease the amount
of energy you can't really do that
specifically with renewables like solar
and
solar and wind it's very dependent on
the weather and with nuclear it's
completely stagnant right once you get
the plant up that's it so my i'm trying
i'm confused like
do you really think that a carbon tax
could completely make our entire grid
carbon neutral because i just don't see
it in any way being possible yes i do i
think it's the only way we can make it
happen
okay thank you well thank you because
can i respond yeah real quick please if
you're right well
if we had started carbon fee and devon
in 30 years ago we would have all the
solutions that you're saying we don't
have right now
we have a market failure
when you have a market failure the
market doesn't produce all the things
you need to get the maximum benefit
the market fails to account for the
costs of using fossil fuels in their
price
the the pollution that comes out of
fossil fuels is free
and economists say
in order to correct the market failure
you can do policies lots of different
policies but the most
direct way to affect this market failure
to wrap it up is to put the price of
pollution into the cost of fossil fuels
so
yeah nuclear uh takes a long time to
ramp up and ramp down but when you're
not using electricity you can generate
hydrogen you can split water with the
extra electricity that you're using and
then you can use that later when you
want electricity
more than what you're getting from
nuclear we need to get the market
solving a lot of these problems in a lot
of different ways and that's why carbon
price is a better solution than any of
the specific
chipping away at the edges i'm trying to
give as much leeway as i can out of
respect because you took the time to
come in but i'm asking you you know
because otherwise i don't want to have
to
recess this committee
and then come back this afternoon for it
and have you sitting all day that's why
i'm trying to push you
so i don't have to do that you know what
i'm saying out of respect for the other
speakers
i thank you for your testimony and
appreciate it thank you for your time i
have to let my committee lunch that's
why
okay um
catherine gage
three minutes uh opposes the bill
and uh welcome
if it's repetitious on what was already
said we appreciate if there's anything
new oh thank you so much for hearing
that how old you by the way 18 18 god
bless you we we like when we see the
young people involved oh thank you so
much for listening to me and i want to
thank you is it your dad
yes i was made i want to thank him
because you know i'm going to look to
these here because i'm in i'm in the
learning process this should have went
to the state and you know to engine i
mean um science and technology
you know because they're the duty
experts but i'm we're trying to deal
with it here in my committee
welcome thank you
um so i oppose hr17 because i think a
federal carbon fian dividend with border
carbon adjustments which is of the
three-part carbon price done correctly
is really necessary um for our safety
and it will also really help the people
and the economy because with the
dividend coming back 85 percent of all
households or and 99
of the lowest of the poorest households
will either come out ahead or break even
under this policy they'll be getting
more money in their dividend that
they'll be paying at higher prices due
to the carbon fee and meanwhile this
policy is getting us 90 percent of the
way to net zero by 2050 and there's a
bill in congress
called the energy innovation act that's
carbon pricing done well
and um
another
problem we would have with opposing
carbon pricing at the federal level is
that border carbon adjustments can be
used by other countries that have carbon
prices and they can put border carbon
adjustments on us so that when we trade
with them we have to pay them money
because we don't have a carbon tax so we
have to pay the carbon tax to them if we
don't have a carbon tax here in the u.s
so for example the eu is going to start
doing this on us in 2026
and canada and the uk are also talking
about it so
if they're having a carbon tax if we
don't have a government tax we'll be
paying money for our carbon to other
countries whereas if we have a carbon
tax in the us we'll be able to keep that
money here in our economy and give it
back to citizens
so i think that's why
a lot of citizens support it and i hope
you'll consider opposing this resolution
because it
limits our options especially at the
federal level well thank you they're
very impressive on your testimony i
appreciate it uh do you have written
testimony i submitted something online
okay okay
um representative moffatt
thank you mr i'm supposed to ask a
question so my question is did you know
that i read your concord monitor piece
yesterday and that i thought it was very
well put together oh thank you and i did
speak with your dad on the phone last
night and i we're out of time and i
there are a lot a lot a lot of pieces to
this i wish we had time to get into but
i will say that
we will have an executive session
scheduled on this at some point and
within this committee we will
be able to talk about some of the things
that we just don't have time for now and
i believe it's it'll be on youtube so
you may i think you'd be interested to
tune into that i'm going to give a
little leeway so if you've got some
questions for please ask her because 18
year olds will come in here and get
involved i owe them i owe her that
well thank you miss chair i will ask
when i i was going to ask your dad but i
know we have some time constraints but
global warming used to be the term that
we heard a lot about and it kind of
morphed into climate change because
there was
questions and data that maybe global
warming is not happening there's a
spectrum of
so my question is
did you know that 7 800 years ago
greenland which
eventually became a big ice sheet
800 years ago there were many
settlements on greenland which indicated
that the world clearly was much warmer
then than it is now or since then
because obviously you get cold and those
those settlements went away from
greenland did did you know that did you
have any thoughts on that
800 years ago 800 900 years ago many
southern greenland viking
settlements
that's all my family the vikings
i'm sorry i didn't know much about that
i just know that the world set up as we
have it now like for example with all
the people living on coasts it's not
really
gonna be sustainable to live with a
warmer climate and the problems that
will come with it
okay i i kind of ambush you but that's
something that we'll probably get into
an exact thank you mr chair i'm sorry
you're welcome i know i had some
concerns like on my property um i have
so many insurance companies already
figured this out i've got a hundred year
flood plan and then there's a 50 flood
plan yeah and 25 on my property you know
i mean because i have wetlands and
everything behind me so they they know
exactly when that land flooded over many
years through climate or whatever to the
shifting of the moon and sun and all
that other stuff so i just so you know
it was pretty interesting to me when i
bought my property
you know because whether it was in a
flood zone or not you know in accordance
with the studies over the years but i
want to thank you very much uh for
coming in here and i hope you tell your
friends there and your dad took a
picture of you testifying
you know i mean for for history there
all right
thank you very much thank you all very
much
okay five minutes i'm hoping he can
narrow it down to three uh walter payne
from exeter and he opposes the bill
and um
the uh and if it's
something we have already heard if you
get anything new please bring it forward
there's been a lot of talk about the uh
specific uh bills talk closer to mike
because
my hearing's bad and i'm uh overtired no
one's here much better because i look at
lips you know when you're speaking so
that's why you see me looking sure
um so uh yes i do oppose hr 17
but before i look at what it does say
i'd like to talk a bit about what it
does not say
it does not deny that the climate is
changing it does not deny that burning
fossil fuels is the main reason for that
it does not deny that climate change is
already causing extreme weather that is
making life in america and the rest of
the world both less safe and pleasant as
well as more expensive
which is a bad combination
it does not deny that we therefore need
to quickly phase out fossil fuels in
order to avoid ever larger reductions in
our standard of living and ever greater
expenses to protect us from extreme
weather and to repair the damage we
cannot prevent
indeed it implicitly acknowledges that
carbon emissions are a problem wherever
they occur even across the globe in
china or india which is of course true
ten or even five years ago such a
resolution might well have denied one or
more of these statements
that's progress
all it's taken is an unrelenting string
of record floods fires heat waves
hurricanes and tornadoes for most
serious people to accept that climate
change is real and is wreaking havoc all
around the earth
some of this damage can be quantified
destroyed homes and businesses reduce
crop yields and fish catches other
damage is impossible for price
lives lost natural wonders erased as
well as smaller losses such as cool
evening breezes in the summer
more mosquitoes and deer ticks and fewer
days for kids to play in the snow or
skate on ponds well these costs are not
being imposed by government they're at
least as much a burden as attacks
and a steadily arising one
so we need to act today to avoid the
worst effects of climate change and
eventually regain the benefits of a
stable climate this is the type of
problem
familiar to every parent farmer business
owner indeed anyone who wants to improve
anything
you have to sacrifice something today
for a better tomorrow
and here a better tomorrow is in
comparison to the do-nothing default
which is continual
climate catastrophe
there are two reasons this is
politically difficult for climate change
establish a stable climate is a global
public good it exists for all or it
exists for none
so any individual's action is
insignificant and even small countries
can free ride on the efforts of large
countries
the time secondly the time between
sacrifice and reward is much longer than
between planting and harvesting a crop
even while immediate action is necessary
the results of reducing emissions will
not be apparent for more than a decade
hr 17 offers no solutions
it simply wants to rule out taxing
carbon even though that's widely
considered the most efficient and
fairest way to reduce emissions
it objects that a carbon tax will quote
manipulate consumer decisions suggesting
that the switch to renewables which of
course is what is needed will be a
nefarious process rather than the stated
goal of public policy though work its
way through economic incentives the way
market economies work all over the world
while no one wants to unnecessarily pay
more for anything the relevant question
is whether fossil fuel tax an explicit
one will cost us less
than the climate tax
over the long run
the resolution raises two issues that
are addressed by well-designed carbon
taxes and there's been a lot of talk of
this so i'll just mention at the end of
that paragraph uh that more
fundamentally the current price of
fossil fuels does not include the cost
of damage they they do now
through conventional pollution that
harms the health of millions of
americans and in the future climate
change
every time we fill up our cars we're
getting an artificial bargain at the
expense of future generations
a carbon tax will shift energy-intensive
manufacturing this was also mentioned
without reducing global emissions this
is of course the global public good
problem problem that's dealt with the
border carbon adjustment
whether this resolution passes or fails
will not alter the atmosphere by one
molecule of co2 but it sends a bad
message by trying to score political
points when we need to begin working
together to solve the greatest challenge
in human history and one that has no
political affiliation
most of us are not going to be around to
pay the climate tax by the time becomes
prohibitively high
see a couple of people here but not too
many
but our children and grandchildren will
be along with everyone else who comes
after us for centuries to come even
though they will have played no role in
creating or ignoring the problem
an intergenerational form of taxation
without representation
if your child wasn't feeling well and a
doctor discovered a tumor would you
ignore it hoping that you might not be
around the time serious harm can you
hold one second i apologize sure if any
member here wants to go grab a sandwich
before one o'clock
okay because
apparently they don't it just keeps
going uh please go get something to eat
uh because i know some have
have to eat or drink so i'm out of
respect for my members here
okay so just get up and go to the
cafeteria grab something quick for one
o'clock thank you okay go ahead yeah
sure so um if your child wasn't feeling
well and a doctor discovered a tumor
would you ignore it hoping that you
might not be around by the time it
caused serious harm
do you knowingly let it drip in your
roof become a stream and ruin your house
so that's it i've i submitted this
electronically i have some links at the
end to the subject i discuss which
obviously can't go into a great length
but the links are from actually people
far more knowledgeable than i they can
discuss that mention public goods and
negative externalities border carbon
adjustment that sort of thing
i also just quickly
in the earlier testimony had very short
answers to some of the questions that
were asked so for instance uh you asked
earlier what to do once significant
numbers of people are driving evs how do
we prepare pay to maintain our roads
the the answer is through a
vehicle miles
traveled tax which every year when you
get inspected which we're doing every
year
they take the miles subtract from the
previous year how many miles you've
traveled multiply by some factor based
on the weight of your car and whatever
it costs
i think that's what they're planning on
uh something like that there because
we're actually losing money
uh on the gas tax to maintain the roads
but as was noted
the at the federal level i don't know
about the state level the federal level
the highway trust fund is not even
paying for our roads we're already
subsidizing them from general revenues
not a great idea um the other thing
regarding uh the elderly in your
district who who complain about their
energy bills
yes a true carbon tax
would raise their energy bills
very little at first but after five ten
years it would be significant however
as long as all of the
revenues from that fee are rebated back
to households america in america on a
per capita basis
the average elderly person who's living
probably not in a large dwelling
probably isn't flying around the world
probably doesn't have a speed boat is
using less fossil fuels than the
national average and therefore would get
a payment back from the government
uh monthly under the bill they discussed
that actually would exceed their
increased cost of energy so they have to
depend on the government you're telling
me and hopefully the government comes
through like a welfare is that what
you're saying
well you uh people who are over 65
generally do get their social security
payments well they paid into that social
security that's their money right and
very much the same medicare that's their
money coming back very much the same way
the money would be coming in
from from the from the
carbon fee
every day
and once a month
it would be divvied up and rebated out
and that's a condition that is built
into the bill it's not like it's like
put in and then they come back three
years later and try to extract it all
right well i i thank you dear appreciate
that yeah
real quick yeah yeah
i know we're running
my question has to do with mother nature
and climate change and uh i admire your
passion your knowledge there's just
recently a volcano eruption in the
pacific i'm sure you're aware of that so
in around 1818 it was a gigantic
volcanic eruption you may or may not be
aware of it in indonesia and it was so
incredibly
powerful that it changed the climate for
a couple years in new hampshire after
that happened
we had 12 months it snowed every month
and this is when all these people got
the heck out of new hampshire because it
was so cold farmers went to warmer
places so
given that mother nature changed the
climate in that way
when that happens again we just had a
volcanic eruption right when there's
another krakatoa type of eruption that's
going to lower the temperature of the
whole world like as has happened is it
possible that if there is global warming
which we can debate
would might that not be a good thing if
it tempers the next uh mother nature
volcanic climate change cooling first
i'd like to make a general question a
general comment
i'm not a scientist
okay i took high school biology and
chemistry and physics
and frankly i don't think the new new
hampshire legislature is the place to
discover the truth or falsity of
scientific concepts that's generally
done in our leading universities and i'm
sure that when you take your child to
the doctor and he says you as he has
conditioned x y or z
and the fellow has gone to medical
medical school or fellow gal has gone to
medical school and gone through a decade
of training you probably don't say
hey my buddy at work told me that that's
not a real phenomena maybe you do i
don't know but myself i generally trust
experts in certain fields who have spent
their smart people have spent their
lives studying stuff
i'm not going to be able to
to prove or disprove climate change to
anyone in this room but regarding the
specific question i think it's very
important to understand
that data from any phenomena whether
you're talking about weather
or stock prices or political popularity
has
perhaps a trend
and around that trend it also has noise
right so if you look at
if you look at uh
the stock market on any given day it's
like
all day long most of that is noise it
means nothing however if you look at a
long-term trend and you see that the dow
is wherever it is it's tripled in in 15
years
that's significant right
and and that's something that that that
we need to look at but the little little
you know anyone who's trying to manage
their investment portfolio
by by trading stocks at their lunch
break is probably not helping themselves
likewise with climate
yes you'll get people who find these
little anomalies and say oh this this
you know on january 3rd
five years ago it was actually
much warmer than it was today so
obviously we're not getting climate
change we're not getting uh warming
is is not very useful
now
a a a
volcano kind of a random event i don't
know that there's any trend involved in
volcanic eruptions related to climate
sure sure so so yes that volcano event
volcanic event will temporarily suppress
uh global temperatures in the same way
that when we actually when our cars
spewed out all sorts of particulates all
that stuff in the air suppressed uh
warming which is why after we cleaned up
our cars from conventional pollution we
actually started seeing
more more true warming because the the
there's less of that stuff blocking so
to answer your question
the the trend
in temperatures and other effects sea
level rise and all the things that are
correlated with rises in co2
are are unmistakable
to people who do this for a living okay
and yes the the volcano that just
erupted might have some slight
temporary
uh reduction uh a little bit of noise
but it's not going to change that trend
as long as we continue to emit co2
the co2 in the atmosphere is going to
continue to rise the methane is going to
continue to rise and we're going to
continue to get warming with all that
entails so
you know focus we really have to focus
on the trends not the noise i think
yeah
thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much i appreciate you
missing some of your lunch
okay i'm going to close the hearing on
house concur
was the bill
on um h.r 17 and
i was gonna
i thought we'd have more time but uh
when you testify
i don't know how many we we don't have
anyone testifying on your bill
uh so
i'd like you to talk to us a few minutes
after
on some of the air
you know that's going on because i'm
willing you know this is out of my area
and i'm willing to get educated on it
here because
i know thank you
i have
i'm very disappointed with the executive
summary because it doesn't follow the
facts of the report
it's written by politicians it's not
written by the scientists if you go back
and look at the actual
scientific
report that basically they in there say
oh you know we got one one and a half uh
degree change to four and a half degree
change depending on what the model is
and they say
we've been saying this for years and
it's wrong and all due respect i know
one of the climate scientists that was a
lead author on this report and she is a
legitimate climate scientist
and it's the climate scientists
climate scientists they get the money
from nasa doe whatever so all being
funded by the same cabal that says we
are going to give grants to those that
support that point of view
propaganda and i can show you the money
flow
i'm sorry but there's a sign
exxon mobil had a science group in the
70s and 80s and they found the same
thing that these reports say now
they shuttered their
climate science group town
there's documentation there's a pulitzer
prize
series of articles by inside climate
news where they looked at
what exxon decided around 1990 rather
than go with the science and
admit that the carbon that they have on
the ground
she's not going to keep growing in value
they decided
is that
carbon dioxide increase a problem of the
significance and the hype that you guys
want to make it it is is it is it so the
gray shaded i i referenced to you a
climate report that looked at looked at
carbon dioxide over the last
435 million years by looking at stable
isotopes
okay
and basically do you know what the
temperature of the earth was then they
said no land-based ice then it was ten
to twenty we went through we went
through glaciation periods not humans
we weren't here sea level was 200 feet
higher
all of our coastal cities would be under
hundreds of feet lower that's why they
were able to come across the bearing
straight in and and come into north
america during the glacial period when
more ice builds up on land the seas go
down yes that was that way 15 000 years
ago
that was when that melted seas rose
hundreds of feet
they did the perspective that you guys
are pushing is that the world is going
to come to a very
a fossil fuel producer and that's not
good for new hampshire
um
it's been in congresswoman
so um
i just i'm going to ask a two-part
question is um when i assume you uh
you've you know about the nullification
crisis i believe of 1837
and um you know how that would kind of
how that those legal precedents would
kind of play into what you're kind of
describing here in this house concurrent
resolution and i'm also wondering how
you would imagine in your mind how how
states would be
nullifying um what you would view as
unconstitutional acts by the federal
government that um that would possibly
violate the state's sovereignty over
specific issues issues that the federal
government doesn't have sovereignty over
well i i'll answer by an example we we
recently had two supreme court cases
addressing
actions by
the federal government in
implementing vaccine mandates
one was you trying to use the powers of
osha
to uh
have that uh
that vaccine mandates relevant to
anybody who worked in a business over a
hundred uh people in size and the other
one came from the
medical side saying that vaccine
mandates can be
implemented in the medical community
one
was
viewed by the
u.s
supreme court as unconstitutional that
is the osha
derived standard
and the other the medical standard was
allowed to stand
so now
states have
have in many states have passed
resolutions or state laws saying
you cannot mandate people in our state
to
to get vaccines and
i think
the state that's leading the charge on
this right now is florida
florida says no vaccine mandates allowed
yet the federal government's saying you
must mandate
so
how do you
where does the state
and how does the state deal with that
issue and i think
the the
the proper uh
the answer is the state continues to
stand up and say the state of florida is
not supporting this and we will not
permit prosecution of this particular
issue and it may go to further court
decisions but the voice of the people
must be heard and the only place that
voice can be articulated is out of state
government people on their own as
individuals don't have that authority
that's what this testimony had said the
states have to stand up for their
citizens
uh follow-up guide
yeah thank you um so i i i guess so the
reason why i ask these questions is
because we're going to be addressing um
a constitutional amendment later that
would try to make new hampshire
independent this a lot of the ideas in
this are kind of related to that so
that's kind of the reason why i'm asking
some of these questions and um so to
clarify
to clarify regarding and i'm going to
ask a question about the court cases
that you just asked um so obviously the
osha case was specifically regarding the
federal authority
to use the the osha to mandate within um
businesses right that are regulated by
the federal government and obviously
that was ruled you know unconstitutional
they couldn't use osha for that mandate
but with the with the other the medical
requirement if i'm not mistaken you can
correct me if i'm wrong but would you
would you believe that it had to do with
the fact that states have taken federal
dollars right medicare and medicaid
dollars right for example new hampshire
has taken those and we established the
granite advantage healthcare program and
by taking those dollars there are
certain strings attached so if we wanted
could we theoretically if we wanted to
just forego those medicare and medicaid
dollars and not implement any federal
mandates regarding um you know
any kind of uh health care mandates that
they want regarding attach those monies
can we just forego that money and you
know preserve our sovereignty haven't we
kind of given by adopting that program
we've given away our sovereignty by
choice
uh i think that is the problem the
federal government uh implements
programs and said all right if you want
this this money you have to agree to
these conditions if you want the road
tax money to you know uh you you have to
agree to our speed limit rules and our
other rules associated with your highway
system so the federal government has has
illegitimately put constraints on
on these in order to
pull power from the states and
aggrandize that to the federal
government and at some point you come to
the place where you say
no we're not going to do it
we're not going to we're not going to
permit this and we're going to stand for
our state's rights
thank you for thank you for clarifying
that i appreciate it
yeah um
other okay representative
so
um thank you for taking my question
thank you
um
so
in the case in new hampshire for example
um
at university of new hampshire the
president of the university
felt compelled or actually i think he
probably wanted to do this he
supported a vaccine mandate because unh
was
uh receiving
millions in
national institute of health and other
federal
federal funds
right so and
this wasn't contested by the usnh board
of trustees or
i don't think anything i didn't hear any
strong opposition to this but
are you saying that
what
by by adhering to jeffersonian
principles
if
the people of new hampshire said
we don't want this to happen at unh
that that should take precedent over a
federal
uh federal law or federal edict that's
not been contested in the supreme court
at a minimum i'm saying
the state of new hampshire has an
obligation to say stop with that
nonsense
stop it
at a minimum the voice of the state
should be heard
we disagree with your
mandates
and and i agree with you i i think the
uh the the the president of unh and the
board they all went
along with it because they probably were
in agreement with it
but i don't believe that is the position
of most of the citizens of this state
right
so
may i have a follow-up yes go ahead so
how would we do this would we
the legislature is responsible for
making those statements by resolutions
and we have a resolution that we just
discussed here before this on carbon tax
telling the federal government no we
don't want your carbon taxes we don't
want any of that nonsense
it's the obligation of the legislature
to be the voice of its people and say no
uh any other questions
if you take a look at uh what i had that
researcher do christina did a good job
on it
15 years in this committee here
um i've probably seen this
i don't know eight times
nine times
we've passed it under republicans and i
tell that under democrats
okay and uh i mean it's just the nature
of the beast there that's the way
elections have consequences
so and i mean i have all the
blurbs and everything else over the
years that were done in most a lot of
them in my name
okay just so you know
uh on this here
i'm a true believer in you know
understated rights
and the federal government getting out
of our homes and our life and pockets
but at times others are no
disrespect to my friends on the left
prefer you know always prefer the
government
to be the answer or when it comes to
this here and
you know and i'm sure my friend coffin
down there
but anyways and that's been my
you know i mean 120 years in here read
for the committee members read the
different statements in there and you'll
see
one of the most
put in there was a great guy that served
there democrat mike rollo really did his
homework
you know on this here many years ago you
know and he was pretty sharp guy mike
rolo but we disagreed on that
so
i thank you for bringing this forward
and i don't have a question i just
wanted to make sure that you're aware of
what you already said it came forward
and
uh
and we'll take it and see where the
committee's at um you know and hopefully
so are there any other questions
okay with that i'm going to close the
hearing
on
hcr8
and we do have written testimony from
my testimony i had you didn't
pick up mine did you
oh right here
you got another one there there's a
there's a bunch we've passed down to the
left i can catch up to what go ahead
okay
okay that's that one there
the branch you ready
representative
is here
okay
we close that one and i'm going to open
up
house resolution 15 a resolution
condemning the communist party of china
and the people's republic of china
and the sponsor of representative
lebranch uh welcome member of the
committee and the floor is yours sir
thank you mr chairman and
hello members of the state and federal
relations and veterans affairs committee
for the record my name is representative
tony the branch and i represent the town
of amherst i'm here to today to
introduce hr15 condemning the communist
party of china and the people's republic
of china
i will now read the resolution just to
give everybody an understanding of what
the resolution is
whereas the communist party of china has
ruled over the people's republic of
china with an iron fist
for 73 years since its founding in 1949
whereas the people's republic of china
has a legally occupied tibet since 1951
and whereas the people's republic of
china has illegally occupied xianjing
since 1949 and whereas the communist
party of china and the people's republic
of china are committing genocide against
the weaker population and other ethnic
and religious groups
whereas the communist party of china and
the people's republic of china have
harvested organs of falun gong
practitioners and other political
prisoners
and whereas the communist party of china
and the people's republic of china have
violated one country two systems policy
which gave hong kong special autonomy
whereas the communist party of china and
the prc have violently and
undemocratically clamped down on dissent
in hong kong and across the country
whereas the people's republic of china
has illegally constructed artificial
islands in the south china sea and have
laid claim to other countries sovereign
territorial waters
and whereas the people's republic of
china is increasingly becoming a threat
to global democracy whereas the
communist party of china the people's
republic of china have made it their
goal to just destabilize america and its
allies and whereas the republic of china
taiwan is one of the world's strongest
democracies now therefore be it resolved
by the new hampshire house
that the new hampshire house of
representatives stands with the people
of hong kong and commends the republic
of china taiwan for its strong
democratic system and that the new new
hampshire house of representatives
condemns the communist party of the
people's republic of china in the
strongest possible terms and calls on
the federal government to do more to
curb the communist party of china's
global influence impose more sanctions
on the communist party of china and to
either eliminate the one china policy or
to recognize the republic of china
taiwan as the official china
the house clerk will forward copies to
all the parties listed below
um and i have an amendment to add the uh
people's republic of china's ambassador
and the taiwanese ambassador to that
list um
now i think we can all agree that what
china is doing today amendment now uh i
do have the amendment okay no that's
really good
i think we can all agree that what china
today is doing is horrible
and that's actually something i agreed
with former president trump on is that
we need to do more to limit china's
global influence
i believe that we in the new hampshire
house need to use our voice to call on
the federal government and our
delegation to do more
and with that i ask that the committee
passed this resolution with an ought to
pass motion and thank you for giving me
the opportunity to speak
wow
i'm very impressed with this
you know so
that's all i'm going to say on that one
any questions or anything on this
okay yes
i just have a question thank you for
taking my question thank you i uh about
the harvesting of organs from uyghurs um
i just it's the first i've heard about
it when i first read your proposal um
do we have has the u.n provided support
for this uh or is there some sort of
validation
i mean if it's going on it's terrible
obviously but and can you can you do a
little deeper dive into are they
actually like
killing live people and then pulling
their organs out or are they uh
blood testing them for when they die
that they can harvest their organ organs
or putting putting them on wait lists
for
organ donation or i would just hate to
say yeah i
support a resolution that might have
something that might be contested
i can definitely get the committee more
primary sources on that
i can read a little thing just from my
research on this is that since 1984 uh
the removal of organs from executed
criminals has been legal and the fact
that criminals
in china include political prisoners and
religious minorities that is uh
definitely problematic and that is what
happened with these uh falun gong
practitioners falun gong was not even a
religion it was just a
it was sort of like yoga as we know it
today it was used by people to uh as a
sort of spiritual release uh and the
communist party of china saw it as a
threat
and therefore outlawed it and
because of that they harvested the
organs of those falun gong practitioners
and
like i said i can get more articles and
raw data on that
if i may just ask and help you out on
that there might while you ask that
question representative uh my clerk all
she did was type in china harvest organs
which i've known about and yeah and
we've heard about it before but there's
so many articles on it nbc
uh has china forcefully harvest organs
from detainees tribute uh tribute
tribunal concludes
okay
19. yeah there's so many articles that
are out there
june 14th 2021 u.n human rights experts
alarmed by organ harvesting
um 20 july united nations concerned okay
um i mean just and then there's videos
and other stuff there on you know what's
going on
so yeah it's all out there
you know i mean
on they're nasty
wikipedia even has a
tylon gong like you which are uh
practicing
practitioners in china what's going on
common knowledge actually in my circles
just uh so you'll know rather than it's
right it's out there you know the
information in front of us
okay uh any other questions
yes sir representative marford famous
chair uh
great work on this um but i do have a
couple of questions uh do you think that
the
the wuhan virus and and the or what some
folks call the china virus or whatever
or the way that the
communist leadership in that country
handled and has handled and is handling
the uh
the pandemic crisis
do you think that one of the whereases
maybe should address that development or
what do you think about that
uh
to that question thank you for the
question uh specifically i have not done
much research on what is happening over
in china in response to covet 19. so i
do not know the specifics but i just
know that this is now in the committee's
hands and the committee can do whatever
it feels necessary on this bill
if follow-up you did say there's an
amendment percolating though right yes i
have an amendment that would add the uh
ambassador of china to the united states
to the list of uh
places the house clerk will forward this
copy of this resolution and i also added
the taiwanese uh ambassador to that list
because if we're condemning china we we
should probably be actually telling them
that uh it needs to get to china somehow
okay yeah thank you for that i get my
point is that if if there is an
amendment percolating if
if
you
wanted the amendment to include
something about the pandemic this would
be an opportunity for that if if that
worked for you it's up to you with with
the amendment that you're working on
well
right it's the committee's amendment i
mean bill right now
and if we want to put something on there
we could very easily do that yeah in the
uh ols amendment's already drafted and
it's just sitting on the desk over there
right thank you
okay any other questions
with that okay thank you
is there anyone else that wanted to
speak on this that has not
submitted the card
with that i'm going to close house
resolution 15.
the census on that uh what
representative moffat brought up
okay
i'm going to open up the hearing on
house resolution 16 a resolution calling
for the federal government to construct
a nuclear waste
repository to permanently store our
nation's nuclear waste
and
the
prime sponsors here representative
lebranch welcome once again
thank you chairman and thank you members
of the state and federal relations
committee and veterans affairs
for the record my name is representative
turn the branch i represent the town of
amherst
and i'm here to introduce hr16
this house resolution very short very
simple
and i'm just going to keep my remarks
short and not waste the committee's time
all this says is that we want a
permanent place to store our nuclear
waste
currently in the united states
we were building a nuclear waste
repository to store this waste because
you know nuclear waste stays radioactive
for thousands of years
we were building a place to store that
waste permanently in the middle of the
nevada desert
and that plan got defunded under the
obama administration
so currently the united states has no
permanent solution to
its nuclear waste
and the reason that this is important
for the state of new hampshire is that
we do have a nuclear power facility in
seabrook and all this says is that we
don't want nuclear fuel and nuclear
spent nuclear fuel in our backyard we
want it to be stored underground in the
middle of the desert not close to
anybody
so that it can degrade slowly and be
away from humans because we don't want
you know nuclear waste currently it's
stored right next to the nuclear power
plant if something goes wrong not only
do we have the nuclear power plant to
deal with but the waste that's next to
it that could be affected by whatever
event occurs
so this is saying that we would like
our waste to be
stored somewhere out of the state uh not
anywhere close to us
or or any uh you know human civilization
so
that's
all this house resolution calls for and
i know it doesn't say specifically where
we would like it to be built but uh it's
at least asking the federal government
to
step up on this uh issue
i'll take any questions
are there any questions
representative moffitt
sure thank you mr chair yes uh thank you
take my question representative uh yucca
mountain i think
nevada was the
sound like the best possible place but
uh senator harry reid and
and some of other folks with him uh said
that they would never support that and i
guess i understand that my question is
you call for federal government to
construct a nuclear waste repository
if a
foreign country
i could name several possibilities
kazakhstan for example
ironically uh but
if if we if we can't put it anywhere in
america and if we can't do yucca
mountain i don't know where we're gonna
go
uh
what about
a foreign repository
do you have you looked and talked about
that thought about that
i personally and thank you for the
question i personally have not heard of
any uh foreign waste repository plans
but i definitely do think that that
could be a viable solution because we
want this to be as far away as
as possible from us because we don't
want to
have to deal with any of the leakage or
possibilities of contamination to the
general population
so
i i definitely think that that is a
possibility and the federal government
should look into any possibility for
permanent storage of this waste
thank you
any other okay did you have a question
you all said
anyone else
okay
um
i'm not sure where i'm at on this here
do we have nowhere and seabrook are you
saying that seabrook is the only area in
new hampshire where they store
to my knowledge uh the nuclear waste
from seabrook is stored on seabrook but
i do not know of any other locations in
new hampshire that nuclear waste
such as nuclear
fuel is stored in new hampshire
at least that is my understanding of the
situation
okay thank you i get to look into this a
little more
we don't have anyone else
speaking
okay um thank you then uh
well if anyone else wants to speak
uh
then i am going to close the hearing on
h.r 16
and
the next hearing is at
2 45
that went quick so what i'm going to do
is a um exec a couple of bills
okay
um
you know you know why harry reid put a
stop to it with obama and the rest of us
because they've got minerals out there
and they they're buying up all the land
and the government's calling it
monuments and they're going in and
taking it and the chinese own it oh
yeah part of the reason jerry went to
prison
i didn't have that on
i'm gonna have to say that again
i didn't have this thing once
okay um
open up the hearing on hr18
and
on a resolution urging congress to
remove the exception from the 13th
amendment except as a punishment from
crime whereof the party shall have been
duly convicted and welcome
representative amanda bolden
who supports the bill and the prime
sponsor and said four minutes
thank you mr chairman thanks for hearing
about this bill today
i sent around a handout of the 13th
amendment for your reference
because sometimes when bills reference
a portion of an entire text you need the
entire text to understand completely
i come from
slave owning people recently the
washington post put out an article
of the a list of every congressman
who's ever served in us congress who had
slaves
and i searched the word bolden and yep
there were two people that i'm related
to who served in u.s congress and owned
slaves
my 11th great grandfather landed on this
continent in the early 1600s and my
fifth great grandfather was one of the
congressmen that i'm related to who was
a slave owner serving in congress in the
1800s representing virginia
and you know how here we
write down a lot of the like we'll print
the remarks you know the speeches that
are made on the house floor and record
them i've read
uh speeches from my very boring
fifth grade grandfather james wood
bolden and he argued passionately in
defense of slavery and he said that it's
a man's natural right to own another man
and he compared
the ownership of another person to the
ownership of a horse
so
he was also super irritated with women
being involved in politics and i'm
really sure he wouldn't like me
but you guys wouldn't like him because
he's also the kind of uh representative
who talks forever and ever and ever and
it's literally pages and pages of his
stupid speech and it's so boring um and
i'll try not to be like him today
um but he was the kind congressman that
as soon as he went up to the well you'd
leave to go to the bathroom
[Music]
so i'm sure that he would be
disappointed to know that just a few
years after he died the 13th amendment
was ratified
freeing the slaves in the united states
so the 13th amendment banned slavery it
nullified the fugitive slave clause and
it nullified the three-fifths compromise
but there was a loophole in the 13th
amendment you can read it on the handout
it's in bold
it allows for slavery still
if the enslaved person has been
convicted of a crime
and this interpretation isn't just mine
um in the case of roughin the
commonwealth in 1871 the supreme court
declared that an inmate is a slave of
the state
due to this loophole almost as soon as
the 13th amendment was ratified states
and municipalities began passing petty
crime laws
which at the time were known as the
black codes
these laws criminalized actions that
were most likely to be committed by
recently freed slaves
such as loitering and vagrancy because
if you had a home and you left it
now you have no home if you had a job
but you were freed from it now you have
no job
some of these laws prohibited former
slaves from holding certain types of
jobs and then punish them
for being unemployed
plantations accustomed to slave labor
were suffering a labor shortage as a
result of the ratification of the 13th
amendment so area prisons sold prisoner
labor to the plantations on the cheap
the prisoners themselves received no
money for their work as returning to
their former slave life was considered a
fair punishment for the crime of
loitering vagrancy unemployment etc
the black codes have been expanding ever
since
albeit under different terminology such
as the war on drugs mandatory minimum
sentencing and so forth
in the early 1900s the black codes were
used to justify over-incarceration and
harassment of italian-americans during a
period of time in which italians were
widely hated in the united states so
effectively my ancestors defended a
system that likely resulted in the
harassment of the chairman's ancestors
the exception in the 13th amendment laid
the essential groundwork for the mass
incarceration we see today
in fact the prison population in
proportion to the total population has
increased by more than 10 times since
the ratification of the 13th amendment
in other words the prison population is
outpacing the u.s population by a
multiplier of more than 10.
and while my fifth grade grandfather
didn't live to see it many of the people
he served with
ensured that the 13th amendment didn't
really have teeth
so today it's my hope that this body can
reject everything my family stood for
and ask our current congress
to close the loophole in the 13th
amendment let's make james wood bolden
roll over in his grave and by the way
here's how much james wood bolden is my
ancestor his middle name
is my grandfather's first name my
father's middle name and my brother's
middle name
so this is like literally my bloodline
um
and as an aside i just want to mention
that support for closing this loophole
in the 13th amendment is um
supported by kanye west
who went to president trump in 2018 and
asked for the same thing that i'm asking
for today
and i also want to mention that the bill
has bipartisan co-sponsorship or i guess
because of you guys
tripartisan or something
so
thanks for your time and i hope i was
brief enough
okay thank you will you take questions
of course okay
any questions for representative
representative
thank you mr chair thank you uh
representative bolden for your testimony
um
that's a couple questions so first uh do
you
i think
do you like you know we're talking about
the black codes and
uh do you like you know do you still do
you believe in the you know the
the school to prison pipeline for
for for african-americans in our in our
country
you believe that exists sorry
yeah i absolutely
um it's unfortunate that i think that um
so i i had a nanny when i was a kid who
insisted that if you put baby oil in
your belly button it can help with a
cold you know and so sometimes there's
things that the people before us believe
and they they want to implement and as
time goes by we realize it doesn't make
sense but if we let those things kind of
grow and expand they they become
unrecognizable compared to their former
their original version and totally out
of control and i think that
um probably the people who wanted to
reinvigorate and enable slavery through
the loophole in the 13th amendment
didn't anticipate that one day their uh
the the white people that would be born
after them would also be caught up in
the same sort of system
of
mass incarceration and it's certainly
seen
largely in new hampshire where
[Music]
the
the war on drugs
and the
the issue of widespread heroin abuse and
things like that
wasn't
much discussed when it was uh
i think
um just a black problem you know for
lack of a better term and now when it
becomes an issue in new hampshire which
is mostly white suddenly people and
politicians want to talk about it so i
think it's
it's definitely one of those things
where it started in one format you know
it was just a dumb
baby oil in your belly button sort of
thing and
you know if you keep listening to and
implementing that line of thinking
um
there's just more insanity down the line
so i do think that in the long term it
affects every aspect of our lives
do you know the name of the largest uh
prison in our country
um
no i don't
what is it
the uh angola state prison
i've heard of this yeah and one final
one follow-up good um and just my last
question did you know um
did you know that in uh
we're in this pandemic
um and we you know we're trying to make
sure that we can speed up the production
of things that would hopefully kept us
that would keep us safe
so would you believe that the state of
new york
used
prison labor to
to to basically produce
hand sanitizer at six dollars and ten
cents a gallon
um i believe that i know that even today
there's a lot of products that you can
purchase for example in walmart that are
made by um slaves in american prisons
and in foreign prisons um and
there's the story of this guy
who was eventually he was tried six
times for the same murder this was just
in like the late 90s until recently
and over the period of the six trials
um many of which ended in a mistrial um
or hung jury he um spent 20 years in
prison and oddly during that time period
was picking cotton in fields in america
and this is you know in the um after the
year 2000 and he was an innocent man as
well as far as you know
uh
as far as anyone can tell his name is
curtis flowers
he's he just got out of uh prison and
out of that cycle i think in 2020 and
he's putting his life back together but
he was a slave of the state as the
supreme court noted in 1871.
okay represent moffitt thank you mr
so i'm trying to understand this so
are you saying that the
the people who
made our license plates on our vehicles
or
our license plates are the products of
slave labor
is that
kind of what i'm hearing or am i not
hearing it right
um
my uh
knowledge of the weight the rate of the
wages in
the prisons in new hampshire is limited
i know there's been legislation to give
prisoners an hourly wage that's
reasonable
um but in most prisons
uh prisoners receive little to no pay
for the work that they're required to do
i hope that answers your question but
our license plates and our badges i
think not our badges anymore because
i guess we couldn't get a good price
that's what i heard but our badges used
to be made by prisoners in new hampshire
and you can go down the road
to um
the showroom on uh what's it called
uh when you get north on main street and
it's called fisherville road instead
here in concord on the right across from
the prison is uh the showroom where you
can buy and i bought like a coaster
there um that was painted and it's made
of wood
and my understanding is that the items
that are sold there the money doesn't go
to the prisoners
so the concept was
the concept that people were sold was
they're being punished
and this is a fair punishment but most
of the time even then and now
the um
reasons that people end up in prison um
their
the idea of slavery as punishment isn't
really justified
said thank you
representative branch
hello and uh thank you for bringing this
legislative very important legislation
uh to our committee
my question is the reason that this is
before our committee and before the new
hampshire house of representatives uh is
because
that we need to pressure our delegation
and pressure the federal government to
do something on this issue and
is my understanding of that correct
that's correct it's just a house
resolution it's a statement
but i think you guys know that being on
this committee i was on this committee
for a long time um and a resolution is
just a letter that you write and maybe
someone reads it maybe nobody does but
at a minimum it's a statement
representative of the views of the body
and of the state
i'm i'm sure you're aware uh of course
this is i don't know why you did it as
an hr versus hr cr or joint because this
is only even if we pass this
it only shows just one part of new
hampshire the house has no weight with
the senate
my understanding is the senate doesn't
take up house concurrent resolutions so
there'd be no point it would be a waste
of taxpayer money they have a rule there
they have taken up resolutions but you
have to work them and go talk to the
senators to get the support they do take
them out so they do have a rule yep and
that they don't take up house
concurrence that'd be why
okay
because you have senator waters on there
and he could have talked to senator what
i think if you get four or five senators
to prove to say they want to take it up
then they take it out it's good to have
senate support on this uh resolution
yeah
uh representative
yeah i just uh you you kind of mentioned
that um
you talked about this not being a fair
punishment but um so what what would
what would you propose as a replacement
for this punishment and um i also you
know to kind of twofold this is um what
what would um
do do prisoners that partake in this
labor even if they're not compensated
do they do they not get some kind of
benefit out of it if they're developing
skills and if it's preventing
recidivization later on if they're able
to develop skills and help to them
honestly too pay for some of the costs
that the state has to incur to ensure
that there's justice and that you know
they serve out a specific sentence so
i'm just kind of curious what your
thoughts on those kinds of things would
be
thanks for the question i think there's
a palpable difference between skill
building and slavery
and
i think that a similar argument could
have been made by my ancestor
in congress arguing that
um
that enslavement was better for the
people that were enslaved at the time
because then they'd have something to do
they'd have work
to keep them busy and that it was
character building
and the
slavery is a different
experience than skill building um
because if skill building and slavery
are not different then what was
elementary school you know
and what is uh
having a job at dunkin donuts but the
difference is being compensated and so
it's not to say that someone shouldn't
be skill building in uh
when they're in confinement in a penal
institution
and it's not to say that someone
shouldn't be
learning new things or working
but it is
an issue of not being compensated
um and as far as what i would propose as
punishment
you know i don't have all those answers
i'm 1 in 400 and that is something that
an entity like this one decides
through the representative democratic
process
and
similar entities in every state as well
as
in
the u.s congress
and i think that that deserves a
well-rounded democratic conversation and
debate
so i wouldn't propose any particular
thing but if um
but it just seems like a
an outdated um backwards idea that's
uh
it's overdue for elimination
uh at this point that particular portion
of the 13th amendment thank you for
clarifying
yeah representative i've got a few
relatives that done some time in jail
and i always told him you do the crimes
you the time
and
um
on the compensation in i mean some of 20
30 years
you should can you speak a little louder
i'm sorry i want to hear you but i'm not
sure i should be on the speaker here
how's that
but what i'm saying i have a few
relatives have done 20 30 years in
prison
and i've always told them when they get
out with you do the crime you do the
time
but anyways my question with you is
shouldn't they compensate
the taxpayers back for paying for those
years because they did the crime
not the people in the
you know outside the prisons
um
that's a pretty big
philosophical debate
that's a big can of worms um what the
design of someone's punishment should be
whether they should compensate the state
or compensate
the person that they
harmed
but when you're talking about crimes
like
the sort of crimes that were created out
of thin air not long after the passage
of the 13th amendment with its loophole
you're talking about crimes like
being a former slave with no job being a
former slave with no home
that's just breathing that's just how
their lives were for a period of time
after the end of the civil war
so that's not a that's not a situation
in which someone arguably from like an
ethical perspective a moral perspective
has offended the state or its people
and ought to um
make some kind of compensation for that
that's just
racism you know it's just a world in an
economy that depended on slavery
and
and it was having trouble adjusting to
the lack of slavery as part of its
economy um and the labor shortage that
was created by the end of the civil war
so that's not really the same as
making right after you've done wrong
and
there's nothing that would prohibit
a legislature
from
creating and passing laws that ensure
that someone can and should make right
when they've done wrong and we have laws
on the books that already
enable that
i think
so i'm in a criminal justice and i
vaguely remember seeing we've had a lot
of bills lately
but i remember seeing some bill that had
uh it was
changing a portion of existing law the
existing lawn mentioned of like a a
requirement that
the
offender
pay compensation to the victim we
already have laws like that in place and
um i
also i think that there's supreme court
history for in new hampshire about the
issue of making prisoners pay for their
confinement and i think that it's
illegal i think that it may be
there may we i think that we have laws
against making prisoners pay for their
own confinement but as far as making
right with the person that they've
harmed we have laws in place to allow
for that and when the thing that you've
done wrong is being homeless
who are you making it right to you know
now you do know that we have prisoners
now well they're getting out there
paying for their halfway house they're
paying for their bracelets
uh that they have on their ankles all
that's being paid for by the individuals
you know i don't think that this
resolution if it were even adopted by
congress which i know is exceedingly
unlikely
would change that
okay my last thing for you even if
congress adopted it uh wouldn't that
still have to come to the states uh
um ratification that that's a big debate
and i think you're talking about the um
amendment yeah under the basically it is
a fifth amendment issue
yeah and the bill it says
thank you
and the reason and the bill says nothing
about article five at all on i mean it
uh on what's in there because the
congress with two thirds there's two
methods described that
i'm sure you all know from being on this
committee that there's a lot of debate
as to the intent of article five and
whether or not
the drafters left to get pizza while
they were working on it and forgot that
that's what they were working on and
started on the article six after that um
but it does seem unclear and unfinished
article five but this encourages
congress to use whatever means that
they'd like to adopt to execute this
thank you uh representative uh lead
one last one last question you guys are
really thorough oh appreciate it um one
last question thank you mr chair and uh
just kind of following along
representative bro uh representative
deshaz's comments and that is our
questions all right would you believe
that in california the inmates who
helped uh put out the fires there
were not allowed to become um
we're not allowed to go through the
process of becoming firefighters
following uh
them finishing their sense
uh i would believe that that is one of
the issues is that even if even if this
enslavement that occurs is skill
building there's no certification
there's nothing that someone can take
with them and say yeah i'm a felon but i
learned how to do carpentry so you
should hire me
the fact that you're a felon certainly
supersedes any interest in your
qualifications and it's not like jails
are handing out certifications
so you can build all those skills but if
you have nothing to show for it as far
as qualified education
and that's and they're not providing
that then
you know it's not really useful
for when you're uh in general in the
general population in the world
well thank you uh no other questions
thanks for your time
thanks for your time oh you're welcome
on my committee we don't ask a lot of
questions so this has been fun well this
year we do
yeah you ever don't
i don't are you the clerk do you want my
bullet points
i mean i just printed them for me
welcome to you if it makes your life
easier yeah well we as you know we deal
with a lot of constitutional issues and
it pays us to understand article five
and the legislation i think if anything
uh doesn't say
anything in there concerning uh you know
the article five on the legislators uh
making um you know with two-thirds or
anything like that it's just it's
recommending or asking
yeah which is probably why you're not
going to get a lot of testimony today
from all those folks
no debate
just wish it was the house concurrent
our house joint resolution
and then you worked it behind the scenes
because you do have a good senate i like
senator waters i've worked with him on
legislation before
that he would work it with the other
senators in the senate to show the state
of new hampshire
versus just part of new hampshire well
we can also do this just as one body i i
understand that but you know how i've
been on house resolutions
with just one body versus the whole body
but thank you
guys
with that um
my good friend representative peter
smith
yes schmidt yeah right no schmidt
schmidt
he's also a marine so just for
everyone's information here
and he supports the bill
how are you representative
i am well mr chairman it's always good
to see you uh i i see you got uh
uh
is uh i don't know whether
representative felinas is uh also
affiliated with the marine corps in some
fashion yes because she's out of step
with the other two where you got a
kernel you got a top sergeant you got
the first side and you're leading the
charge with the kernel backing them up
that's right
so the last time we had any involvement
was uh
went uh with a colonel picture me uh
softball uh
and me uh lining a hard grounder down
the third baseline and you're making a
diving stop and
it's all caught on video
i view it every once in a while
before you get started here you notice
you notice the beautiful swing i put on
it uh before you get started here i just
wanted for the rec
record here
the marine bed sitting right there could
hit that ball softball
to the
moments of the fence or over the fence
so just you know i just wanted to
hit it over yeah well you came close all
right but go ahead
i i gave it a couple of good wraps the
two games i played i thought it's not
too bad for an 80 year old guy
no i'm all the way to 83. i don't know
if i could still do it or not
but anyway i'm pleased to be before you
uh
and
so i do support uh these this resolution
even though i understand your
reservations with regard to hr's
but it does say on line five you know
house clerks will forward official
copies of this resolution of the
president united states speaker of the
united states house of representatives
president of the united states senate
and to all members of the new hampshire
congressional delegation because the
reality is that that this
this amendment is is not exactly a
particularly uh you know
reputable
uh
addition to the constitution in my pe in
my opinion because
it did
lend itself and it still lends itself
that's one of the reasons i support this
because it lends itself
even today
to abuse
with regard to people being a sentence
to involuntary servitude
i will answer some of the questions you
raised
to the previous witness
because i do think that that people who
are
uh who are imprisoned
uh for whatever
particular infraction or crime um
uh
they they should not merely be
kept away from society
uh
there obviously is in the case of
certain criminals uh a need to protect
society from people who are
killers rapists
and other other
violent acts
where people are harmed or killed
society needs to be protected that's why
we have life imprisonment
and
at the same time uh that clearly is that
society benefits from having those
people locked away obviously because
they're not free to con continue their
depredations crimes and misdeeds
but that they are
getting
clearly people are sentenced to life uh
they're not getting out um
and and uh so society is being protected
to some degree but by and large you know
most people are not sentenced to life
they're not executed uh they're gonna
get out
uh and so rehabilitation we all know
rehabilitation is a an equal a part of
the idea of people being imprisoned that
because they're going to get out it
would be better if
they have learned some kind of a skill
and in point of fact as you probably
know we're all members of the
county delegations in our individual
counties um i happen to be the chair of
the stratford county delegation now for
i think this is my 12th year as the
chair of the county delegation
and
one of the things that our prisoners do
but
they're not sentenced to involuntary
servitude
uh they are imprisoned for a period of
time uh and many of them
are
gainfully employed
in the
in in the hub county house of
corrections and they are learning
representative delemus is a member of
the stratfor county delegation
looking around
i see that she's the only one other than
myself here who's a member of strafford
county delegation but we know that our
in
individuals who are incarcerated in
stratford county
have the opportunity to work while
they're there they're not exactly well
paid but they they earn something and
again to your point mr chairman to your
question
they they shouldn't be
they shouldn't be paid you know even
minimum wages
because they are
receiving
room and board uh and and
paying their debt to society in some
fashion so that they're not making you
know top dollar i understand that and i
support that um
although you know sometimes i think the
wages they're paid uh are
sometimes anti-competitive you're also
aware of that right that that some of
the outside businesses engaged in the
same profession or occupation uh have
issues with regard to
things
you may know that the badge
this type of badge that we all
can buy
that they're they're produced in the new
hampshire state prison to my knowledge
that's that's the case
but but one of the things that i happen
to know in strafford county is that a
number of our people are learning
laundry
uh skills uh which is quite in demand
i'm informed uh so they're learning a
trade
uh that they they're they're serving a
useful benefit the laundry for uh for
the uh for the nursing home in stratford
county and
uh and also for the prison itself
is done by the
incarcerated individuals but they are
learning that skill and that trade so
that is a benefit to them
and as i understand that that's uh
that's fairly well paid and in demand
so
it's a combination right they're low
paid that's the give back in terms of
the
take back if you will uh to to the
county taxpayers who are paying the cost
of maintaining their their uh
incarceration and their room and board
so to speak
uh but
getting back to the the language itself
uh this was clearly and historically put
in place
in order to
take advantage
of of people and very often the
convictions
were of a questionable nature i won't
say that they they were plucked off the
streets because they needed
needed
20 people for the chain gang
but i wouldn't be surprised if that were
not the case in many cases i'm currently
reading a book called
devil in the grove
like an apple grove
and it tells the story of
people down in one of the southern
states
and they are they were actually in many
cases picked up and incarcerated because
they did need
some
slave labor
and we all know the song about the chain
gang sweating on the chain gang every
day
and the chain gang and we i'm sure many
of us are familiar with the movie uh
cool hand luke
uh where they're out there on the road
gangs and in many cases they had
uh
prisoners who were uh who were very
conveniently available
so i think
it certainly was abused in the past
look at it look at the history not just
in movies but look at the history and
you'll see that that many
of people of color uh were definitely
uh you know put to work uh involuntarily
because this
except as punishment punishment for a
crime where the party shall have been
duly convicted it lends itself even in
this day and age to abuse
so i think uh i think i've
i think i've made my case
and since i'm
playing hooky from my own committee
which is running late i will take no
questions okay but uh it's very good to
see your colonel
top sergeant very good to see you and
all of you as well thank you
representative smith
appreciate it okay uh is there any other
testimony anyone there
uh with that i am going to close the
hearing on h.r 18
and
at
3 30 we'll be doing a constitution crc
32.
now my plan is to uh have the um
hearing here
and then um
if we overfold then i will move to the
um
reps hall but otherwise we're going to
be right here
just so you know jerry made
30 a month
and he worked full time and was teaching
teaching construction and doing
construction and jobbing uh costing out
jobs for the prison that he was in and
that's federal
and there was no rehabilitation in that
prison
yeah on that last bill
i was trying to find the difference
between in the constitution maybe
somebody would be able to educate me i
was hoping to answer my question
i don't see any uh effect i mean
slavery's gone and yeah
this is just i don't know we'll discuss
it i guess in
when we do our um
basically exactly yeah
can i have your attention please
what we're going to do here in a minute
when we open up the hearing i'm going to
ask each one of you is here it'll be
three minutes to testify
i if you have written testimony can you
please submit it uh to the you know up
to there and they'll pass it up to us
after you're done
um if it's repetitious i'm gonna ask you
to stop
okay if you have new information to pass
on then i appreciate if you can pass
that on
uh we're going to give everyone an
opportunity to speak if i got to be here
till late myself whatever time we're
going to make this happen
okay and but i just appreciate it if you
can
keep it to three minutes
and that way there we can move on i'm
going to open up the hearing in a minute
and then i'm going to turn it over to
representative moffat because i have to
go next door to testify on a bill and
then i will be back
okay
i'm hoping i don't have to move the
legislative hall
you know uh that we can fit because we
can put people in the back standing
there
you know rather than and we can just
move right along
rep foster are they still going on
are they done
huh are there other speakers
okay
thank you yeah
yeah just put them on the bottom
me
no i'm gonna stay right here
mike you can have a seat relax and
okay uh being it that it's 3 30 i'm
going to open up the hearing on house
bill 1195
an act related to the public comment
periods
no wait i'm sorry disregard that wait
disregard what i just said
that's a bill i gotta go testify on
okay um i'm gonna open up the
constitution amendment uh on
resolution uh 32
and it's in the state peaceably declares
independence from the united states and
proceeds as a sovereign nation and i'm
going to welcome my friend
representative mike sylvia to testify
the floor is yours
thank you mr chairman and thank you
committee members for the record i'm
mike sylvia
representing belknap six town of belmont
happy to be here today my first time in
your committee
we're here today to see if our
legislature will allow a question to be
put to the voters of new hampshire
should new hampshire peaceably declare
its independence from the u.s federal
government
some believe that this is a laughable
question
do they fear the answer
some believe
that the question of independence
has been settled
if so
then our state's sovereignty
has been stolen
in my path to liberty i have learned
that our state was created by the people
in 1784
prior to forming our government
in part second of our constitution
the people reserve to themselves
the rights of the people in part first
our constitution places the bill of
rights
the rights of the people above and
before the establishment of government
part first article 7 reads
the people of this state have the sole
and exclusive right of governing
themselves as a free
sovereign and independent state
and do
and forever hereafter shall
exercise and enjoy every power
jurisdiction and right pertaining
thereto
which is not
or may not hereafter be
by them
expressly delegated to the united states
of america in congress assembled
the united states at the time was under
the articles of confederation
in
the first peaceful revolution in america
disposed of the articles of
confederation
informed a new government
under our current u.s constitution
remember
the people of our state reserve to
themselves
every power
not expressly delegated
disposing of our state's sovereignty was
never allowed
for the federal
now national
government to consider the state of new
hampshire to be nothing more
than the local office
for the district of columbia
is to destroy the independence of our
great state
while the people reserve to themselves
the right to revolution in part first
article 10
we are here today
to head off
any consideration
of anything but
a peaceful formation of a new government
independent
of rule from washington d.c
today
we will ask our legislature
to allow the people of new hampshire
to express
their putting the question on
the ballot
this november
and with that
i have a lot of supporters who will tell
you all the various reasons why
this caacr needs to be on the ballot in
november
and if you have a question for me i'd be
happy to answer
thank you representative we have a good
pile of pink cards here and we're
looking forward here hearing testimony
and you will take questions um i have
one and maybe a couple of follow-ups and
there and there may be others
presumably you no longer
recite the pledge of allegiance because
that pledge does
refer to one nation indivisible is that
correct that is not correct
so you do still say the pledge of
allegiance i do not i
have a belief
in a higher power that does not allow me
to pledge to
some other authority
okay thank you
did you know that over
4 000 new hampshire men died or killed
during the civil war fighting to
preserve our union and that thousands
more were wounded and
some of the regimental colors here at
the state house
still have
bloodstained from that conflict do you
think that the cacr does their
memory or their service a disservice i
think it actually does them an actual
honor
if they were here
to see what
has become of washington dc
and the lack
of freedom that we have as a result here
in new hampshire
i think they'd be horrified i think
they'd be very proud of this group of
supporters here
that pushed to have this brought to the
legislature and to the people of new
hampshire
thank you one more follow-up from me
there is a good crowd here we'll see
looking forward to the testimony do your
constituents generally support this
measure or have you pulled them or do
you know
i haven't polled everybody i've had
certainly uh
a good number of uh supporters obviously
i've had some detractors it's
it's
not universally
considered a wonderful idea but
we'll find out if the people get a
chance to vote on it in november we'll
find out exactly how the people of new
hampshire feel
thank you looking around
yes representative representative
lebranch
uh thank you for taking my question
my first question is do you believe that
new hampshire could support itself and
sustain itself as an independent uh
country as an independent democracy if
the cacr were to be passed by the people
this november
i do
new hampshire is a
has great resources great people
currently we are
among one of the the top economies in
the country we are net donors to the
federal government if we had that drain
relieved from us
we could
do all kinds of things um
that would be
[Music]
quite possibly phenomenal
follow up follow what uh my follow-up is
uh
i i understand that in new hampshire the
only way to get something on the ballot
at least to my understanding as a
representative is through a cacr like
this
why not introduce a house bill that
would allow for referendums and to make
this a non-binding constitutional
issue
people have uh toyed with the idea of
referendum uh and
i don't know that that's necessarily
the the best way to go i think our our
tradition here is has lasted for
the duration and
it seems to work very well
thank you
other questions
seeing none thank you representative
thank you
okay at the top of our pink list uh as a
practice we generally try to allow
legislators uh
first chances to to testify not looking
at representative jess edwards
did i just no i didn't unplug it uh
thank you mr chair uh for the record i'm
representative jess edwards representing
auburn chester and sandown
uh today
is uh
my testimonial at the end of it will
feel a little bit like
you know on one hand there's this on the
other hand there's this
i can
uh it really goes without saying that
our federal government
has
grown its powers grossly beyond
any that were intended or limited by our
constitution
and um
and i think
they jeopardize the growth of the
federal government
jeopardizes the harmony
that comes from governing with the
consent of the governed
uh i think uh if this trend were to
continue
whether it be decades or
100 years i don't know
i would say that we're on a very bad
trajectory in that it's this kind of
involvement in government that can help
us turn things back around
to answer a question you know
would our founders be proud of this
initiative
i would say they would be this is what
it's intended to be we're peacefully
getting together we're having a
discussion about something that's very
important to us and to our children
um
and uh i i want to go back i'm just got
a couple things out of the declaration
of independence i'd like to read
we we know the section about life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
that to secure these rights governments
are instituted among men
deriving their just powers the just
powers from the consent of the govern
that whenever any form of government
becomes destructive of these ends it is
the right of the people to alter it or
to abolish it i think that's the spirit
of why we're having this discussion
but as i continue of independence i find
a tremendous wisdom
in our founding fathers
that should speak to us in this moment
also
and that is
that prudence indeed
will dictate that governments long
established should not be changed for
light and transient causes and
accordingly all experience has shown
that mankind are more disposed to suffer
while evils are sufferable than to write
themselves by abolishing the forms to
which they are accustomed
so in my assessment of where the
american society is
and where it's going
i don't think
there's a sense in the population of new
hampshire
that the evils that were subjected to by
an excessive government federal
government
are insufferable
and so i i just don't see
um a public will
to to support this if there were to be a
vote and since i get to vote on this as
well as a member of the house of
representatives
i just want to be on record now as
saying i will vote no and i i hope this
comes out itl out of the committee and i
would hope that not because this is some
kind of an illegitimate scary
conversation
but just because um
i i just don't think that this is really
uh in the in the conscious
consciousness of the majority of our
citizens it's it's it's certainly
premature and i wouldn't put a timeline
on when
it will become ripe i i haven't given up
on the great american experiment
if all these folks would just go run for
office run for
town run for
you know city run for state run for
congress
just get involved run
make it our country again
and with that i'm done thank you
but they heard me
thank you representative and thank you
representative lang if that was you who
fixed that
let the record show
for anyone who testifies including the
prime and now you should have mentioned
this if you do have written testimony if
you do want to share it with our clerk
for the permanent record please
share your remarks if you have them in
writing you can also submit remarks
online to this committee of the
legislative
section of that are there any
questions for
representatives
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
if we were to put this on the ballot for
the people to vote on
wouldn't that show the
desire of the people i mean if there
were the majority of the people here in
the state who actually did vote
for secession from
the united states
wouldn't that be the voice of the people
by allowing to have that that on the
ballot to be voted on
thank you for the question i think
that's an exceptionally fair question
and one that i've had to think about as
i've been lobbied on this and i i as
i've come to look at it is the process
under which we amend the new hampshire
constitution is not meant to be easy it
requires a a series of separate steps
all of which have to be in alignment and
an agreement in order to pass
and as a as a representative of
3 400 people
i would vote
uh to not put this on the ballot in 2022
um and and i think i get a vote too my
vote as a representative is part of the
process and that's where i'm at
um i would just say
that um
i think is a pivotal election for new
hampshire
uh and for the country
and
i from a political perspective
i i'm just uh also very concerned that
we we muddy the waters with you know
insurrectionist talk and the like and
that rather than being taken seriously
we
open up
ourselves to national media and local
media to just make a mockery of the
whole exercise and
that'll be a setback in my view that's
why i'm another reason i'm voting no i i
just think it's really bad timing
follow up
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my follow-up question
is legitimately is this one of the steps
though i mean would would getting this
is is coming to this
committee
and dealing with this uh cacr
is isn't this one of the steps that
would be taken
uh
absolutely i i i have come in my
five years here to really believe in the
process and the committee processes is
is critical to everything uh the house
produces and so
your independent uh determination with
within this committee is is is important
and i i hope that you do it with all the
deliberation uh and discretion that is
appropriate to the question
and i i also want to thank you
for your husband's
you know it's a form of service so thank
you
other questions
seeing none thank you representative
edwards
uh i'm now looking at representative
brody deshays
thank you
uh thank you to the members of the
committee for letting me speak today so
um i assume many of you have seen my uh
i sent a letter to the committee a while
back i just distributed again to the
committee members um sections of that
letter were published in the new
hampshire journal regarding the
constitutional issues behind this but um
i just want to kind of deconstruct real
quick because the letter
for the most part i think almost
everyone in the room has read the letter
right and there are some people who are
very upset with me in the room which i
can perfectly well understand but um
you know after speaking to
constitutional scholars i didn't do this
in a vacuum right i reached out to
constitutional scholars i'll actually uh
cite one right now who i spoke with this
week who's an expert one of the
international experts in uh this kind of
issue is dr david williams uh he's the
head of the john s hastings professor of
law executive director of the center for
constitutional democracy actually sort
of ironically why i found him to be the
best
scholar for this is that he aids
secessionist movements in revolt
movements in foreign countries and how
to develop constitutions so i wanted to
kind of get an understanding of how he
felt that this would fit in
to our constitutional process here in
new hampshire and nationally right
because this does have national
ramifications um and that kind of you
know that will enter into my first point
here this is not a referendum right this
is a constitutional process right we've
just begun on a constitutional process
with this hearing today and it's it's
great it's great that we're entering
into a constitutional process it's the
members of the legislature who propose
this it's their right the people have
come here to testify and support her
against it's their right but we have to
remember this is a constitutional
process every vote cast is aiding in
that constitutional process by putting
this on the ballot
you're it's the process is a whole thing
right it's not like we we prepared to
get onto the ballot and then that's when
we approve or disapprove of the
constitutional amendment we're approving
it each time along the way right so
we're not this is not a mere referendum
we are embarking on a constitutional
process and every vote for it has
constitutional ramifications right
judging by amendment 14
of the us constitution section 3.
right some scholars would argue that
this is rebellion right you are
rebelling against even if it's peaceful
right rebellion can be peaceful children
peacefully rebel against their parents
every day right so even still we we you
have to we have to you know take
we have to get back from the 30-foot
view and look at the 3000 foot view
right um
this very well could be an argument
where you know if if voting for this
even if it's a good idea right and even
if people believe in their heart that
they should be voting for this even if
people say they don't support it but
they want to give people the choice
aiding and abetting in that process
right could very arguably be
unconstitutional right now it's a pretty
open-ended question still
but the next part i'll mention is um
there's a lot there's gonna be a lot of
talk about the new hampshire state
constitution right specifically part one
article seven in part one article 10. so
let's address part one article uh
article seven so new hampshire is a
sovereign state right we are still
sovereign
now we are not an independent nation
we're not a sovereign nation right but
in the way that this constitutional
amendment is written it implies it's
using the word sovereignty in the modern
sense it's not using it in the original
sense of the framers right the framers
kind of viewed sovereign as that there
was a number of things that an entity
could be sovereign over right now
they're very it's very explicit in our
federal constitution which the state of
new hampshire ratified and joined into
right and we were already part of a
perpetual union when we ratified and
entered into the articles of
confederation and perpetual union right
we always drop that last section the
whole name of the document is the
articles of confederation and perpetual
union established in 1777
but um when new hampshire entered into
the constitution when we created our own
constitution as the prime sponsor
mentioned we established that we are
sovereign the point of that was to
establish that we are sovereign over
everything within our borders and that's
within our purview based on what's not
within the purview of the federal
government now many people bring up a
great point here right that the federal
government has you know we've ceded
right a number of powers to the federal
government that we probably shouldn't
have ceded
but
even still we did that through the
sovereign process right so article
specifically you look at article 1
section 8 of the us constitution that
cites what powers the federal government
has and then the u.s constitution is
very explicit with the bill of rights
right the 10th amendment everything else
is left with the people sorry everything
else is left with the state governments
amendment 9 says everything that's not
in the state governments is left to the
people
so we have to remember that right so new
hampshire is still sovereign and has
control over a myriad of specific issues
and whatever the federal government
doesn't have responsibility for and
whatever the state government doesn't
have responsibility for that is reserved
to the people now new hampshire's
constitution is an agreement between new
hampshire's residents
and
the state government
some will assert today maybe that part 1
article 10 applies and this is the
revolutionary amendment sorry article in
our state bill of rights some will
assert today that part when article 10
applies to the federal government it
does not
we have a right to revolution in
specific circumstances but the new
hampshire constitution does not confer a
right to revolution against the u.s
government or the u.s constitution
right
the us constitution is pretty explicit
about what happens you know
that regarding you know amendment 14
section three right we had a civil war
it kind of was de facto established
right revolution against the federal
government isn't constitutionally
allowed
so now we can revolt theoretically
against our state government right our
state has you know pretty much
recognized and is securing that right
through governance but um we don't have
a right to revolt against our federal
government right the state constitution
is not an agreement that would include
the federal government it's separate
right we have an agreement the people
between the federal government with our
us constitution we have agreement the
people between the state government with
our state constitution
and one last time because i kind of
mentioned it just briefly before this
but um remember new hampshire lost many
of the powers that people are
complaining about today and many of the
concerns and we lost some of that
sovereignty
because we accepted federal dollars and
we seeded a number of responsibilities
right now we're still sovereign
technically over this right we can
through the constitutional process
freely take back those powers it just
means we're going to have to be giving
up the carrots right we took the carrot
we get the stick
we could also vice versa say we don't
want the stick but that means we're
giving up the carrot
so i think um to kind of look at that in
the context and after speaking to a
number of constitutional scholars i felt
as if it would be against my oath of
office because i when i take an oath
it's not only an oath to our state
constitution it's also an oath to our
federal one last thing
i've drafted an
amendment to this in case it would be
necessary
i'm going to read and i i have the votes
to get it passed
right i'm pretty confident such i'm
going to read what it would change the
language
quote new hampshire shall never declare
independence from the united states nor
unilaterally leave
the union of states first established by
the articles of confederation in 1777
and superseded by the united states
constitution in 1789.
this amendment this kind of language was
very similar to what other states
adopted after the civil war
right
it's a very normal thing that states
have done it does not mean that we're
giving up our sovereignty what it means
is that we're recognizing the federal
government's sovereignty over specific
issues that is quite clear in the u.s
constitution
right our state entered into that u.s
constitution we entered into this
perpetual union it's just recognizing
that our state
would still recognize that perpetual
union right that the u.s constitution is
and the u.s government is a legitimate
authority and that we are co-shares of
sovereignty with the federal government
right we share authority we share
agreements with the people and we look
to the consent of the governed
because ultimately the power lies with
the people and uh with that i'll remain
open to any questions thank you well
thank you representative shea i'm i'm
glad that's why i gave you a little bit
of more leeway on speaking forward and
i've asked you to do some research for
us and you've done a great job on it and
one of the questions that concerns me
with this here
we have refuelling airplanes down in um
at pease there they refuel the coast
there and they do refueling for for the
security of the coast what will happen
to all them aircraft there and now
security on the coast
well
you know this is kind of i in my opinion
we wouldn't even get to that question
because the federal government wouldn't
allow us to leave
right that would
it would it would be it would be a moot
question if i may i'd appreciate if you
let uh no i i appreciate the sentiment
how are we well the u.s constitution is
quite clear right that the federal
government is responsible over defenses
right and so we we wouldn't you know
there would be absolutely no way for us
to first leave the union right we can't
we can't we can't rebel against the
union right that's that's pretty clear
right state lawmakers can't rebel
against the union it's in our it's in
our u.s constitution can you hold one
second representative can you please no
signs in my committee room
can you i i understand uh we have a
rules and regulations and our rules here
no signs thank you okay go ahead yeah so
i mean back to your question though you
know how would that work um
well the federal government would be
under
if something's unconstitutional the
federal government's not going to
recognize it as legitimate right and
that's kind of what we get to the whole
issue of this right is that the federal
government isn't going to entertain this
for even a second at least from my from
my perspective and from what i've read
from what i've talked to with
constitutional scholars right and i
think it's quite clear just with the
legal press and that's the fact to
establish with the civil war right
i mean it was abraham it was abraham
lincoln who
you know a republican who quite frankly
recognized that you know we're in a
perpetual union right in the civil war
before the civil war this was a
constitutionally open you know question
there's no doubt about it right there
was still a lot of legal debate after
the civil war and with um in my
testimonial read that i mentioned
texas versus white
it's pretty you know and this president
has been upheld right it's pretty clear
the the the union of states was
established when he came together as
colonies to rebel against the king right
king george iii in the crown we
established the articles of
confederation and when we all entered
into that as states
it was a perpetual union and then we
made that union more perfect when we
adopted the u.s constitution right a
more perfect union implying everything
else that was perfect about the
article's confederation plus everything
that we're perfecting and we're still
perfecting right this
this issue i think people are misguided
and they're providing an answer to an
issue that isn't the right answer that
isn't the constitutional answer right
they're trying to work outside of
constitutional government to get this
done we have a we have a set way of
doing things and
you know we should push back against a
lot of this overreach and we've seen our
governor push back against a lot of the
overreach from washington too
so i think i think we're working as hard
as we can as state lawmakers but i
understand some people you know
will never see eye to eye on this issue
no i agree with you i got one last uh
question here of course i've been on
this committee for 15 years and you're
all there laughing or whatever when
you're speaking or when we're talking
this year i can tell you right now my
voting record is the liberty rep for 15
years
so
have respect for uh whoever's speaking
up there and i appreciate it but anyways
um under the constitution i've been
carrying it for years as you see they're
warned new hampshire and the u.s
constitution so that's like i said why
yes
under the commerce law under trade and i
know you've been researching this for a
while
what happens to the state of new
hampshire on our commerce
well i mean that's even it's even
outside of just the commerce clause the
issue is let's say let's say
theoretically let's entertain it that um
new hampshire somehow in some way
managed to convince 70 percent of voters
and the majority of the legislature to
leave to leave the union and to give up
you know everything that comes that
entails in the union um
we'd be leaving the largest free trade
bloc in the world quite frankly we'd be
crippling our economy the 15 to 20
percent of workers who cross the border
every day wouldn't be able to the
federal government wouldn't recognize us
they wouldn't recognize any passports
that we issue they wouldn't let them out
new hampshire doesn't have an
international airport there's no way to
travel internationally not to mention
the united states probably would not let
any other country in the world recognize
us
right we wouldn't be recognized in the
international stage we would become a
hermit republic we'd become a hermit
republic in a large and globalizing
world we would kill our economy we'd
kill the new hampshire advantage this is
a one-way ticket
to a sales tax and an income tax in my
opinion how else are you going to
support the current programs that we
have in this state and you know i'm not
saying the federal government's perfect
everyone in this room knows the federal
government is far from perfect right
democrats republicans libertarians
anarchists whatever have you right
but
at the end of the day we
we can as legislators we can't push
forward unconstitutional um
legislation
right especially something like this and
i you know i say that in the most in the
most respect that i can have for those
who have brought this forward because i
think it's a very good discussion to
have about what the role is of state
government within this federalist system
what the role is of you know
how states can you know how they how
they associate and how they associate
with the federal government how this
issue of sovereignty works i think it's
a great learning experience but i also
think
i think it's opening up a can of worms
that we basically close at appomattox in
right
okay thank you uh any other questions
representing the branch
uh thank you for taking my question uh
it's my understanding and you know we've
seen history in the civil war that if a
state does secede
my question is do you think that if we
did get to that point where we did
declare independence
could the united states invade and
occupy us
as a territory and it would all be for
nothing um you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
deny the premise of your question
because the way that we interpret
the civil war and the way that the
supreme court has is that states never
seceded right there were active
rebellions in those states but they
never seceded actually
every southern state had a legitimately
recognized government that was in
association with the union throughout
the civil war and many of those
lawmakers that ran those governments
that were still in association with the
union and some of them secretly still
had open
open um open conversations with the
union army and with the federal
government
right so
representative branch would there be
people who are formerly state lawmakers
that
would secede and try to establish their
own government in rebellion yes would
the federal government probably end that
rebellion yes but would our state
government stop existing
no there would still be a legitimate
state government because there would
still be pro-unionist legislators
that would that would stay in that
government that would still conduct
their own elections and that would be
the legitimate government until the
federal government was able to
re-establish order in conjunction with
the state with the pro-unionist
government and with our state militia
thank you um
follow-up did you have follow-up one
follow-up
this is more another constitutional
question
if we passed the cacr and it did get
approved
is it correct that it would also be in
direct violation of other sections of
the new hampshire constitution such as
article 7 which specifically states that
we do delegate some powers to the
american congress because we would have
one that says we're independent from the
united states and a different section of
the same constitution would say
we delegate powers yeah the subsection
of the same article of you know
part one yeah that that's 100 correct we
would have we would have the same
article
would contradict itself with the
subsection right
so
then that's the other thing too so now
we're all of a sudden
we're not only establishing a um
an extremely difficult situation with
you know
the us constitution right and how we
would be blatantly violating that we'd
also have a
a uh you know
two two articles in the same you know
sorry the same article two parts of it
and direct juxtaposition to each other
right where we're saying in one we're
sovereign over some issues the federal
government suffer over other issues
essentially just recognizing what the
current what the current you know
constitutional agreement is between
these governments and its people and
between these two governments in the
federal
system we'd be adopting another
amendment
against the us constitution that would
then say
that beginning part of you know
recognizing sovereignty uh you know
that's
you know it would it would be very
complex and i think it would be a huge
issue and we'd have to address we'd have
to further amend our constitution and i
would say again unconstitutionally we'd
be putting forward amendments that would
be going against um
against the federal constitution well i
would have to repeal the article 7 for
sure because i agree with you on that i
represent massimilia
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
some of my constituents are concerned
about
what happens if this passes and new
hampshire does become a sovereign nation
what will happen to their medicare and
their social security
well that's a that's a good question and
those programs would um
they would they would cease to exist now
again though um i'm not entirely sure
i'm not entirely sure well they would i
know some of the people they would cease
to exist being given by the federal
government the state government could
try to adopt it but new hampshire
typically you know we get a lot more in
resources from the federal government
than you know
than we get from it sorry then we take
then we give to it um
i think i think representative this is a
that's kind of the logistical issue
right but the logistical issue that's
more that's a matter of preference of
how we govern right and so while it's a
legitimate question while it's a
legitimate concern i'm more worried
about the constitutional ramifications
right because theoretically we could end
our granite advantage program the state
of new hampshire and the expanded
medicare medicaid we could stop you know
a number we could stop giving you know a
certain portion of our state funds to
unlock these federal funds and end these
programs or we could end a lot of these
programs and and a lot of concerns that
people have you know whether they're
legitimate or illegitimate about maybe
possible federal overreach in some cases
i think they're very legitimate concerns
and others i'm not too sure but i think
at the end of the day we should really
concentrate on the constitutional
question of whether or not legislators
can actually push this forward and
support this and whether or not it's
actually going to work within our state
constitution be constitutional or
constitutional with the federal
government right and i think so far in
my research talking to reading i mean
i'm not even kidding like 200 pages
worth of scholarly documents speaking
with the writers of those documents and
stuff doing research for you know
multiple weeks and sitting down even for
an hour this week just to prep with a
constitutional scholar works
internationally on this issue i couldn't
find any conceivable universe where we
could legitimately do this
thank you representative you know uh
representative and it's not a question
but for the last 15 years the fourth
graders have been coming up here i've
been asking every one of them if they
ever read the new hampshire constitution
i haven't come across too many kids that
even know we have a new hampshire
constitution so you'd be surprised how
the rest of new hampshire is they're all
many go on the u.s constitution and have
no clue
about what's in the new hampshire one
even some of our reps here
in the building uh representative branch
you have another question
uh yes a question came to me while we
were listening to that response uh i
hate to ask this type of question but
it's a
a legal question uh
you said that if we did become
independent and
representatives were part of the
traitorous government that they would be
treasonous uh would you believe that the
the people sponsoring this current
legislation would be considered uh
treasonous i'm i'm not qualified to
answer that question i don't think and
i'll tell you why though i'll tell you
why though
because it's still an open question
right we haven't seen this in the modern
context in the modern sense it's an open
question it's something that the
who would decide the answer to this
question quite frankly would be the
state legislative body right
if if another member of the house
brought forward you know to to expel
another member because of something that
they felt violated amendment 14 section
3 of the us constitution right and
there's that that current proposal right
now that would allow us to fill the
vacancy if that seat became vacant then
that would be when we have to have that
debate i hope we don't have that debate
i hope that the debate that we have is
just about the feasibility of this and
that we let these lawmakers you know
voice their opinion introduce what they
think is the way to go forward for this
state but that we recognize that it's
just not feasible it's not
constitutional and you know we have we
have a good strong dialogue with a
number of you know residents and u.s
citizens in the uh in the crowd today
and um and that we as legislators ask
them good probing questions really
understand what their disdain is for the
federal government what their disdain is
for overall government and why they
think this would work and maybe find
ways within constitutional government to
address those concerns right and
actually you know improve government
moffitt
thank you again representative uh before
we lose you uh to follow up on
representative labrance's question um
are you aware that there is a measure in
a different committee that's uh being
heard with regard to sanctioning people
who who uh propose
this type of separation have you heard
anything about that are you aware of
that are you talking about house bill
i don't have the number of stuff is it
the one that representative bill marsh
prime sponsored is that the one you're
talking about that's the one i believe
yes so what that bill does is it doesn't
sanction people right the legislature
already has this power to say someone's
violated the constitution or their oath
of office or done something else what
the measure does is it allows that if
the state legislature right if i can't
remember what the exact process is again
because i've been so caught up with this
i didn't even i didn't want to get into
that right and i didn't even want to
kind of enter into this discussion but i
think
the committee if the committee views it
as an important aspect then we can talk
about it but um it just allows us to
fill the seat if someone is expelled
from the house that's all that measure
does right because the prime sponsor of
that and i spoke to him about it to
better understand it before this because
i said it could come up right and um he
said all it does is if someone was
expelled from the house for any reason
at all right that currently in statutory
law
the expelling someone for treason or
secessionist acts currently isn't
allowed you can't you can't have a
special election for that reason
right so what it does is it allows the
seat to be filled it allows the state
government to declare a vacancy and for
a special election to happen we can't
declare vacancy right now for someone
leaving the legislature for that reason
so i i don't think we should ever get to
that though right because i i don't
think
i don't think that there's
entirely malice in this right i don't
agree with it i don't think it's
constitutional but i don't think there's
malice and i think it's starting an
important conversation
right for us to have regarding you know
the constitution so then residents of
new hampshire and members of this body
of this legislative body and of the
state government can better understand
our state and federal constitution
better understand our federalist system
and better understand sovereignty in
general and how that works in a
federalist system
thank you all right thank you i'm seeing
no other questions
um thank you for your testimony you
definitely did a great job in
researching on stuff that i've already
was aware of being on this committee for
15 years but constitutional issues so
thank you
the chair gonna recognize uh
representative tim horrigan
for three minutes
welcome representative horgan
welcome good to be back i'm represent
tim horrigan from stratfor county
district six the towns of durham and
madbury and
even though i'm a state rep from two
small towns in new hampshire i consider
myself an american first you know i'm
proud to be a granite stater but my
identity as american
comes first and this uh
proposal aside from the
practical difficulty it does seem kind
of un-american
there is a constitutional conundrum i
think the members who sponsored it
were protected from punishment for
saying unpopular things um and
you know saying you're doing unpopular
things in the scope of our duties the
legislature on the other hand it does
kind of conflict with the oath we took
to defend the us constitution but
i'm sure at least this time around
there's not much chance of it uh
passing i don't see how the sponsors are
going to get to 240 votes and let alone
two-thirds of the people approving it
um
mr representatives made a lot of
interesting points some he did a lot of
research i um i've sometimes researched
issues like that in that much detail i
haven't been able to do it this time but
i've been thinking about for a long time
but ivy
just on a person note i have a great
great great uncle who is a senator from
virginia not west virginia but virginia
during world war ii because he
he was basically well that was back when
um senators were appointed so he was
appointed by you know a
provisional legislature for the small
parts of
virginia that
weren't either
controlled by the confederacy or hadn't
become part of west virginia his name
was
senator lemuel jackson bowden so i'm
proud to be at least related only by
marriage to him um
and uh
and said the residents of shays explain
the practical implications this is just
about impossible there are some nations
that are smaller than us that are doing
okay but i don't really think
really don't think we could we don't
really have anything
aside from the borders that and certain
you know little cultural quirky things
like liquor stores the interstate and no
income or sales tax i think we're not
really uh
we're not really equipped to be an
independent entity apart from the other
49 united states that's just part of it
is not going to work although we do have
two international airports one of which
is right near right in my part of the
state the portsmouth uh
the portsmouth airport formerly peace
air force base uh could easily be
converted international airport we also
have manchester
we probably have to take the boston off
of manchester boston regional airport so
that's uh
and as for the federal government um it
is pretty big i'm not sure if it's
necessarily
more regressive than the state
governments a lot of the
progress we've made
over the last decades and centuries has
actually been more driven by the federal
government which tends to be more i
think more respectful of
people's rights than the individual
state government so it certainly
has very weak leadership at the moment
um especially the senate i was watching
the senate on c-span even though our
most individuals and senators are great
and our especially i
respect our two senators deeply and one
of whom senator shaheen is my
constituent but
certainly the senate is a bad joke
that's what's happening there is totally
not right um we've had uh
i don't i'm not totally satisfied even
with the current president even though i
voted for him and i have my syllabus
bumper stick in my car and as for the
last one i know there's some friends of
his here supporters but he certainly
i think at least have denied that was
for whatever reason that was a very
chaotic four years and that was uh
you know a lot of strange things
happened and he didn't really have
control over it so that's i don't know
if the federal government necessarily
works i certainly
um
you know we're sitting in committee
we're bipartisan so this is not a
partisan thing but we'll just
acknowledge i'm a democrat and i don't
even trust my fellow democrats to run a
small independent country 1.38 million
people let alone
let alone the proponents of this they're
even less qualified than my federal
democrats i just uh
it'd be very steep learning curve to us
actually being independent countries
so i say we should
we're part of the united states there's
no way we can get out um unless
something really dr things really
drastic change and so i would say uh
this casa is a waste of time and i will
certainly be voting against it when it
comes to the floor or whatever else so
thanks thank you representative will you
take questions if there's any sure any
questions for representative hogan
cnn thank you very much thank you
um chair recognized the honorable former
state rep and the cop
thank you mr chair and committee thank
you for hearing from me today do you
mind if i stand up
just make sure the mic is up so people
can hear
and i just wanted to say thank you very
much and let me speak i'm a former
representative from this biennium 2020
2022 for a reason
in our state government we have had our
rights as citizens usurped by the
highest office here the governor had me
removed from the state house on january
7th inauguration day because he called
it
armed protesters were at his house
so he made his inauguration private and
wouldn't allow me to be sworn into
office a duly elected representative of
the people there's my constituency right
there liberty patriots in this state
have been usurped of their rights
redress of grievance has been denied
dan richard has had a redress of
grievance before the private the
previous biennium in 2018 under
democratic leadership to my utter
surprise and dismay under a republican
leadership in 2020 22
they did not hear the redress of
grievance from the people so if you
remove redress or grievance from the
people what cause do the people have to
let their government know they're very
unhappy with what's happened
since january 7th on april 9th our state
speaker speaker packard called me a
female representative a female slur and
never apologized for it i took my shots
and slings and arrows and stayed as a
state rep
june 24th we had a budget bill where the
governor took all of our activist groups
and put them and paraded them in front
of us okay if i may hit the side what
does this have to do with the
constitutional amendment
this is new hampshire what you're
talking about we're talking about state
sovereignty and our people but we're
talking about succeeding from the united
states talking about putting it on the
ballot so the people of new hampshire
can vote for it
okay but what i'm trying to say is if
you can keep it paul reverse before the
cart no i'm i understand i'm just asking
you to keep the conversation to
succeeding from the united standing to
you that if a state representative duly
elected by the people in her town
representing my constituents cannot be
effective in government has had the
governor remove me by state police from
the state house has had our honorable
state speaker who's a republican i
happen to be republican allowed a race a
slur a female slur on the state house
in a hot mic and he never apologized and
my party told me don't do that we might
wind up with the other party speaker
well excuse me there's a certain level
of integrity and decorum that that
office holds and he should have been
held to account he should have been
brought up on charges for the ethics
commission and nobody wanted to do it my
fellow women in the republican house
said oh don't do that
where's the support from the women for
me as a representative and a female zero
so i move forward to june i understand
but are we looking to get rid of that to
the end
but i'm saying this are we looking to
get rid of the state reps too along with
are we going after the us no we're
talking about new hampshire and our
state sovereignty and the right of the
people for redress of grievance we have
been denied that right from our current
governor
do you agree with that he has usurped
every branch of government from the
senate the house the judiciary the ag's
office it's all ridiculous what's
happened in our state now you have to
listen to your citizenry you're not
elite you're not above the people our
government has the right of redress and
we don't have that in new hampshire the
free state
the first in the nation state it's all
bs and we have to exercise our
government we are not minions of the
federal government we are not charges we
are not
what would you call um you know
prisoners of our own government we're
not
and as a result of june
okay
what i called the omnibus bill burger it
was like a
wrapped poop sandwich to be
kind what happened in that day my fellow
representatives were usurped their arms
were twisted by the governor and his
minions in the establishment republican
party to vote against their principles
the freedom caucus was
the knees taken out from under them that
was the last bastion these people had of
their voice in the house gone
so now we're here to speak to you to let
you know we're very unhappy we want your
government our government to respect us
it's not us versus them we're citizens
and our citizenry is being ignored what
else are we left to do so i left the
state house with dignity
she became an activist because i want
our liberty and our rights restored
so are you asking us then to modify this
here and maybe go after go after the
governor and the
state rep or the speaker
versus the u.s i'd love to talk to you
about that
representative baldusow but
to be specific to the cacr32
i would like us to pass it and let the
people decide at the ballot box november
2022 okay
uh thank you um is there a question
representative branch
you'll take questions uh you know i'll
take a few in the in light of people
needing to speak
uh my first question i have many is
how does the cacr change anything about
the corruption that you accused redress
of grievance
but
how does leaving the federal government
change state government versus
succeeding from the federal government
to become a sovereign state once again
we're called a sovereign state but we're
really not if your government's run away
and you're not listening our our
governor if you are not aware arrested
some folks at the executive council
meeting on october 13th i believe it was
correct me if i'm wrong is it the 13th
or the 17th the 13th arrested a
grandmother dragged her to her knees 72
years old do you know who did that at
the request of our governor our own
state police yes granted they may have
been the detail officers for the
governor and they may have had a certain
affinity for him growing to learn how he
has been with them but they violated
their oath
when i'm trying to get it and i
understand what you're saying but
let's say we succeed from the u.s but
you're still
horus before the cart but you still got
the governor you still got the
legislation aci 32 on the ballot that's
it right agreement
don't please don't uh
but you still what i'm trying to say is
you still have the governor you still
like the u.s reps we take baby steps
once this passes if the citizenry of our
state decide this is what they want then
we reconvene and have meetings about how
to do the commerce clause the pzfos
clause all of those things think of this
we talk about social security and money
from the government what if we're not
sending our money to the government we
keep it in new hampshire
yeah we're going to have to if there's
something like this we moved it forward
because everyone's money would be uh i
don't know if we could get it back from
the federal government
you know retirements and everything else
uh that are because we would be in like
a separate country it's our money don't
forget the bunny tree doesn't have a
left to the right pocket it's the same
citizen you know representative you know
i got the utmost respect for you and i'm
one of one of
the only reps there with paul ingridson
dan itsy that started to redress the
grieving caucus in this house and we
moved forward we got representative bill
o'brien to move forward with redress so
we have done this here in the house
in there and then of course over the
years they they stopped it took it away
but this bill has nothing to do with
that this bill has nothing to do
whatsoever and i'm hoping when you come
up here you talk about the legislation
and not what joe schmuckatelli did to
you
at the governor's office has nothing to
do with this
that's your government treating you
poorly you ser patient of our rights
under the government usurping every
branch of government this legislature is
an independent branch of government free
of the executive branch but they've
never exercised their rights or their
power all right thank you let's give
somebody else a chance to come up then
uh
thank you representative aldazaro thank
you
okay uh the chair is going to recognize
celeb daya where is he at caleb i
haven't seen him in a while welcome back
next to you he's a good man right here
hey welcome back
hello
um
i come before you today it's pretty rare
i haven't been back uh actually since
the inauguration ceremony for uh the
um
post the elections in uh in 2018.
um but i come before you guys today
um
because
this what you see here
is a product of a lot of patients
a lot of patients
and i it might be hard for many to
understand
but
from the entirety of my life
i've watched presidents come and go
congresses come and go
and i have watched
the rights and liberties
of the people here in new hampshire and
the people across this country
be severely diminished
and in
ways that
are very much disconnected from us but
very much
very much important to all of us
regardless of party
um
my political engagement
the reason why i actually
ran for the house of representatives had
nothing to do with issues so great as
this
but it had to do with a
disgust
of
what i was seeing going on around me
i saw the federal government
warring gallivanting across
the world
projecting its power
uses of force
killing people that i don't think
deserve to die
um
i got involved because i was an anti-war
activist um
and and some other little local things
too but that was the first reason why i
got involved and i just could not accept
that this federal government that i was
paying tax to funding i could not accept
that they were committing these crimes
when i was in high school
there was a
a news story that broke via wikileaks
i'm sure many of you are aware
there was a video called collateral
murder
there was a video of can you try to keep
it to three minutes yeah absolutely
thank you so much at that time
there was an american air force pilot
who killed someone who was evacuating
um
wounded people from a war zone
and it didn't sit right with me and that
story was
broadcast
and it was suppressed by
the media
and
the people who were responsible chelsea
manning is her name
she was treated as if she was a war
criminal herself for exposing those
crimes
and this is just one of many things that
got me involved however
this is only one of very very many
crimes that have been committed by this
federal government
the surveillance state that has grown up
around us that edward snowden
opened our eyes to
this has been a product of great
patience
and
it behooves all of you whether or not
you think this is serious or not whether
you plan to vote for it or not
it behooves you to take it seriously
because there are a lot of people in
this room who do take it seriously and
do not want to be a party to these
crimes any longer
and
yeah that's you know i'll i'll leave it
there but uh i would greatly like to to
take any questions i know uh
i know there are you know some uh former
friends of mine here so thank you uh
uh any questions for
you know
any questions for
cnn none uh thank you
thank you uh chill recognize the um you
know take that
uh jesse
rackenstrand i hope i didn't brutalize
it it poses the bill
was jesse
was reconstructed
straw
is he here
jackie racquet is that you
okay
uh he's got it please keep it to three
minutes i've got to try so i can get you
all in all right it won't take long at
all sir
um so i actually oppose um the this bill
here
it is uh as far as i'm considered with
an open rebellion against
um the united states federal government
by doing this but um
i consider myself an american citizen
but i consider myself
firstly a citizen of the uk
i think when the
the colonies decided to rebel
against the crown and against
uh king
king james i believe it was
but um king george yep
king george uh they
they were in open rebellion against the
crown and uh
i i support an amendment to the bill to
uh return
the power
of the uh
of new hampshire to
to the crown to its to its rightful uh
the rightful uh rightful ruler we need
we need the uh
we need uh
we need to swear fealty to the king and
the queen of england we need to kiss the
ring
and um new hampshire was one of the
first colonies
blessed by the crown of england and uh
we just need to um
if i may where you from
uh i'm from virginia the commonwealth of
virginia the first of the colonies
okay
all right you didn't put an address on
here because i would have put you near
the end because they let the new
hampshire residents speak
but uh thank you if you can close it up
please yep um yeah i just wanted to say
that um
um
we really need to return to the united
kingdom we need to be under one one
kingdom and uh god save the queen thank
you sir well that's not going to happen
but thank you have a good day seeing no
questions thank you
okay the chair recognize
roussan
chester
and uh supports the bill
am i saying it wrong from bedford
chester that's you am i saying am i
abusing your name
badly oh okay
i speak italian so i might be confused
greek so you know um my name for the
record is russ sanchester it's spelled
r-u-s-s-a-n
uh it's an imaginary name so no problems
with it getting incorrect i just want to
correct a couple of things that was said
um
first of all
as
a lot of you folks probably know because
you understand you know the new
hampshire constitution and the united
states constitution the new hampshire
constitution was actually written and
ratified on june 2nd of 1784. the united
states constitution was ratified on ni
on september 17 1787.
so actually the new hampshire
constitution was in place before the
federal constitution whoa
okay um
um so what i want to do is i want to
take this from a little bit of a
different perspective um we've heard a
lot today about
uh the people of new hampshire are tired
we're tired of of the tear what we feel
is tyranny at the federal level
um i want to give you um what the united
united nations definition
can be defined as a pattern of behavior
that is used to gain or maintain power
and control
it can manifest as emotional economic or
psychological actions or threats of
actions that influence on another person
this includes any behaviors that
frighten intimidate terrorize manipulate
and hurt it can happen to anyone of any
race age sexual orientation religion
religious identity or gender it affects
people of all socioeconomic backgrounds
and education levels incidents are
really isolated and usually escalate in
a frequency and surveillance
you have some of us confused what are
you talking about i'm reading the
definition from the united nations
but this i'm i will be getting to that
in just a second it sounds familiar
though
yeah but can you stick with this here
because uh this is dealing with the us
succeeding so we don't care what the u.n
says i used the united states definition
because it was very very broad um
what this definition is
is of um abuse
this is the definition of abuse the
people of new hampshire and the people
of all of our states in the union have
been abused by the federal government
it's very clear to see if you look
around and you look at the statistics of
suicide of mental illness all of that is
stop treating the disease and stop
treating the symptoms and treat the
disease the disease is we are being
abused as a people
we have a tyrannical government and have
for quite a while long before this
administration um and the bottom line is
nobody not one single human in this
world deserves to be abused we do not
deserve to be intimidated and frightened
and terrorized and manipulated
are you ready to help that this state
are you ready to begin the wave of
freedom against this abuse
after all isn't that the advice that
you'd give your own loving family
members
walk away
before it's too late
well thank you are there any questions
seeing no questions thank you very much
let me see
oh you have a test if you have testimony
if you can please uh pass it up uh up
the side there there
and they'll pass it up to the clerk
the chair recognized uh that supports
the bill
jason gerhard
welcome to the committee jason where are
you okay
nobody do keeping this or that whatever
you got to call him again the name okay
i'll see you there okay
okay welcome you three minutes please
i'm going
go get it so i want to so i want to take
a little different approach on this
and look at the criminal justice
ramifications of what's happening with
the federal government
so as someone that spent 12 and a half
years in federal prison on some bogus
charges related to the federal income
tax i can say that the federal courts
are completely and utterly corrupt the
state courts at least have some
semblance of justice because of jury
nullification which thankfully new
hampshire passed in 2012.
so for those who aren't aware and just
how important this is because you cannot
bring up jury nullification in federal
court you'll get shut down before you
even get the first word out
so
juries now okay
the judges they can override the rulings
of judges they believe the judges are
misinterpreting or misapplying the
relevant law so even if you are caught
with a kilo of crack you can say listen
jerry this law is bogus and so be it you
can't do that in federal court and
in federal court is where the most
abuses occur
decades and decades and decades are
given out for the most mundane things
from growing weed to if you file a lien
against a federal official that's a
felony you lose your rights forever gun
rights and other things
so if we were to step away from the
federal government
we could then
overhaul the whole corrupt federal court
system as it stands which i think is the
most important thing you have people
riding away in federal prison right now
so you wanted well he's not here anymore
because he's on to more important things
but talking to all these constitutional
scholars
i mean come on you don't need a
constitutional scholar to figure out the
constitution so supply to everyday
normal people if the average american
can't understand the constitution we
have to rewrite it thomas jefferson said
the constitution should be
re-hauled every 19 years
so he figured it was a generation of men
would be about 19 years we had this idea
that we have to follow these rules of
these guys have been dead so long no one
even knows their names we print them on
money that's created by the federal
reserve which is a complete fraud as it
is i mean why do we want to stay part of
this system i don't understand it what
is so sacred about it we're holding on
to old traditions that don't exist
anymore
these rights don't exist i mean look at
the bill of rights you have corporations
for pretending to be people
they have the rights you know now we
have federal corporations and state
corporations that
um
operate in other states that overall the
the will of the people everywhere and
internationally
so i think we've just created a monster
and we can talk about oh we're what's
going to happen to our social security
there is no money in social security we
know that
come on they're printing the printing
presses haven't stopped those things are
smoking right now inflation's
skyrocketing like we have to stop and
focus here
you know we'll find a way to find trade
the canadians want our maple syrup you
know like
just we're focusing on the wrong stuff
here there's people riding in federal
prison oh and one last thing and i'll
just wrap this up the adpa the
anti-terrorism and effective death
penalty act 1995 after oklahoma city the
argument was we have to start executing
people faster people are using the
appeal system to the advantage of just
milking it forever well it turns out the
adpa actually slows down the process of
executing people
and it limits your appeals
so you get one appeal one year after
conviction that's it you can't even if
the law changes to your benefit you
can't reappeal you have to wait for a
constitutional
you know um over um
overreach yeah it has to i can't figure
the right name but anyway point is it's
all corrupt just end the charade we're
not here to go burn american flags we
love this country that's the whole
reason we're here you know so
all right thank you uh seeing that
there's no questions all right
uh the chair recognized uh carla garrick
how are you kyle
i can have that one i know who she is
i wish there was this much
uh who supports the bill says five
minutes but please if you can get it
down to three
uh it's four minutes when i practiced it
but he had 27 minutes so you know i
think
he's the legislator that i asked to
research the bill
and uh to be able to that's why we had
him up front i'll go as fast as i can
let's do that i always have reasons for
my method you know madness
but go ahead
uh honorable committee members thank you
for your time today my name is carla
garrick but my friends call me queen
quill so i guess if we're going to have
a monarchy monarch off you know i'm game
i'm an immigrant to america and became a
u.s citizen in 2000 having to take a
citizen's test where
you know new americans learn about the
constitution and the enumerated things
that the federal government is supposed
to be limited to doing
which isn't much
i'm an author i'm an activist and i'm an
attorney but i'm also a political
refugee to new hampshire moving here in
2008 as part of the free state project i
was the republican nominee
for new hampshire senate in district 20
and i received 45 of the vote in the
last election i'm now going to run again
i'm a proud free stater and like many
but not all free staters i support new
hampshire independence i'm testifying
today in support of cacr32
because it should always be in the hands
of the people how they are governed
the federal government has failed us it
no longer follows the constitution the
federal government ushers in
unconstitutional wars the federal
government hurts our fellow granite
staters with its war on drugs which just
makes bad personal decisions worse the
federal government colluding with the
federal reserve
makes us all poorer due to the inflation
caused by money printing face it granite
staters are abused by dc
what do we advise victims to do when
they're abused
we tell them to leave
which means we have the right to ask for
a divorce
that's all today's proposed amendment is
an opportunity a democratic opportunity
for granite staters to decide whether
our relationship with the federal
government is worth salvaging i say it's
not and everyone should know we would
all be better off if we went our
separate ways
what are we taught about abusers
they will tell you you can never leave
they will tell you they will change
they might even tell you it's your fault
abusers and the federal government are
gaslighting liars
who cannot be trusted
we all know the definition of insanity
is doing the same thing over and over
and it's your duty to at least create
the opportunity for granite staters to
decide their own destinies
as an impen as an independent nation new
hampshire would be prosperous and
peaceful along the lines of a small
successful country like liechtenstein or
luxembourg or switzerland
we'd have four side four times the size
of iceland's population
we'd easily be able to work with our
neighbors much like the countries in the
shenzhen area and europe do many
american retirees already receive their
social security pensions in foreign
countries like mexico
no future challenge related to
independence is insurmountable where
there's a will there's a way
let's see if there's a will
there are many compelling reasons to
support national divorce and i encourage
folks who are curious to visit the
foundation for new hampshire
independence website i serve on this
federally recognized 501 c 3 educational
nonprofits board and at
nhindependents.org
you'll find hundreds of reasons why you
should support a free and independent
new hampshire not least of which would
be that we would all be richer if we
could keep our hard-earned federal
income taxes
and that's about 25 000 on average for
granite staters so if you just want to
be a little richer
you know ask your representatives to
support this
today your only duty is to the democracy
democracy which every single one of you
claim to support
you need to vote in favor of this
opportunity
because it's not up to you it's up to
individual granite staters
we're called to live free or die state
when we become independent will also be
the live free and thrive state afford us
the opportunity to try
i want to just address briefly a couple
of things that came up here today
um
in 2016 when brexit happened
uh there were several online polls that
were done 42 percent of granite staters
in two separate polls including one done
by the union leader supported a free
and independent new hampshire 42 percent
we've come a long way since then
to the point that representative edwards
made uh you know he said he's going to
vote against it i think that we should
say let's see
what the people think that is truly what
the role should be here is let's leave
it open to the people
to uh representative uh brody deshay
um you know it's disappointing that you
would try and sort of lean into the
gaslighting and create this sense of
fear where it's like rebellion treason
you know all these things the right of
revolution is enshrined in our new
hampshire constitution
and um and so these are just scare
tactics
uh
i believe it was
you that said the power resides in the
people
so i would say let's prove it let's let
them vote and then i will leave you with
this especially for my democratic
friends if you've tweeted or mentioned
the words voter rights or democracy in
the past five years
i suggest you also support this bill i'd
be happy to take questions
thank you you know my mike's not on yeah
no mine's just no you know i i didn't
know uh i forgot about the free stated
thing how many out here are all free
status
wow okay
quite a bit all right
okay that explains uh mike what's the
relevance of that question well the
reason is because i'm i'm just concerned
on the free status because i know
you do a great job on liberty and how
you you know where you're going
on freedoms and other things that you
want and drugs and everything else and
no regulations and i understand
so uh you know okay
with the characterization there well i
just wanted to see how many free status
came in to testify that's all quite a
bit so
that's good okay thank you and then
sorry i would just like to make one more
note i forgot to mention this and i did
say i would take questions you know to
give you a sense of what the federal
government is i sent a christmas card to
ross albrecht in prison he's in jail for
building a website he has two life
sentences today my husband went to fetch
the mail and he came back and he said oh
we got a letter back from ross and i was
like oh isn't that great you know i was
kind of excited
the letter is a returned christmas card
to a man who will spend the rest of his
life in prison that is your government i
say no thank you okay thank you
okay
um
seen
you have a question
representative
thank you
thanks for taking my question the
question simply is
you are you aware that we are a
republican not a democracy
yes thank you okay seeing that there are
no other questions or chairs going to
recognize
my husband also was impressed brian
what's this here is that a z
zitski
hi brian welcome if you can keep it to
three minutes we appreciate it so we can
get everyone in
thank you
in my lifetime the united states
incorporated has violently murdered
approximately a million innocent people
and caused the immeasurable suffering of
many times then
this will be the first time i have had
even the potential
of an opportunity to vote on my consent
vote yes on cacr32 so i can have that
opportunity
vote yes so the voters of new hampshire
can have that opportunity
thank you thank you um
seeing it there's no questions uh thank
you very much
the chair recognized uh peter
harry a.y.r.e
hirey welcome peter
and he's uh in support of the bill one
to two minutes i like that peter
okay
this one has no name
all right good evening everyone
appreciate your time and thanks for
everyone for coming out i have a few
prepared remarks but like carla did i
wanted to respond quickly to some things
some other folks said we had one speaker
who referenced time and again
experts and i would just say that we
here can rely on common sense and our
own critical thinking if we want to look
to an expert on the constitution i would
put forth lysander spooner
to talk about wars and call them civil
war i would
i would reference the great axel rose
when he said what's so civil about war
anyway
there's been talk about money going out
in new hampshire and money coming back
to new hampshire i just want to make
clear that those federal reserve notes
are not the same for example what if the
state of new hampshire residents
were taxed at a billion dollars but then
the dc regime said here's 10 billion
dollars we're going to we're going to
put in a nuclear waste facility in the
in the white mountains we're going to do
all these super funds we're gonna you
know so
so we have to think about
what comes with these grants
and how it affects folks
we also know that there's been questions
how will this policy how this program
unfold we don't know for sure no one can
answer that but we know there's a lot of
smart people here there's a lot of
people with passion and we'll work to to
bring about the best outcomes we can and
it's better to have a less acute
issue than a more acute issue we know
that
i'll get to my
prepared remarks i would say i would be
content with each of you
supporting this with neutrality just to
see how folks
in new hampshire respond but i would
encourage you enthusiastic support
i i would say that i've been an advocate
of liberty for a long time i used to be
sort of bought into the nationalism i've
since seen through some of that
part of that was through my reading of
history and the history of empire seeing
them grow and fade and what that brings
so
what i see i don't think anyone here
would deny that the us has been an
empire and it's on the
uh collapsing phase
empires at their cores tend to be
conformist uniformists they have group
think they stagnate they thrive on fear
and aggression and even we see democide
on the periphery though is where we see
creativity diversity critical thinking
innovation mutual respect and peace and
that's what i think we can do here in
new hampshire the culture
is that it's not just freedom it's
freedom coupled with responsibility
and
so i would ask you who best governed
your life i wouldn't pretend to say i
know i can go shopping for you i could
plan your vacation for you all these
things we we each individually know our
preferences we have the tacit knowledge
relevant we know our incentives and
the same is true i think we here can
govern ourselves much better than some
strangers even if they're experts even
if they're geniuses hundreds of miles
away who claim the ability to do this
for a third of a billion people we have
an opportunity today to to
peacefully evolve away from that and i
think uh it's
uh
to speak to the gentleman uh
politics always lags and it's and
there's been talk of independence
movements in various states for years
now and we're seeing that come
become more serious and i think for good
reason because the
american empire is
is
very clearly seen to be based on
violence
and
it's time we move past that and we can
do better and it's possible to thrive
while things around us are collapsing
okay
thank you for your time thank you um
are there any questions seeing none
uh the chair recognized um
aria di mazzo de
boy i butchered some names there that's
for sure
so if i butcher your name let me
apologize in advance all right
it's okay i've heard worse all right
and he supports the bill you got one
minute i like that go ahead yeah so i've
had this whole prepared statement but
i'm throwing it out i'll probably it's
written down so i'll pass it up at the
end but seeing as my family first came
to you came to north america in 1620 i
think i'm probably fairly qualified to
answer the question of
what would these people think about what
we're doing today they'd be ashamed that
anyone had the audacity to stand here
and act like we have to be loyal to dead
people that dead people are the ones who
governors rather than us governing
ourselves
ultimately this is a question of who
governs who do the people of new
hampshire govern themselves are they
governed by washington d.c or are they
governed by people who live more than
200 years ago
and that's all i have to say
okay
thank you
i i was thinking that in my mind about
governing i
i don't nobody's governing me that's for
sure but anyways um
no questions
that sounded like a question
no i'm just saying i mean i live a lot
i'm a retired marine and i live a life i
don't you don't think the federal
government governs you no not at all so
they don't write the laws to which you
are compelled to obey well the state of
new hampshire probably does the same
thing
yes but does new hampshire govern itself
or does the federal government
new hampshire governs themselves but
they also over the years taken a lot of
carrots
and they've taken a lot of funding and
they agreed to certain things which i
totally disagreed for me i didn't agree
to any of that did you no you then you
need to run for state rep then
i have run for state rep also ran for
sheriff okay well most of the people in
this room have run for something okay uh
and of course you all know that the
state is not a uh is not a home rule
state we're a dillon state where the
legislators make the decisions uh on
behalf of the people you know that right
do you truly believe the federal
government doesn't govern you well i'm
not going to answer i'm not going to sit
here and keep going back and forth
that's a really simple question it is i
i don't think the federal government
runs my life i
try to i'm sorry for you you don't you
don't see the boot on your neck nope i
don't nope thank you um
who's next is
chris reichman
welcome chris
appreciate if you can get it down to
three minutes
i get about 20 cards here that i want to
get through
i read very fast thank you
my name is chris streetman and i'm from
alstead i'm a small business owner an
employer a veteran a planning board
member and former selectmen
i come here today to express my support
for cacr32
most citizens may not realize that this
is not our first rodeo we spent seven
years in open rebellion against the
crown before we gained our independence
seven years
at issue is whether the citizens of new
hampshire are better served by special
interests in washington
or by you
and concord
new hampshire no longer has a seat at
the nationals table
since the passage of the 17th amendment
in 1913 no state has any representation
any longer at the national level the
three-legged stool
envisioned by the framers is mutated now
the central government has its president
the people still have their congress
person who represents on average 708 000
people
but the senate now represents the
special interest groups
75 million dollar
campaigns for a senate seat
really
that change is significant it
strategically altered it completely
altered
what we signed up for
when new hampshire joined the union
it's not the same country that we agreed
to sign onto
it altered the structure
my question is this if new hampshire was
independent right now let's
put let this be your mindset
we are in an independent new hampshire
and a bunch of guys come from dc
and they're going to pitch us on joining
their government
what would the pitch be
do you like huge monolithic
bureaucracies we have to borrow
just to do what we do but we still
choose to do more how about decisions
made by special interest groups and
corrupt politicians do you like that
we're gonna have wars and we're gonna
send your sons and daughters into wars
that that we can't even afford or pay
for uh we're not even gonna follow the
constitution when we do send those in
and but you are going to have to
follow what our regulatory behemoth says
you must do
um and you're going to pay for it we're
going to tax you and send all that money
to dc
uh what do you say
it's insane the people of new hampshire
would never take it if you look at the
state of the united states today you
couldn't sell it to the very people
we're talking to
do any of you seriously think
that there
that this whole talk of national divorce
that's occurring across the country not
a day goes by in my news feed
when it doesn't pop up when another
article written or another editorial
doesn't pop up where people are
wondering
whether people are best served by dc
this is a question it's not a question
that we're just asking here in new
hampshire a bunch of crazy free staters
and people are just asking it's asked
all across the country
besides the failings of government our
country has devolved into political
parties always at war over power
oligarchs who paid the price to play and
those who were forced to pay the bills
and that's you and me
there is bipartisan support for a
national
divorce and i suspect we have the same
bipartisan support in the people of new
hampshire
i think you need to give them the right
to see that question
and that's what's a that
that's all right if you can close it up
that's
that's what the question is can they see
the question thank you for your time
thank you i appreciate your testimony
is that written
testimony yeah do you have written
testimony you want to turn in yeah i'm
really old and i can't see well so i
screwed up most of it but i'm happy to
send it that's all right yeah uh we're
old too and we uh same thing so don't
worry about it
okay
thank you
i'm only 39 so
okay uh bonnie cruz
i want to welcome bonnie uh
in two minutes
thank you
hi go ahead
you said you were
you were a marine and you don't believe
with federal excuse me i'm not if anyone
served in the marines when we weren't
were we are back
all right you you said you are and
somehow you still are but the federal
government doesn't run your life so this
must mean that you're just okay with
things that i'm not okay with
war is all across the world every day
people dying
my dad was in the army for 26 years
by the way that's why i'm a free stater
i don't have a state that i'm from
i moved every three years of my life and
i chose new hampshire
because when covet happened and i lived
in texas at the time
texans just rolled over
and i heard
on the radio
about people in new hampshire free
staters who were deciding
we're not going to just roll over and
take it we're going to
not listen to the rules that are going
on ruining people's lives and businesses
and livelihoods
and that's that's why i moved here i
haven't had to
i haven't had to change my life a bit
since i moved here because there are
people here who are moving to new
hampshire because new hampshire is
supposed to be the live free or die
state
where we don't just take crap from
people who decide that they can control
our lives that includes the federal
government the federal government was
never
i mean i've never voted i mean i mean
never voted for the uh
the federal government to exist well i
was just born into it i didn't get to
sign a contract there's no implicit
contract
that's why free staters are choosing new
hampshire to move to because there's
already a culture here of
peaceful
just leave me alone ism live for your
die that's what it is
and i just i really resent the fact that
you um are acting like you're going to
be
against us you're you're characterizing
us in a bad way you are you are you said
oh with your drugs what is that supposed
to mean with your drugs
i've never said dude i just said they
support open drugs so uh just to correct
that so it was never said does that mean
that does that mean that
you're gonna go i'm not gonna sit here
and argue with gemma i agree with the
free state of a lot of this stuff so i
mean i don't so you're arguing with the
wrong guy and i so
continue please
that was basically my point my my dad
was in the army and he uh
had to go through a lot of crap and do a
lot of bad things my grandpa was in the
marines and he was in vietnam and he had
to kill school children because of the
federal government and it's ruined his
life he's in uh absolute shambles he's
uh you know a ruined human human being
because of what the federal government
is making new hampshire people pay for
every day
and fund
and we just don't want that anymore
we're just asking you to allow us to
vote to not to have the opportunity to
not fund that
okay thank you and i want to thank your
father for his service here for making
sure we fought him over there my dad
wants uh you know my dad wouldn't agree
with the way you're treating people uh
who me yeah
okay yeah thank you have a nice day you
got a question yeah quick quick question
just a just uh uh
are you opposed you check the pose to
the bill i'm assuming i changed my
stance i was going to make a point i
don't like the things this guy's been
doing insane
so you oppose the bill no i support the
bill i want you to i just said i want
you to vote to pass the bill since i'm
not a bad guy we'll change it for you
originally right you didn't you didn't
want to support this originally but now
you do i had a a
a point i was going to make in opposing
the bill i
elliott axelman all right where's he at
how are you elliot
yeah
all right
welcome i'm gonna try not to treat you
too bad okay thank you
all right thank you very much committee
for letting me speak um i have some
remarks a few representatives made some
points i wanted to clear up i believe
representative said we wouldn't have
medicare social security anymore
medicare is federal medicaid is state
federal but social security if you move
to any other country pretty much any
other country you will still get social
security so that wasn't uh totally
accurate but uh more important though if
we left we'd all be saving 20 30 40 on
federal income taxes federal corporate
taxes and 100 other taxes or so we'd all
have 20 30 40 000 more in our pockets we
could afford insurance as for those who
paid into medicare and they're already
70 and can't necessarily work and save
up any more by private insurance we will
arrange during secession no one's going
to say you know we leave and next day
we're gone and you know no negotiations
like brexit there will be months or
years of negotiations those who are 70
and worked hard like some people in this
body will get medicare because they paid
into it so you know it's not that simple
we're not gonna let him die on the
streets
i believe jess edwards said he agrees
with some of our points but at this
point he thinks he would vote no um but
it seems like he's coming along so i
think in a few months he might support
the session uh he said if you don't
agree with it just run for office or
vote harder again with all due respect
um obviously i respect representative
edwards but he said just run for
congress we've tried that exact method
run for congress and support was running
for 240 years every day so me i'm not
that old my father my father's father
yeah my father's father was an army
judge plenty of family in the military
they served the federal government right
now
i think they would you know they
wouldn't support the federal government
anymore my grandfather i don't think he
just passed away but we've tried that
exact method for 20 to 40 years the
definition of insanity is literally
trying the same thing every day again
and again for 240 years and expecting a
different result does anyone in this
body i haven't heard from any person in
the world who thinks who has explained
to me a proper actual methodology for
how we're going to change the track the
trend of the federal government the
federal government every day for 240
years has become bigger expanded and
minimized our liberties crushed our
natural human rights
what is the reason to believe that it's
going to change in 2020 it'll change in
2024 it'll change we'll win by congress
both parties have had full control
nothing has changed it either grows
extremely fast or it grows super fast
there's no big difference it's always
growing super fast or extremely fast um
again i've asked representative to the
chase to debate me he declined he does
not want to debate me i've asked any
legislator any legislator or anyone else
to debate me on independence nobody one
person debated me a few weeks ago i
technically won the debate it was a
great debate we need to have this
discussion any legislator in this body
or anywhere you did buy me a cup of
coffee by the way yeah yeah thank you
okay yeah for the record yeah anyone who
wants to debate me i'm very happy to
debate i think we should have a public
debate um as for the constitution
representative deschez brought up the
constitution a few times and i think
that's a very interesting point number
one as as i'm sure some will mention
about lysander spooner i never signed
the contract the theory that my
great-great-grandfather theoretically
assuming they lived in the united states
and weren't immigrants my
great-great-great-great-great-great-grandfather
24 years ago signed a contract binding b
all contract law in the world would deny
that that is legitimate i cannot bind my
son let alone my grandson in perpetuity
to be a slave to anyone else right i can
sign a contract for me and i have
limited custodial powers over my son if
they're five years old but i can't say
my grandfather my grandson will be a
slave to you in 200 years so the fact
that anyone says the constitution's a
contract is total bogus all contract law
would agree with that in the world look
at any contract law in the universe you
can't if you you can't if you didn't
sign the contract under informed consent
if someone 240 years ago signed a
contract to say that that applies to you
but even let's say the constitution is
legitimate and just full disclosure full
openly to the federal government i
withdraw my consent i never consented to
the federal government ruling over me i
don't want you i don't want your money i
don't want your laws but if we're gonna
talk about the constitution and i think
the shay's mentioned a few times it's
unconstitutional on its face even though
it's not um okay if we are going to obey
absolutely obey and enforce the
constitution who has violated the
constitution if it's a contract who has
violated it us or them well let's list
the violations of the u.s constitution
by the dc tyrants they've violated the
first amendment many times i've written
books about it violated the second
amendment many times i've written a book
about it violated the fourth and fifth
amendment's due process i'm finishing up
a book on massive amounts of violations
of due process by the federal government
if you don't like civil asset forfeiture
eminent domain um acquitted context
sentencing felony murder rules uh almost
every single federal law warrantless
checkpoints cbp surveillance almost all
of it comes from dc they have violated
the constitution so representative de
chaise is saying they are the traitors
he is saying they are the traitors you
say you want to enforce the constitution
the letter of the law everyone in dc i'm
not going to say the word but what
happens to the traders that's what
representative chase is saying he's
saying words traders we want to leave
peacefully this is an abusive
relationship even if we entered into it
voluntarily which nobody here signed any
constitution nobody joined the union if
we had to join the union today we would
vote no if all of you were independent
now and have to vote whether to join the
union or stay independent i'm sure all
of you would not want to join that
terrible cluster
of what the union is 20 for 29 trillion
reasons obviously we would want to
remain independent now we are saying we
want to peacefully leave imagine there's
a woman being abused beaten viciously
beaten and abused in every way by your
husband and she wants to leave
peacefully whose side would you be on
you're saying we can't leave peacefully
and in fact what representative the
shades just said to people like me if we
want to leave we're committing rebellion
and also we'll come in with tanks the
federal government and kill you so what
they're saying is we want to leave
peacefully
you're they're saying your trader for
wanting to leave in fact we're going to
use violence against you so he's saying
we're saying we want to leave peacefully
and the opponents of this legislation
are saying that violence solves the it
solves the question also they were
saying the civil war a lot of people say
the civil war settled this literally
that is saying mike makes right they
tried to leave they killed you so don't
try again again they are the ones we are
the peaceful ones over here you see all
the peace signs over here we're all
anti-war we're all pro-peace non-violent
voluntarists
they are the ones supporting violence
they said the civil war settled this so
again go back to your friend mary she's
being abused by her husband she tried to
leave once her husband caught her
unfortunately beat her tied her up beat
her to near death and it didn't work out
would you tell her to never try again
because her husband settled that issue
because mike makes right never try to
leave again that's ridiculous of course
i want you to close it up
six minutes thank you thank you thanks
for allowing me all right if session is
illegal as somebody mentioned we should
be still be part of the british
government that was a secession clear
and simple we seceded from the fed from
the british government and i mean people
who who say it's illegal they're right
it was illegal it was it was treason and
they understood that but if i'm in the
company of thomas jefferson or george
washington so be it call me a traitor
and kill me if you will that's all right
um
it just let me see if i have anything
else here i'm happy to two questions as
well
all right thank you actually any
questions any questions uh seeing none
uh thank you
mr chairman i'm gonna approach you and
ask you a question before we move on to
the next witness yes you can
thank you thank you
[Applause]
okay um
the chair recognize uh justin o'donnell
and uh he supports the bill two minutes
i like you justin already two minutes
put a good in my committee we've been
sitting here since nine this morning me
seven eight o'clock but go ahead
honorable members of the committee uh
thank you for hearing testimony for
myself and others today my name is
justin o'donnell i'm from manchester and
some of you may know me i've worked with
some of you i've worked with many
members of this house on legislation and
activism in the past i've also worked
against some of you and against many
members of this house some of you on
both different sides depending on the
issue i come to you here today on an
issue
not on partisanship not on the side
i came today not knowing where i wanted
to stay just where i stood and i the
representative aldesaro has asked us not
to be repetitive so i just want to take
a moment to
comment on representative deshay's
remarks earlier regarding the
constitution he spoke a lot about the
u.s constitution and his ramifications
however i feel compelled to agree with
and speak to what lasander spooner wrote
in no treason constitution of no
authority and he says
but whether the constitution really be
one thing or another this much is
certain
that it has either authorized such a
government as we have had or it has been
powerless to prevent it in either case
it is unfit to exist
what we are discussing is a measure to
allow the people of new hampshire a
voice in whether or not they would
reject subservience
to a document that has failed to protect
their rights
he also insinuated that you could be
considered to be in rebellion simply by
voting in favor
of putting this question on the ballot
well to be frank the line between
sedition and patriotism is fine and
often blurry it is the duty of those
people who call themselves patriots to
oppose the expansion of overreach of
tyrannical governments at every step and
when standing up for your individual
sovereignty crosses the line between
patriotism and treason it's not you
that's gone too far it's the government
that you're opposing that has
overstepped its bounds
i urge you to pass this measure and
allow the decision to be made not by
this body but by the people of this
state directly
and to address the question
representative branch had asked earlier
in the day why don't we pursue a measure
to allow people to simply have a
referendum on the ballot we've tried and
this body refused and state reps in this
body
testified against a constitutional
amendment two years ago that would allow
citizens of new hampshire to petition a
referendum onto the ballot and the
arguments made were that the people were
too stupid and uninformed to be that
directly involved in the legislative
process and that this body was loathe to
seed that authority back to the people
so it was this body in this house of
representatives that
kept that power from the people and
that's why we pursue it now as a
constitutional amendment thank you i
want to wrap up if anyone thank you
justin um
you have a question well
can i have that testimony have you sent
that i'm sorry thank you i've been
writing it as we've been going okay
can you can you take that and and email
that to our committee yes that would
really be great thank you thank you
question uh representative moffat has a
question for you
yeah thank you for taking my question
and i i
will preface it by just saying this has
been very very interesting for me to get
a better sense of how a lot of folks are
looking at things uh so the wheels are
turning in my head but i want to ask you
and i and maybe somebody else can speak
to this if new hampshire were to become
independent
uh what
other countries in europe
who would you see this new sovereign in
new hampshire aligning with or
connecting whether
or lying or not necessarily lying you
know
who uh who would this new
entity connect with uh
outside of uh
the united states is there a
a country that
would have a similar
type of uh
uh political philosophy that that this
new sovereign new hampshire would
connect to i'm just i'm just wondering
lichtenstein switzerland monaco um there
are small nations scattered across
europe that have governed themselves
independently for centuries
without a larger empire to protect them
there is no
there is no sense to an argument that
secession or the breakup of the united
states need be a violent breakup or
anything other than an amicable national
divorce should the united states break
up and sever whether it's just new
hampshire or new hampshire texas
california alaska any of the other
states considering secession is part of
the national divorce there's nothing to
say that a compact between those states
and a mutual defense treaty and mutual
trade treaties couldn't be reached in an
amicable and peaceful manner as part of
the discussion process and negotiation
process afterward we saw with brexit
that when the united kingdom wanted to
leave the european union a union very
similar to the united states where
sovereign states joined in an economic
and defense pact that those negotiations
were approached peacefully while
contentiously peacefully
and the united kingdom was allowed to
leave
and even when the united kingdom left
one of their own provinces scotland
decided they wanted to have their own
referendum to leave the united kingdom
and go back which failed but it showed
that a peaceful process can occur and
those processes happened through
negotiation and talks and public
involvement
not
through backdoor deals and closed roam
bureaucratic processes
uh follow up comment real quick uh yeah
so again the wheels are turning i'm
thinking about uh borders and tariffs
and
what if other entities countries put
tariffs on our products or would we put
tariffs i mean there's no answer tonight
these you just got us thinking about
this in ways we haven't thought about it
before and we'll have more questions
later but anyway thank you for for your
your testimony thank you justin i don't
see anybody a question
thank you
now that was a good question there
because i look at the ports the waterway
the security of the
new hampshire
thought involved in just saying get rid
of the federal government
okay uh the chair recognized that
supports the bill uh john coffin josh
oh josh okay i'm sorry josh i should get
my glasses
did he no i'm right here oh he's right
right there
hi josh uh i appreciate it let me see um
where's this guy right here yeah
unsure i'm gonna try please keep it
under three minutes i'll try thank you
uh thank you for letting me speak here
today uh it's your privilege one thing
that
one thing that hasn't really been talked
about is uh the perspective of some of
the history here
so when
when america first started
each state was an individual country
and we were a confederation of states
um
i didn't write anything down obviously
here um i normally don't speak
so i'm going to try my best here
take your time okay three minutes
yeah no
pressure um
so i guess you know i i pretty much i
decided to speak because i heard other
people that were representatives uh they
kept citing the 14th amendment as some
form of authority
now if we look at how that happened
through history it's no form of
authority at all
um
calling the united states a country is
like calling europe a country we don't
call europe a country we know better so
the idea of the states is they're all
supposed to be individual nations
and the federal government their role
was they met like maybe a couple of
times a year you know the farmers left
their farms you know the businessmen
left their businesses and they'd meet
for a couple of times a year settle some
stuff and go back home they weren't
career politicians
we're not seeing exactly what we're
seeing today
um
and then we had what was called the
civil war
which i preferred to call it the war
against the states
and it was totally about state
sovereignty
you had a federal government who wanted
to do something that they're not
supposed to or that they don't have
authority to if that sounds familiar
today
that's what's happening
and
the states had the authority
to leave that that union because the
federal government wasn't doing
what they were supposed to be doing they
wanted to do more they wanted more power
well we know who won again somebody else
had said might you know might wins and
so we saw you know a big war machine win
now the way again the federal government
is supposed to only meet a couple of
times a year and that's it they're not
supposed to live in dc and like hang out
and get paid like by a bunch of
corporations
what we're seeing is an abuse of power
and this isn't the first time in history
we've seen this obviously
and i'm not really sure what else to say
i guess if anybody has any questions i i
do know a lot about this history and i
guess i should have came with something
written down
well you did a great job there for your
first time speaking so okay okay are
there any questions
seeing none thank you thanks
the chair recognized alice alex weed
i said that right weed
okay
yeah they have it
i don't have it but they
welcome uh alex thank you
so you said how many minutes uh seven
minutes
three minutes yeah you get yeah you got
it
uh my name is alex weed i reside in
manchester uh i am not a constitutional
scholar
uh i want to speak on financial matters
uh there are logistics involved uh with
that
you made this uh mr speaker you made
this statement uh today we don't care
what the un says
i say to you the imf care does not the
imf does not care what you say
this is not a conversation about new
hampshire versus the united states it's
about the state versus you
it's about the individual versus the
collective
the federal government is bankrupt
social security
medicare they print money into existence
out of thin air
what good is federal funding if the
money has no purchasing power
in zimbabwe they printed 100 trillion
dollar notes
it was better to
burn the money for its intrinsic heat
content
if people want to do further research on
this they can go to fred
fred.stlouisfed.org look at the m1 look
at the m2
look at how much money they are printing
democrats if you really truly wanted to
help people you would advocate for
honest and sound money we're not getting
that from the united states
the chickens are coming home to roost
you will not be able to stop the
financial crisis which is about to beset
the world
the death of the dollar will be the
second largest event in human history
next to the birth of jesus christ
it literally does not matter how you
vote on this issue the united states
government is collapsing this goose is
cooked and you cannot save it
out of this chaos a new world order will
be formed
your vote will decide whether we submit
to globalist tyranny or whether we
embrace individual sovereignty
what sort of order do you wish to create
i don't know about you but i've already
voted in my heart
okay thank you
[Applause]
are there any questions uh
representative branch
in
in your testimony today you talked about
the collapse of the united states in a
new world order
uh
we increasingly see a rise in uh chinese
and the chinese communist party and its
influence in the world
uh how do you see
us fighting against that if we're we're
not the united states and we're all
divided uh the 50 states ourselves how
are we supposed to stand against
china and the chinese communist party
and its influence
uh i think we're united
right all right who's weak
okay that's a small yeah that's a small
group in new hampshire oh there's a lot
of people uh who are not present right
now
ultimately this is a spiritual battle
and it's it's a spiritual battle of uh
sovereign individuals
ultimately
china is the testing bed for the
collectivist
social credit score system uh australia
also uh that is the testing ground where
they are perfecting their technology and
it will come here
this this is this is a spiritual battle
it's the the battle is within
further questions thank you i agree on
the spiritual thing i've been in many
countries all around the world and
religious
is a dangerous thing in other countries
that's for sure
um any other questions
see you none thank you very much for
your testimony you're welcome thank you
i have a card here for somebody that
said nobody so that tells me that's
getting thrown out but it says it's got
a phone number and it's got it
oh that's your legal name oh yeah oh oh
i apologize okay hey nobody it's a good
what do you get on is that a marine
corps emblem
oh okay
but hey welcome nobody
i am nobody hear me ruler
the uh i changed my name to nobody when
i ran for governor
i ran against john sununu and uh nobody
knew it because he ignored me but uh my
slogan was nobody knows how to run your
life better than you do and nobody
deserves that kind of power
and that's really
what this comes down to today i was told
when i was a child
that uh we had a government by consent
in the united states and that that was
the basis of the justice of our system
well nobody ever asked my consent
my consent has been neither requested
nor required what has been done
is that i have had decrees imposed upon
me
all of my life regardless of my choice
regardless of my rights as a human being
and regardless of my consent the united
states government has no more interest
in consent than a serial rapist
the problem with the constitution is
that it has been soaked in centuries and
oceans of blood it has been the excuse
for murder for torture for rape for
doing enough doing medical experiments
on people against their will for slavery
for mass
imprisonment
for
destruction of human beings for the sake
of doing it and the basic problem
is that the united states government is
a corporation
now what is a corporation a corporation
is a person without a soul without a
conscience that is able to act
independently in in jewish mythology
they call this a gollum and the problem
with gollums is they always
turn from their intended purpose
and start doing mischief and our
government
the government that claims to own us
is doing a lot of mischief
the uh
there is absolutely no way
to justify
keep forcing people to pay for wars to
which they are morally opposed there is
absolutely nothing that could possibly
justify forcing me to pay for the
imprisonment of my fellow citizens when
i think there is they have done nothing
wrong there is absolutely nothing
morally that can justify forcing me at
gunpoint to pay
for to fund the lab in wuhan that may
well have developed the corona virus and
released it either accidentally or
intentionally with or without the
cooperation of the sainted dr fauci
there is absolutely nothing that can
justify
forcing me to to put a drug in my body
that i don't want can i get you to close
it up uh we're over almost four minutes
i'm i'm getting there
so so that is basically the problem here
when you
force your will on other people against
their consent
you are doing something wrong and
nothing but evil will ever
come from that and when you look at the
rising hatred between democrats and
republicans and it is hatred i have
never seen this country so hateful as i
have during the trump years and during
the biden years and you know partially
one of them was a malignant narcissist
and the other one is a senile child
molester but so i guess that has some
understanding but the thing is when you
seek to control people and to force your
will on them
yes you are inviting and you deserve the
hatred and the violence that you receive
in response i appreciate thank you for
your testimony i appreciate it i don't
mean to cut you off but i got other
people will you anyone have any
questions
seeing that there's no questions uh
thank you
uh the chair recognized uh
just move that from this
uh will kelly
hi well kelly
welcome
and um
it says
will
and then kelly yes
yes hillsborough
yeah hillsbow yeah
in three minutes please thank you and i
should be able to keep it much shorter
than that we appreciate it so a lot of
people have gotten up here and talked
about the logistics of what happens if
new hampshire succeeds
there's of course
issues
issues that have to be worked out things
like that
that and really i think that misses the
heart of what this is right here right
now we're not talking about whether
anyone on this committee thinks that new
hampshire should succeed i think there
are some very
good questions and reasons people should
be skeptical of that what this here
is is asking if this bill should be
idled or put to a vote
my representative is not here on this
committee
what i'm asking for those here who are
considering itling this vote
is to give me a voice a voice we're not
asking
for whether you think this should or
should not happen what we're asking is
if this gets put to the legislative body
so that people can provide the vote
or people can provide their input and
work through their system and have their
voices heard and i believe a vote to itl
this today
is a vote saying that people like me are
not intelligent enough and should not
have the right to voice our opinion
through our reps to make this happen so
i'm asking each of you here today to
give me a voice let me talk to my rep
and let this come to a vote don't kill
this in committee and that is all okay
thank you
yeah
uh the by the way uh whether it comes
out of your itl just your own
information or ought to pass it goes to
the floor and it needs two-thirds of uh
you know the vote ourselves i think two
yeah so one way or another it's going to
go to the floor of everybody either
going to vote
i think it's suit
three fair yeah it's a constitution yeah
it's a conscious amendment yeah i read
three
okay the chair recognized uh
let me see we already did will kelly
right yeah
okay
christopher
what is that uh n
looks almost like wind uh from from
emerald street
in keene
is he here christopher from kane
yeah wade oh okay yes all right
hi welcome
hi
three minutes thank you okay i'm
christopher wade from keene new
hampshire i want to
there's a lot of i want to talk about
but i'll try and keep it short the new
hampshire advantage died um the supreme
court recently ruled a couple years ago
now uh that basically you have to
collect tax for 10 000 different jury or
more than 10 000 different taxing
jurisdictions in the united states it
doesn't matter that you're in new
hampshire uh and new hampshire doesn't
have a sales tax
there's a 25 tariff on goods coming into
the united states which basically
reduces your effective income by about
13 percent
there's a lot of problems and these are
just some examples of
what uh what we can't solve without
independence
new samples new hampshire's population
would be wealthier if independent and
one of the wealthiest countries in the
world
71 to 78 of the population in new
hampshire supports independence
according to a union leader poll that's
three times three four times more than
any other uh independence movie in the
united states that's i believe uh even
more or basically around what
canada
um
independence
in quebec i believe was
so there's actually a good chance that
this could pass if those numbers are
accurate and obviously it's not a
scientific poll so it is hard to tell
but i'm also comparing against
unscientific polls so if new hampshire's
constitutional authorized joining the
united states it must be the case that
it can authorize leaving the united
states
this is the peaceful solution in
independence not the violent version and
i would encourage you to vote for this
amendment else we risk things getting
out of control you can only repress the
population for so long
if independence is impossible that is
all the more reason to declare it that
sends the message to dc that we will not
sit idly by and do nothing if the dc
invades we will gain economic prosperity
that's exactly what happened in
afghanistan
explicitly because
explicitly because this is not a war and
troops on our streets would help us
economically
they would contribute to our economy
nobody has proposed a war
nobody is suggesting war what we're
suggesting is that we declare
independence
at some point
the united states will leave they will
take their troops and go home just like
they did in afghanistan it might take 20
years but it can happen
an independent new hampshire does not
mean anyone will lose their u.s
citizenship as this is
the way of uh this is done through birth
okay you are born a u.s citizen well i
mean generally speaking most of us
anyway um and you wouldn't lose it just
because you are now also a new hampshire
citizenship now people born
after independence would only have new
hampshire citizenship but
again that's that's not really too much
of a problem
nobody would lose their social security
because it's not where you live that
determines that it's based on having
paid into the system and i know many
people who live in different countries
who largely or i'm sorry legally collect
on their social security
this amendment does not solve every
issue this is just to ask reps to let
the citizenry vote on independence and
the details are left to the courts and
legislators to decide through law to
resolve any conflicts that remain
certainly there would there will be
issues
independence is messy
those who support i'm almost done the
support those who support independence
are still supporting democracy we
wouldn't be here right now those who are
violent aren't here but they exist
already and peaceful people can also
become violent if things continue down
this terrible path and we have been
heading that way i ask you not to create
a situation that would move peaceful
people to violent revolution
the us is the u.s waging war against new
hampshire would result in significant
economic harm to the u.s just as it
would harm harm new hampshire
this is not afghanistan but even those
with few arms are successful at winning
a war against the united states many
countries have divided without war
we can do the same in new hampshire
well thank you
one thing that you said about social
security won't lose um so you're saying
there that
we'll keep our ties if we uh this passes
keep our ties with the u.s and do social
security social security doesn't go away
because it's not based on uh where you
live so if you paid into it let me let
me rephrase that question
will people be required to still pay
into social security now so okay
what happened to it that you would do
and answer me real quick if you can
what would happen to all them people
that are 55
50 40 60 that aren't 65 yet or whatever
that paid into the system what happens
today i would still get it up until the
point in which they stopped paying it
they will get it yeah that's how that
works
okay
all right yeah and we have such strong
economic ties to the united states the
united states would would be crazy it's
this isn't afghanistan that they're
invading it's they're actually hurting
themselves because we're so closely tied
economically to boston to the united
states even after independence
okay thank you um the jail recognized um
sean
farber
hi sean um three minutes we appreciate
it yep
thank you um i wasn't gonna originally
talk but you know after hearing all of
this and just sitting back and thinking
about it
i just thought i've grown up excuse me
one second i can't
hear
i appreciate it if um
thank you
okay go ahead
um i grew up this country like everybody
else just thinking well most people
thinking you know america is a really
you know a place where we do things
different we embrace democracy and i
think everybody republican or democrat
can say we really you know we believe in
democracy what that form of democracy is
varies
um you know you do the right things
everything's going to work out we're the
greatest country in the world in all
those things over the course of my
adulthood and especially in the last
eight years
you kind of lose some of that luster on
those things
and
being in new hampshire i've seen that
things can really work at this level and
are
are doing well and it's kind of restored
my faith in systems
um but
just thinking about it it's
if we don't get a chance to use our
voice if we can't even
speak and say
through a vote on a ballot
that we
don't agree with what's going on in dc
and we want something else i mean in the
end of the day that's all we're asking
for here i mean
i'm not going to bore you with you know
definitions of why we should
legislatively do this or not do this i
just want a voice i just want a chance i
just want to be able to say
like i've been taught all along why
america is so great i should be able to
say things by doing the right things and
and going through and getting this done
the right way
so thank you well thank you sean uh
yeah you know i noticed you're from uh
londonderry yes and you know you could
always voice i never had a problem
voicing with me or anybody and i you
know been kicking in doors for people
down here in londonderry so
freedom's a beautiful thing thank you
okay the chair recognize
uh
jonah wheeler
oh by the way of course you won't get a
chance to vote for me anymore it's my
last term oh is it your last term yeah
but go ahead you're such an exciting
state rep it'll be sad to see i'm done
all right
i'm going to work on my team i know if
you agree with him or not i mean he's
exciting
thank you al rapper al desara for having
me here today i mean i i oppose this
legislation um for a number of reasons
one of most is i love this country
uh and i i heard that a lot from the
other side you know we love this country
so much that we want to leave
i love this country so much that i want
to fight to make it better i know as a
black person i've
you know not i don't identify but like i
as someone who has faced the worst of
this country you look like american to
me that's what i was going to say right
thank you mr balosaki but as someone who
has faced the worst of this country as
someone who has been homeless who rents
who has had a house fall through who
doesn't have health care who has
gotten the short end of the stick in
terms of this country and what it has
given me
i can tell you that
my passion for the country and fixing it
only grows
the greater my struggle is uh the more
struggle that i have the more i want to
fight and be here and say look we should
focus on those poor people who are
actually uh
you know
the lifeblood of this country we could
we should focus on the people who you
know a lot of these people here today
who are angry and upset about the
situation that we are in inflation all
of these things the wars i think we
agree on those situations
so why wouldn't we be here today
condemning those wars trying to pass
legislation to effect change uh in terms
of how we could reduce inflation or
something like that why wouldn't we
focus on the issues that are making
people angry and not try to create a
whole other divisive issue
like
seceding from the union
and it just seems like a waste of time
to me when there are serious issues that
could be addressed not by the federal
government but right here in the state
legislature we could be focusing on
those issues condemning the federal
government for what it needs to be there
are things that we can do we have the
power here in the state house we have
the power as people um i agree the
federal government is is quite
tyrannical it's it's leaning towards
dictatorship that is a scary thing that
is a terribly scary thing
but i don't want to leave the united
states of america just because
some people who are at the head of the
united states of america are twisting
and manipulating what the message of
that country is
we've lost our country this is not our
country we've lost it but we can bring
it back
seceding is not how we bring it back
fighting for it is how we bring it back
honoring
what the people who died in 1776 you i
mean you were a marine you you signed up
and fought we have to honor those people
by fighting for what this country stands
for and restoring the soul of this
country restoring the liberty life and
pursuit of happiness that is entitled
and guaranteed to every person in it
thank
you you know i'm impressed thank you i
appreciate that on your conversation
here with the committee
i i agree with you on your that we
you know we fight for what's right and
like i said somebody's been all around
the world and seeing how people want to
religious groups and other countries
want to kill americans whether you like
it or not but unless you've been there
done that you have no clue so i kiss the
ground i walk on in this country
and appreciate every day on what i got
because i worked for it right and
nothing's given to me and really quickly
i mean you love it i think i thank you
for your testimony really quickly like
if you have a drug addict son you don't
throw him out on the street you take him
in and you take care of him right you
love him it's unconditional love and we
need to unconditionally love our country
thank you mr welcome no questions yeah
all right
okay the chair recognize uh patrick uh
bender
uh one minute uh supports the bill hi
patrick
from manchester all right i'll do my
best it might be a little over
patrick bender manchester father free
stater small business owner
i moved here five years ago i've lived
in other countries i've traveled the
world and i agree with these statements
that there's something special here
let's turn red right
is all right
so um i recently went back to california
for the first time in three years and um
you know one of the reasons why i moved
here
was because i i i see the decline there
it's
it's almost uh
i mean it's just sad it's sad to see so
i i found myself on the beach feet in
the sand
watching a bunch of people
walk by in their mask on the beach um
and watching
all these mandates i mean i went to a
park and it said that you had to wear a
mask in the park
it
it's it's insane what's happening around
the us today
and we'd be delusional if we ignored it
and said this is happening in some
vacuum or you know that's not going on
we have to recognize the the greater
situation there so when i heard about
this bill coming up i kind of i wasn't
sure whether uh
whether the time was right until i just
got back from a trip in san diego to san
diego because
it's it's not good what what what's
going on in the u.s and all the other
reasons
you know
is that everyone in the us is very
delusional about the wars about what's
happening in dc they it's easy with our
prosperity to ignore all of it and just
say oh we'll get by on the fact that
we're doing so well economically
but that's going to come back
so when i saw this law this cacr come up
um i i started walking through myself
through the process of of what it would
mean
and
ultimately this this is just a question
can we can the people answer it that's
all we're talking about
and this is the democratic process this
is the process this is the peaceful
process is is getting people to to
answer that question because i've been
following this kind of stuff around the
world for a long time this usually ends
in violence uh and the way it happened
in the us they said we're gonna be
independent and the king said no i'm
gonna come send soldiers there right it
goes violent
if it doesn't go peaceful right so we're
trying to we everyone wants us to go
peaceful everyone does but it's
untenable it's already violent they're
already attacking us
it's already that bad and
they don't they're not our friends
people in california don't
they're not they don't give a crap about
you and new hampshire
and that's my impression you know not
just california everywhere everywhere
i've been they care about themselves
they think their state's number one they
would love to exert all their control
over you
and i think it's an abusive relationship
that we need to get out of
while we can why we can do it peacefully
um i don't think this will even if it
went to the people i i you know i think
it's a big thing whether it would
actually pass there but we got out we
got to let the question be asked because
if we don't we're shutting down the
peaceful option and that's not we can't
do that
because then that's that's already
saying that that
that's giving into the violence
and so we need to stick with peace
thank you very much questions
if not the
chair is back and thank you we'll be
looking for aaron lyons of derry
okay that one there's the one that just
got done right yeah
there you go okay to chill recognize
kyle r
if wait a minute wait a minute we want
aaron oh i'm sorry aaron aaron uh aaron
yeah lying hiding lions
sorry about that it took me a second
yeah no problem three minutes and uh
before you get started here i have three
cards left so that's telling my
committee that we're going to be going
home soon so i appreciate it if you're
going to submit a card you get it in
right now i'm cutting that's it
okay thank you go ahead thank you
um
so
i can trace my lineage back to the
mayflower
and back to england right
um
my family is very very proud of that
i have
a ton of military in my family i have a
ton of friends in my family
that that are current and former
military
i see
i see the rot every day
from the federal government
and how it affects
our soldiers
and
their mental health all of that
i see
the federal government
playing mind games with us
their people
they're attacking
their own people
they
why would you
keep on
dealing with somebody that plays mind
games with you
why why wouldn't you just cut the cord
like
like an abusive boyfriend
i can fix him
i can fix him he's not that bad i can
fix him
i
had a friend commit suicide because of
that
and then look at look at the suicide
rate in the u.s
like
it's
untenable that i i don't see a point in
dealing with people that don't care
about you
don't
seek your consent for
these edicts
that they're foisting upon you
so why are we
why are we still in this abusive
relationship
that's the question i would like to pose
to you
and
i think that's uh all i have to say
thank you uh i mean you know there's a
good question why are we in an abusive
relationship
but you know the question i have is um
this abusive relationship has thrown so
many carrots to the state it bought not
probably about
90 percent of our military is paid
through the federal government
our equipment everything that we have
here in the state
i wonder what happens all that our
airplanes are it's all owned by the
federal government
and how we would protect the sovereignty
of
new hampshire real quick in 30 seconds
could you answer that the sovereignty of
new hampshire buy our own
buy our own
what pistol about so you're saying maybe
raise taxes on everybody and just not
necessarily i would
you can ask the citizenry for donations
for
like
you don't have you can
look at um back when
we had uh
was it
back when we had militias right
uh state militias citizen citizen
militias right
so
it was it was
the
community
who bought and and
bought our our weaponry look at um
uh um what are they the um
look at the barracks all the armories
right those were community owned
the people owned those weapons
the the
the people own
the us government's weapons
all right thank you
appreciate your guy answered that on
thank you i mean i own a lot of guns but
my guns don't stand up to a lot of the
other weapons that would come in
what's that
for that one oh you're going to teach me
no no no no no not that not that thank
you well so
what happens
so um what happens if
the federal government nukes new
hampshire right just just play ball with
me here all right i'd rather not get
into it he said she said better no no no
no no no i'm just asking a question on
militia because the militia
uh under the if you brought that up and
i didn't want to go into it even more
because if you read the us constitution
uh the section two the duties of the
commander-in-chief that he has the
authority to call on
the militias to uh in the seven colonies
or the nine colonies or whatever it was
the seven i think it was that's why i
carry the constitution because i'm not
perfect back in and pull it out just
like the rest of us right so i'm saying
is that it's already in that
constitution u.s constitution about the
militia so our militia could be pulled
very simple
for that united states not if we cut the
court we have no okay all right no
i just want to let you know what it says
in the u.s constitution under section 2
commander-in-chief's responsibility you
had a question
yes
thank you
are you aware that i believe that in the
new hampshire state constitution that
the
militia is
at the
behest of the governor
so even if we were to secede from the
union successfully and have and and
have our own sovereign state
that our governor actually
if we were to if we were to to follow
this constitution and this constitution
would still be at the behest of the of
the the governor
yes but we have a more direct line of
communication with our governor and we
do have a more direct you're correct and
we don't have we don't have to buy with
49 other states and territories for the
attention
of our governor
okay thank you we want to move on thank
you for taking my question
absolutely okay uh chair recognize
kyle what's our uh what's your last name
okay don't worry about it one minute
thank you
oh can i get a spelling on that kyle
please
r o u
s
thank you
thank you for having me i'll try to be
as quick as i can
i want to uh take the opportunity to be
the
needless parent everyone uh not everyone
i suppose but i often get the reputation
of having which is to directly
uh
try to ask why we're here for cacr32
which is about adding the option for
voting for the citizenry of new
hampshire to secede from the the union
and it's up to you fine folks to decide
whether that
that option even ends up on the ballot
in november
if am i correct in that yes okay
so given that uh
there are a lot of reasons for seceding
there are a lot of reasons for not
succeeding and all these abuses and all
the information that we can bring out
is
unfortunately i think not material for
what we're trying to do here today we're
trying to convince you guys to let
the new hampshire residents
have our own voice in that position and
we we get to then come forward and
debate with each other and the rest of
the world and the rest of the union to
figure out where we're going to end up
at the end of all of that
so i want to appeal to this council
to ask you why we
why you might vote against this
if now is not the time
then win is if the timing is bad then
why is california moving forward with
their own
i'm sorry i'm sorry no we're just trying
to organize so we get uh cards oh yeah
okay
go ahead we apologize go ahead yeah um
so if not now then then when
if not us the people of new hampshire
making this decision
then who
exactly what should be our goals in
trying to add this or not add this to
the ballot uh i believe there is no
better time because honestly i'll have
to ask you guys how many times you want
to do this because just because
we shut down cacr 32 this year for this
ballot
almost guaranteed we're going to be back
and we're going to try again because we
really really doubt that things are
going to get that much better in two
years so give us the opportunity to to
voice our opinions as soon as possible
and we can work towards
how that's going to work out in the
future putting this measure onto the
ballot
is
allows us to have a say over our own
future and there's a lot of valid
questions about like what do we do about
the carrots how do we avoid the sticks
but the question is
what are we trying to do
are you trying to grab for carrots are
you trying to avoid the sticks are we
trying to have our own moral position on
on being able to give the voice to the
people of new hampshire one way or
another if they vote against it then i'm
sure all of us here would
do our best to try to convince them that
this is the right path but if there's
not enough people to carry it
so be it but cacr 32 is about
giving us that voice and allowing us
that option to move into the future
okay uh you're uh over three minutes oh
am i right sorry one minute went fast
but yeah i did sorry
if you can close up uh yeah i'm done
that's good okay thank you are there any
questions uh no
not seeing any thank you
thank you uh cheer recognize uh melissa
oh wait is that no
okay i'm sorry
um
was that is that
chase chase kelly is that right
my friend
how are you
good
and you support the bill
yes
yeah thank you so much for being here
all day for
i know you guys worked so hard
um i just came across this today i
didn't come here purposely for this so
i'm not in like any uh you know
planning for all this in fact one of my
friends asked me earlier what do i think
and i was like you know i believe in
united we stand as one nation
as a strong nation but after
listening to all these testimonies
and i can relate to my
soul is i came from vietnam a communist
country and my father spent seven years
in a communist prison as a political
prisoner a powu
and
you know i
can tell you right now i'm living in
china not in america right here right
now
in the past few years both on and
offline
everything happened here
monitoring speech
freedom of speech is almost gone
and
since the i was in dc on january 6
and on and offline i have been
persecuted
and october 13
when the nine people got arrested i was
like right there with my camera
i witnessed seven of those
uh arrests which is
totally
totally uncalled for ridiculous
and i'm like i felt like i'm in the
nasty time the jews and the nazi time
it's that scary like if you breathe a
bit
strong you get arrested
it's that scary and right now i'm scared
for my own life
because
these things that they call vaccine that
nobody responsible for the injection to
your body which is to weaken the immune
system of the people that leading to
stuff to kill us
and the eye vex i mean whatever the name
the medicine is if you mention that on
facebook or any social media you get ben
why is that you know and
they already have this new technology
that is as thick as a hair
they can inject into our body is it's a
chip that is controlled it's like the
666 thing that's going around it's gonna
be implemented we're gonna be tracked
and traced like rats and right now i'm
worried where am i gonna be able to go
shopping for food
where can i get on to travel to do
things that i need to do i'm worrying
about that because i'm not gonna get on
that call vaccine which is not a vaccine
and a lot of my friends lost their job
persecuted all kinds of sleep abuse on
and offline
so
and in the bible i'm a christian and in
the bible
jesus said that the temple to serve god
is our body our body is a temple to
serve god and nobody can trespass that
nobody if i can get you to stay with um
oh so real quick so new hampshire a pine
tree riot started in 1772
we liberated this country
so this idea of getting divorced from
the federal government
starting from new hampshire too it's a
living or that spirit and i'm thankful
to be living here and you heard a lot
today about the word peaceful resolution
peaceful solution
this is the way that we need to give an
opportunity for the people to voice up
their opinion yes or no at least i have
a chance to say it and then we rest with
that if we don't give the people that
chance
then you know violence is gonna come
because you hear a lot of peaceful today
translation without peaceful process
there will be violation and i'm all for
peace and i'm here almost
the last weeks and this week for um
election law and other stuff in a
peaceful way to try to to keep our state
our country together but in the airplane
when the pilot the airplane go down it
has a thing to eject so you can get out
safe you don't want to die with the
whole plane right the whole country is
dying right now so why do we want to die
together so let's save ourselves
thank you so i'm asking you to please
support this bill
thank you
[Applause]
okay the chair recognize uh ian freeman
i haven't seen ian in a while
oh there he is right there
how are you hey thanks for having me uh
one reason might because the federal
government raided my house earlier uh in
2021 over bitcoin of all things but
that's not why i'm here
i've been in favor of independence for
new hampshire for multiple
administrations this doesn't have to do
with joe biden or trump or any of these
people
new hampshire said goodbye to one tyrant
back in the 1700s
and we can do it again today
you know i came in on mr deshaz's
analysis of this particular situation
and i have to wonder did he even read
cacr32 because we addressed pretty clear
he brought up article 7 of the new
hampshire state constitution's bill of
rights and
acted as though there was some sort of a
conflict
it's two sentences i'm just going to
read it for the record
the people of this state have the sole
and exclusive right of governing
themselves as a free sovereign and
independent state
and do forever hereafter shall exercise
and enjoy every power jurisdiction and
right pertaining thereto which is not or
may not hereafter be by them expressly
delegated to the united states of
america in congress assembled that's a
state sovereignty
provision that says we're sovereigns
and
when new hampshire joined the union why
would we have joined something that we
couldn't leave
if we decided we'd had enough
in fact
that brings me to a different article
in the u.s constitution
uh
amendment number 10
which says i'm just paraphrasing this
one
it says unless something has been
expressly delegated
to the u.s government some sort of right
then they are retained by the states
the u.s constitution has rules for
joining the union which makes sense
you wouldn't want to just allow anybody
to jump into a union they have to have a
process
but the u.s constitution
does not have anything about leaving
that means mr duchess that that is
left to the states to decide
so if this state decides
by voting more than two-thirds
that it's time to say goodbye and
peacefully that's also in this
proposed amendment that it will be
peaceful
then we can do that and it doesn't
matter what some supreme court justices
said who lincoln by the way uh put into
place in the 1800s
so we can do this and there's very
little that they can do about it if
we're res if we're ready to go what are
they going to do to stop us
so we have both article 7 in our new
hampshire constitution which is all
about our state sovereignty and then of
course there's article 10 which is the
right to revolution it is clear by the
new hampshire constitution that we have
the right to say goodbye and break up
with this abuser thank you
thank you um
okay please
[Applause]
happy to take any questions i helped
write the amendment are there any
questions for eon
yeah that's right okay
no i know you'd have some good ones
there but uh
okay i would love to hear his question
no i i can't
he's can we wait he testified no i'm not
gonna break the rules
i mean i could break the rule but i'm
not gonna um i have a question for you
mr baldesaro if you don't mind okay um
is there a chance that this could be uh
continue to another hearing in a morning
session where the full committee will be
here no okay yeah this is it for us uh
we'll exact tomorrow and i have one more
hearing tomorrow
uh in the morning then we'll start
executing what i have left there to
finish up for
crossover and everything else
my committee will be done with 19 bills
well i appreciate you when you do
execute this just keep in mind
even if you're against independence even
if you're in favor of the empire
in favor of continuing the union you
should vote in favor to ought to pass
this bill to let the people of new
hampshire decide because if you think
it's a terrible idea to leave surely you
think the people of new hampshire agree
with you and so therefore they would
vote it down uh if it came to their vote
in november
what's to be afraid of no we're not
afraid of nothing right but thank you so
i'd like to hear at least i'm not
anyways good uh representative another
maureen here you're not afraid either
just quick comment uh
it sounds like the chair is planning to
exact this and some of you know the
process we have hearings and then we get
all this testimony then we exec and we
discuss the testimony in all kinds of
perspectives so i i do not know what's
going to happen in exact session i i
really i just don't know uh how
all the folks are going to vote we'll
talk about it
but in terms of the process
however it comes out of committee
if it goes
to the
it will go to the full house
and
sometimes it goes on to what we call
consent that may or may not happen we'll
find out tomorrow the consent calendar
occurs when
uh uh this is
a measure
this is this is a cacr interesting good
to know thank you when
just understand that the full house will
have a chance to uh
uh
speak to this to or people at the fellow
so i i anticipate that there'll be
representatives who will take this to
the floor i suspect so and uh give
expression to the whole house uh the
perspective their perspectives and pass
on your perspective so
we have a hearing we have exact session
tomorrow it will go to the full floor in
there and there will people i suspect
will give voice
to your perspectives to the whole house
so just so you know that that's in the
works and will happen question on the
process is it true that because it's a
constitutional amendment that there
there has to be a roll call though yes
on this yes okay that'll be interesting
because then we'll get to see you right
you'll get to see uh
right
who supports people being able to speak
on this because if you vote against it
that means you don't well ian you know
me a long time and uh i'm going to tell
you right now i'm i'm on the fence on
this i don't know you know
well let me know what it's going to take
to get yours
it's not going to take anything i mean
i'm a liberty guy myself but i also know
in my mind if i was sleeping and
dreaming this is a great concept
this is awesome i would love to see it
but when i wake up in the morning and
realize it just can't happen
you know i don't believe it yeah
and there's too many ifs and what's in
all that in in in raising taxes it's not
like back in the 1700s you're raising
taxes and every and then services that
got to be supported and money that how
do we figure out to make up for that
federal money that's coming in because
we've been eating the carrot for many
many years the same thing with our
militia so there's a lot involved here
that most people don't look at the whole
puzzle
okay uh you know
what's that
well i'm just saying i'm a reality type
of guy yeah i mean you know
the question is should we be in the seat
to vote the question is should the
people decide that's all you have to
figure out i think they should thank you
okay thank you appreciate it okay um
did you melissa
is there melissa econom from max makers
newton
i'm melissa welcome uh one minute please
so
please not
wait oh i can't hear you say what i said
please bear with me because i'm not a
speaker oh don't worry about take your
time i'm not either can i get a spelling
on her name yeah
it is e-c-o-n-o
economics economics
thank you
some of us are just as nervous as you
are so don't worry about it go ahead i
don't know
um first of all i want to say to you
that um i liked everything that you said
and um i wish we could fix our
government i wish we could fix our
federal government i really do
i just don't see it happening um
i honestly see the united states going
in the direction where we'll we will no
longer be free
and we'll not no longer be free citizens
and this should concern all of us um
it's really scary what's going to be
what's going to go down
if we just keep going in this direction
it's scary for me
and my kids this isn't even really
mostly about me it's about the children
i'm sorry i i
i'm so scared for our children the what
kind of what kind of society are they
going to grow up in that's what
really really concerns me
our federal government has never had our
best interests at heart and
they never will
let's just face it they never will
we could have the opportunity
opportunity for our children to grow up
in a free society if we could become our
own sovereign nation
and if you look at history you can
clearly see
that the elites of this world have been
slowly slowly taking away all of our
freedoms
that our veterans have fought and died
for
collectively we can we can
make this happen we can work together we
can make this happen we can do it we can
do it
um
i know there's a lot of like you said
there's a lot of different things like
you're not thinking about this you're
not thinking about that yeah and i get
that i i feel the same way
but
we could make this happen as a community
we really really could
um
buck minister fuller said
you don't change a system by fighting it
you change a system by creating
something new that makes the existing
system obsolete
and we can create something new and i
just want to say please support c8
cr32 so at least it can be on the
november ballot so at least the people
can decide
thank you for listening to me you did a
great job melissa uh no
i can tell you um
it's really nervous
you know um i was glad to see somebody
come here up here from londonderry
because i can tell you i've got all the
emails i got
were from all around you know the state
or around the country on this issue here
not only one for my district in
londonderry so apparently
you know what i mean it's not that
important or they're well working
because it's a conservative district i
don't know what happened why
but
at the polls i'm going to ask you here
the last six seven years we we've
elected people that are voting against
second amendment issues first amendment
want to take over control voting issues
for the whole state instead of
going against new hampshire constitution
shouldn't we be making a difference at
the polls we're voting in the same
people over and over
that are sticking it to us
i i think that
what's happening at the at the polls
is we don't have much of many choices
they give us these choices
you know and um if you if you want to
run for something you either have to
have like a lot of money or you have to
have i don't have a lot of money okay
well i mean
maybe at a local level yeah you don't
have to but i'm talking about like say
the governor you know um somebody that
that's
high up huh state
representatives don't have a lot of
money run run for office yeah i would
love to um i just don't i don't
i don't i don't know enough people
that's the thing like me i'm just this
little person here
and um i'm i mean i'm a strong person
don't get me wrong but
i don't have a lot a large following and
i feel like you might have to have a
large following you know and i don't
have that so i don't know that a lot of
people would even vote for me but anyway
i just think that
a lot of the voting is set up and it's
set up for us to feel you're either you
know you're you're you have the left you
have the right you have the libertarian
in the middle and people are like well
i'm not going to vote for the
libertarian because one of the i'm just
going to vote for the
worst of the less evils you i mean the
best of the less evils
and so
that's what happens and it's gonna
happen over and over and over again it's
never gonna change and if we want our
kids to grow up
in a free society if we don't want our
kids to be chipped or or transhumanized
or anything like that
we really really need to to take a look
at this in our souls and our hearts
everybody here you all have to know
that you can feel it in your heart and
your soul that
something is going wrong something is is
going in a direction that
we won't be able to
to fight
we won't it's the elites well i thank
you very much
sorry okay
so i went on i didn't mean to ramble
like that no no you're not you're doing
great good uh we have our processes here
and i'm not i have to ask you a question
to be able to say anything
uh representative duchez knows the
process that's why he can't really
engage so
my ques my question to you
so to speak if i can i'll answer it if i
can
did you know that
a cacr is a heavy left you need 60 it's
very difficult to do i put one in last
year
came out of committee 15-3 against
although i thought it was a great idea i
have one in this year in another
committee i know it's a very heavy lift
and uh i'm not going to hold my breath
on it
uh i'm asking if you knew these things
and and i do
two-thirds right
yeah
but also to finish my question to you
sorry because it has to be a question uh
did you know that
your movement so to speak the the folks
who think like you the liberty folk
types of people
have
had a very significant impact on
numerous bills over the last few years
and
did you know that you should not be
discouraged or angry overly angry i hope
if this doesn't work out this particular
time well we'll know soon but uh
did you know that you folks have had a
lot of influence on a lot of measures
i didn't know that we had a lot of
influence on a lot of measures however i
did however i do know that we do need
two-thirds of the votes
um i don't think a lot of people
even know about this and i say that
because i've talked to
so many people like because i'll just go
up to someone random i know i'm shy but
i'll go up to someone random at the
grocery store and be like what do you
think about this and this you know what
i mean and and people are very concerned
they're like well what does this look
like what does that look like if we do
that a lot of people do not know
that this even exists that they do not
even know you'd be surprised they don't
know that new hampshire is trying to
secede
so
we would
if we could like make it more known
and
shout out on the rooftops hey everybody
like and and put something in place too
not just say okay we're just gonna do
this we need something in place to
replace
the system
we need like okay a plan for health care
a plan for like you said social security
medic we need those plans in place
but we can do it
we we we can definitely do it
okay thank you thank you sorry no no no
no don't be sorry we've got another
question i'm just trying to move it
along because i have one more card left
and we have another question sit down
don't
one more question oh i'm sorry
sorry thank you mr chairman thank you
for taking my question would you mind
hanging around until this is done and we
are adjourned
sure great thank you
okay well thank you very much you did a
great job
okay the chair the last uh speaker
clarence gardner welcome clarence
i missed lunch today so i'm uh hopefully
i'll be able to catch dinner tonight
thank you i'm clarence gardner from
where
glad to be represented by miss leah
cushman
i did run for state house several years
ago
did not win but
in my fantasy of winning one of my
things i wanted to do was be on this
committee because this is important work
because of me right
okay okay
i would have been glad to be under your
wing
i wanted to object to
three things that i've heard here today
according to my understanding
one is the term perpetual union was
brought up
if you look in the dictionary under
perpetual it means lasting forever
you can't write something on down on
paper and say it's going to last forever
perpetual at that time or in that
meaning
according to
my understanding is that it meant there
was no fixed end to it
that doesn't mean it can't end
another is the word treason was brought
up
and that word's been thrown around a lot
in the last few years
the united states constitution defines
treason
if i recall correctly there's two things
making war against the united states and
counterfeiting its money
nobody's suggesting doing either of
those
the word rebellion was used
comparing it to children rebelling
against their parents
i'm pretty sure every time if you look
in a constitution or statutes or
whatever when they talk about rebellion
against the united states the word armed
is always in front of that word
and beyond that
this is a this is an important question
we're talking about
and
i want to point out that
when when the question of
leaving britain peacefully or otherwise
was brought up
or even after that when they were
debating what kind of government we
should have
those debates took
place
over the course of months
and the people got involved
um
as people have said the point here is
not to dis to debate whether we should
do this or whether we shouldn't as
whether to vote on it um and if the vote
does get on the ballot
i would hope that
a lot of
public debate happens
we have a lot more
capability to do that than they did back
then you know when they were hoping
every little newspaper in town might
print the latest pamphlet
we've got facebook we've got
twitter et cetera et cetera and
those are good platforms for debate if
they will allow it
thank you thank you
are there any questions for
clearance
seeing no questions uh thank you very
much
okay uh is
is there anyone else uh before i close
this out that
wanted to speak and didn't uh sign up no
i don't see anyone thank you
okay so
that was the question yes the only thing
i would like to do is i would like to be
on the record that um i'm not a free
stater there were a lot of people here
that are not freezing oh i know that
okay i was i was born in concord new
hampshire i've lived here my entire life
my family was in new hampshire
government as
long ago as the 1800s so i just want i
just want you to know that there is a
lot that this represents i never thought
about resigning from the united states
but it's come time
the state the our federal government has
has crossed the line for so many years
it's time to give us the opportunity to
at least demonstrate to them that we're
done
i just wanted to be on the record well i
would think that we would give them the
opportunity to demonstrate it on the
floor of the house whether it comes out
of this committee i tell or ought to
pass
because like i said it's going to take a
large vote
in the house depending on how many
people show up for the hearings
you know at the house
i'm going to go ahead and join uh
adjourn uh close out constitution
amendment 32 and i'll listen say again
we'll we'll close the committee by the
way but who just had something to say
that was me right here mister to your
right oh brody go ahead i just want to
thank everyone for coming and i will say
i will say the many constitutional
scholars that i called about this um
they found this fascinating because this
is kind of the first time any state has
tried to or any entity has tried to
amend its constitution probably since
you know i'm not sure when i discussed
it they weren't sure if any states um
when trying to secede from the union
back during the civil war had actually
tried to do it through amendment and so
this is a it's a very unique thing one
scholar actually the one who i cited um
dr
david um williams he said that he
actually wants to have a number of
scholars maybe look more into this kind
of concept and write some papers on it
so i thought it was a really interesting
intellectual conversation that people
brought to the committee today i i was
you know i was very happy that i got the
opportunity to look into this and i
appreciate everyone coming today yeah i
definitely want to thank everyone
speaking
hey one last thing here
if you this committee i've been on this
committee in 15 years i'm going to my
16th on dealing with constitutional
issues
if many people come in here want a
constitutional amendment
and they want article 5 or you know
there's two ways on that but if you read
the federalist papers why i don't
support that stuff is because nowhere
does it give the rules
many people don't realize the two from
new york
walked out and never got to vote and
there was many silent votes on the
change in the
constitution
that
i myself do not want to happen again so
keep that in mind i mean that's why i
voted against a lot of this over the
and a half years
we started the rochester 912 group in
rochester new hampshire we started it in
2009 and i want you to know that we have
this is the proof
of what we've been doing you
[Applause]
don't
stop tonight
thank you
real great